hey everyone welcome to this video on
aws full course we'll begin this full
course video with what aws is and how
aws services work and we will be looking
at a bunch of aws services like ec2
lambda s3 im cloud formation ecs route
53 elastic beam stock vpc sagemaker
cloudfront auto scaling and redshift
after this we will do a comparison of
popular cloud providers that is aws
azure and gcp moving further we will see
how kubernetes is implemented on aws and
how to become a solution architect we
will also guide you through aws
certification exams and in which we have
explained how to choose the right
certification for your career we will
then conclude this video by discussing
the essential interview questions and
answers to help every individual crack
an interview by the end of this video i
can assure you that all your aws career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experienced aws specialist sam and rahul
together we will take you through the
various topics of aws
so let's start with an exciting video on
aws full course but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from simplylearn
meet rob he runs an online shopping
portal the portal started with a modest
number of users but has recently been
seeing a surge in the number of visitors
on black friday and other holidays the
portal saw so many visitors that the
servers were unable to handle the
traffic and crashed
is there a way to improve performance
without having to invest in a new server
wondered rob
a way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
market
before we see how aws can solve rob's
problem let's have a look at how aws
reach the position it is at now
aws was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website
in 2006 its first cloud services
offering was introduced in 2016 aws
surpassed its 10 billion revenue target
and now aws offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the aws cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 percent of the global market
now let's talk about what is aws
aws or amazon web service is a secure
cloud computing platform that provides
computing power database networking
content storage and much more
the platform also works with a pay as
you go pricing model which means you
only pay for how much of the service is
offered by aws you use
some of the other advantages of aws are
security aws provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
os language database and other services
easy to use
users can host applications quickly and
securely
scalable depending on user requirements
applications can be scaled up or down
aws provides a wide range of services
across various domains what if rob
wanted to create an application for his
online portal aws provides compute
services that can support the app
development process from start to finish
from developing deploying running to
scaling the application up or down based
on the requirements
the popular services include ec2 aws
lambda amazon light cell and elastic
bean stock for storing website data rob
could use aws storage services that
would enable him to store access govern
and analyze data to ensure that costs
are reduced agility is improved and
innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include amazon s3 ebs s3 glacier and
elastic file storage
rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw services which he can
then optimize and manage
popular services in this domain include
amazon rds dynamodb and redshift
if rob's businesses took off and he
wanted to separate his cloud
infrastructure or scale up his work
requests and much more he would be able
to do so with the networking services
provided by aws
some of the popular networking services
include amazon vpc amazon route 53 and
elastic load balancing
other domains that aws provide services
in are analytics blockchain containers
machine learning internet of things and
so on
and there you go
that's aws for you in a nutshell now
before we're done let's have a look at a
quiz
which of these services are incorrectly
matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comments section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
amazon voucher
several companies around the world have
found great success with aws companies
like netflix twitch linkedin facebook
and bbc have taken advantage of the
services offered by aws to improve their
business efficiency
and thanks to their widespread usage aws
professionals are in high demand they're
highly paid and earn up to more than 127
thousand dollars per annum once you're
aws certified you could be one of them
too hello everyone let me introduce
myself as sam a multi-platform cloud
architect and trainer and i'm so glad
and i'm equally excited to talk and walk
you through the session about what aws
is and talk to you about some services
and offerings and about how companies
get benefited by migrating their
applications and infra into aws so
what's aws let's talk about that now
before that let's talk about how life
was without any cloud provider and in
this case how life was without aws so
let's walk back and picture how things
were back in 2000 which is not so long
ago but a lot of changes a lot of
changes for better had happened since
that time now back in 2000 a request for
a new server is not an happy thing at
all because a lot of
money a lot of validations a lot of
planning are involved in getting a
server online or up and running and even
after we finally got the server it's not
all said and done a lot of optimization
that needs to be done on that server to
make it worth it and get a good return
on investment from that server and even
after we have optimized for a good
return on investment the work is still
not done there will often be a frequent
increase and decrease in the capacity
and you know even news about our website
getting popular and getting more hits
it's still an bittersweet experience
because now i need to add more servers
to the environment which means that it's
going to cost me even more but thanks to
the present day cloud technology if the
same situation were to happen today my
new server it's almost ready and it's
ready instantaneously and with the swift
tools and technologies that amazon is
providing uh in provisioning my server
instantaneously and adding any type of
workload on top of it and making my
storage and server secure you know
creating a durable storage where data
that i store in the cloud never gets
lost with all that features amazon has
got our back so let's talk about what is
aws there are a lot of definitions for
it but i'm going to put together a
simple and a precise definition as much
as possible now let me iron that out
cloud still runs on and hardware all
right and there are certain features in
that infrastructure in that cloud
infrastructure that makes cloud cloud or
that makes aws a cloud provider now we
get all the services all the
technologies all the features and all
the benefits that we get in our local
data center like you know security and
compute capacity and databases and in
fact you know we get even more cool
features like content caching in various
global locations around the planet but
again out of all the features the best
part is that i get or we get everything
on a pay as we go model the less i use
the less i pay and the more i use the
less i pay per unit very attractive
isn't it right and that's not all the
applications that we provision in aws
are very reliable because they run on a
reliable infrastructure and it's very
scalable because it runs on an on-demand
infrastructure and it's very flexible
because of the designs and because of
the design options available for me in
the cloud let's talk about how all this
happened aws was launched in 2002 after
the amazon we know as the online retail
store wanted to sell their remaining or
unused infrastructure as a service or as
an offering for customers to buy and use
it from them you know sell
infrastructure as a service the idea
sort of clicked and aws launched their
first product first product in 2006
that's like four years after the idea
launch and in 2012 they held a big sized
customer even to gather inputs and
concerns from customers and they were
very dedicated in making those requests
happen and that habit is still being
followed it's still being followed as a
reinvent by aws and at 2015 amazon
announced its revenue to be 4.6 billion
and in 2015 through 2016 aws launched
products and services that helped
migrate customer services into aws well
there were products even before but this
is when a lot of focus was given on
developing migrating services and in the
same year that's in 2016 amazon's
revenue was 10 billion and not but not
the least as we speak amazon has more
than 100 products and services available
for customers and get benefited from
all right let's talk about the services
that are available in amazon let's start
with this product called s3 now s3 is a
great tool for internet backup and it's
it's the cheapest storage option in the
object storage category and not only
that the data that we put in s3 is
retrievable from the internet s3 is
really cool and we have other products
like migration and data collection and
data transfer products and here we can
not only collect data seamlessly but
also in a real-time way
monitor the data or analyze the data
that's being received that they're cool
products like aws data transfers
available that helps achieve that and
then we have products like ec2 elastic
compute cloud that's an resizable
computer where we can anytime anytime
after the size of the computer based on
the need or based on the forecast then
we have simple notification services
systems and tools available in amazon to
update us with notifications through
email or through sms now anything
anything can be sent through email or
through sms if you use that service it
could be alarms or it could be service
notifications if you want stuff like
that and then we have some security
tools like kms key management system
which uses aes 256 bit encryption to
encrypt our data at rest then we have
lambda a service for which we pay only
for the time in seconds seconds it takes
to execute our code and we're not paying
for the infrastructure here it's just
the seconds the program is going to take
to execute the code for the short
program we'll be paying in milliseconds
if it's a bit bigger program we'll be
probably paying in 60 seconds or 120
seconds but that's not cheap lot simple
and lots cost effective as against
paying for service on an ugly basis
which a lot of other services are well
that's cheap but using lambda is a lot
cheaper than that and then we have
services like route 53 a dns service in
the cloud and now i do not have to
maintain a dns account somewhere else
and my cloud environment with aws i can
get both in the same place all right let
me talk to you about
how aws makes life easier or how
companies got benefited by using aws as
their it provider or their applications
or for the infrastructure now uniliver
is a company and they had a problem
right and they had a problem and they
picked aws as a solution to their
problem right now this company was sort
of spread across 190 countries and they
were relying on a lot of digital
marketing for promoting their products
and their existing environment their
legacy local environment proved not to
support their changing i.t demands and
they could not standardize their old
environment now they chose to move part
of their applications to aws because
they were not getting what they wanted
in their local environment and since
then you know rollouts were easy
provisioning new applications became
easy and even provisioning
infrastructure became easy and they were
able to do all that in push button
scaling and needless to talk about
backups that are safe and backups that
can be securely accessed from the cloud
as needed now that company is growing
along with aws because of their swift
speed in rolling out deployments and
being able to access secure backups from
various places and generate reports and
in fact useful reports out of it that
helps their business now on the same
lines let me also talk to you about
kellogg's and how they got benefited by
using amazon now kellogg's had a
different problem it's one of its kind
now their business model was very
dependent on an infrared that will help
to analyze data really fast right
because they were running promotions
based on the analyzed data that they get
so they being able to respond to the
analyzed data as soon as possible was
critical or vital in their environment
and luckily sap running on hana
environment is what they needed and uh
you know they picked that service in the
cloud and that's sort of solved the
problem now the company does not
have to deal with uh maintaining their
legacy infra and maintaining their heavy
compute capacity and maintaining their
database locally all that is now moved
to the cloud or they are using cloud as
their i.t service provider and and now
they have a greater and powerful ita
environment that very much complements
their business today i'm going to tell
you how you can become an aws solutions
architect so who is an aw solutions
architect now the main role of an aws
solutions architect is to help you
deploy your applications on the aws
platform now this is nothing but a cloud
computing platform so it's not to say
that you can't deploy your applications
on the cloud computing platform yourself
it's just that when it comes to
organizations the applications that you
need to deploy become a whole lot more
complex that's where an aw solutions
architect can help ever since cloud
computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what an aws solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
aws cloud companies around the world
work on a budget an aw solutions
architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an aw solutions architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw solutions architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure
they're also responsible when it comes
to minimizing risks that an organization
can face when it comes to cloud
computing platforms now they could face
risks like security leaks calculation
mistakes and application down times an
aw solutions architect has to ensure
that these don't happen before we can
talk about how you can become an aws
solutions architect i have some exciting
news for you guys we've launched our own
youtube community you'll get to see a
lot of quizzes polls offers and much
more to make your learning experience a
whole lot more fun you can find all of
this on your subscription feed or you
can also click on the top right corner
right now to get started and let's get
back to how can you become an aws
solutions architect now to become an aw
certified solutions architect you need
to clear the aw certified solutions
architect associate level examination
now here's some details about it the
exam score ranges from 100 to 1000 marks
and the minimum passing score is 720.
however there's a catch the passing
marks are actually set using statistical
analysis so they can be changed based on
how difficult the examination actually
is the exam fee is 150 dollars and you
can also take a practice examination
which costs 20 dollars now regardless of
the examination you take be it solutions
architect sysops administrator or
developer any associate level
examination costs hundred and fifty
dollars for the professional level
examination it's three hundred dollars
now if you want to learn more about the
aws certifications i suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch our
video aw certifications in 10 minutes to
learn more now the exam duration is of
130 minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options on which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options out of which
two of them are correct you can take the
examination in english japanese korean
and simplified chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination
first let's go to google and search for
aws certifications
click on the first link
so on this page you can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications
aws provides
click on architect
and select the awa certified solutions
architect associate certification
click on register now
and here you need to click on the aw
certification account
you can sign in with your amazon account
or create a new one
i already have an amazon account that
i'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
now after that is done you can schedule
a new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam
press continue
and here you need to select your
language
which i'm assuming is english
i'm from india so i don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country your time zone and other details
based on your requirement
and select your preferred month i want
to do it in october
now select search for exam center
select the one that's closest to you
i'm going to select this one
and here you can select the day that you
want to take your test and the time
available i want to do it on 15
select the time that i want and press
continue
now you can go through all the details
here
change them if you want to otherwise you
can press continue
after this is done
close
and here we have the final step
which is the fees
you can enter your details here
and pay now to finish the process
now let's look at an outline of the exam
content now what you're going to see in
the exam are five major domains and here
you have each of the domains with their
respective weightages first you have at
34 percent designing resilient
architectures at 24 percent you have
both defining performant architectures
and specifying secure applications and
architectures at 10 percent you have
designing cost optimized architectures
and at six percent you have defining
operationally excellent architectures
now let's look at each of these domains
in detail now the first domain or design
resilient architectures can be divided
into four parts firstly you need to know
how you can choose reliable or resilient
storage using services like aws s3 aws
glacier and aws ebs then you have how
you can design decoupling mechanisms
using aws services now this is possible
with the help of aws sns now these
aren't the only services that enable
this these are just some of the services
then how you can design a multi-tier
architecture solution now this is
important because you need to know how
you can create a solution that involves
several other services then you need to
know how you can design highly available
and fault tolerant architectures now for
the second domain defining performance
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are aws
rds aws redshift and aws dynamodb the
second step is how you can apply caching
to improve performance a service that
can be used for this is aws elastic
cache third how you can design solutions
with elasticity and scalability you have
aws lambda aws cloud watch and aws data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like aws inspector aws cloudtrail and
aws iam you need to know how to secure
data using cloud hsm and aws may see and
how you can define the networking
infrastructure using cloud front vpc and
elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures firstly you need to know
how you can design cost optimized
compute solutions you can use aws ec2
elastic bean stock lambda and aws light
sale then you need to know how you can
design cost optimized storage solutions
using aws s3 glacier ebs and elastic
file system and the final domain to
define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions that enable
operational excellence now some of the
features are that you perform operations
as code you annotate documentation you
make frequent and small reversible
changes and anticipate and tackle
failures now let's have a look at the
job opportunities when it comes to aws
solutions architects now if you have a
look at this graph you can see that aws
has always provided a lot more job
postings as compared to the other two
giants in the cloud computing domain
which are microsoft azure and google
cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a significant lacking of
experienced personnel when it comes to
aws so i would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in aws so
how can simply learn help you with your
aws certifications now we are on the
simply on home page
and here we are the aws solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aws
solutions architect certification
training course we have 36 hours of
instructor-led training 20 hours of
self-paced learning 16 live demos three
simulation exams three hands-on practice
projects and so much more here our main
emphasis is on making sure that you have
enough hands-on experience with the
services that you crack the examination
at your first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like iam vpc ec2 s3 and so much
more we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery and so on we even have
practice examinations to help you
prepare for the real one let me start
the session with this scenario let's
imagine how life would have been without
spotify for those who are hearing about
spotify for the first time spotify is an
online music service offering and it
offers instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to aws
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before aws let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users cancelling the
subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem aws offered at
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed aws also offered
tools and techniques like storage
lifecycle management and trusted advisor
to properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used aws addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and aws solved spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into how aws became so
successful and the different types of
services that aws provides and what's
the future of cloud and aws in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with aws all right let's
talk about what is aws aws or amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their idea
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database service and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage service
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
software's include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
service because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay as ego system as well as
its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift fd is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 age lower than what was before
general electric
ge is at the moment as we speak
migrating more than 9000 workloads
including 300 desperate erp systems to
aws while reducing its data center
footprint from 34 to 4 over the next
three years similarly howard medical
school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a bit in java.net php node.js
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
lightsail is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon x3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and deter any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility and managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
and lays all your data using standard
sql and your existing business
intelligent tools it also allows you to
run complex analytic queries against
terabyte of structured data using
sophisticated query optimizations and
most of the results they generally come
back in seconds all right let's quickly
talk about some more services that aws
offers there are a lot more services
that aws provides but are we going to
look at some more services that are
widely used aws application discovery
services help enterprise customers plan
migration projects by gathering
information about their on-premises data
centers in a planning a data center
migration can involve thousands of
workloads they are often deeply
interdependent server utilization data
and dependency mapping are important
early first step in migration process
and this aws application discovery
service collects and presents
configuration usage and behavior data
from your servers to help you better
understand your workloads route 53 it's
a network and content delivery service
it's an highly available and scalable
cloud domain name system or dns service
and amazon route 53 is fully compliant
with ipv6 as well elastic load balancing
it's also a network and content delivery
service elastic load balancing
automatically distributes incoming
application traffic across multiple
targets such as amazon ec2 instance
containers and ip addresses it can
handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones away auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using im
you can create and manage aws users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to aws resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of aws well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's what in store for aws in the
future as years pass by we're gonna have
a variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back a lot or greater focus will be
given to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about their
likes and dislikes and you know give
them the appropriate product as per
their need all right though the setup
and the environment it sort of looks
complicated we don't have to worry
because aws has tools and technologies
which can help us to achieve it now
we're going to use services like route
53 services like cloudwatch ec2 s3 and
lot more and all these put together are
going to give an application that's
fully functionable and an application
that's going to receive the information
like using the services like route 53
cloudwatch ec2 and s3 we're going to
create an application and that's going
to meet our need so back to our original
requirement all i want is to deploy a
web application for a product that keeps
our users updated about the happenings
and the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we are also going to
use route 53 for dns and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm going
to use elastic bean stock for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see gsg sign up
and the environment name is gsg signup
environment 1. let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if i
go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right
and some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind an load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's it's not a fancy url right
it's an amazon given url a dynamic url
so let's put this url behind our dns
let's do that
so go to services go to route53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url choose from over 300 in demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more let
me help you understand about aws ec2 a
compute servers in the cloud through
this video somewhere far in the country
a scientist has a lab far in the woods
and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked this
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend aws as
you see on the screen aws was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment aws has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in need is welcomed by
the new and trendy id technology aws and
sure enough his new aws friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new happy-faced aws
friend talked to this scientist about
aws ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new innovations in
i.t and in cloud that he had been
missing all these days so his new friend
aws started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing hardware or
provisioning in aws and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with enterprise great security that's
beyond imagination in on premises and if
this still does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world
now this really made the scientist to
get excited especially when he thought
about working from home working from
home there is nothing like it isn't it
now this person the scientist is not
tied up to a particular environment he
can work from home work on the fly work
from anywhere still the data and
everything else in his id environment is
secure and safe now let's move to the
next level of discussion let's talk
about what is ec2 and some of the use
cases of ec2 and this use case we're
going to talk about or this architecture
we're going to talk about it notifies a
group of users about a new letter and
the components or resources this
architecture would need the first ec2
instance then sns a simple notification
service and
coupling ec2 and s3 service together
that's all it would require to get an
architecture that notifies a group of
users about a new newsletter and now i
think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration network management tools media
services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for developers for providing secure and
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are gonna
like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns and ec2 for
compute and s3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very cheered up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter all right so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is amazon mission
image that's really the softwares and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances and how many instances do
i want you know which subnet do i want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate
behavior of the instance and do i want
to update any patches when the instance
starts running all those pieces of
information go in here when we configure
the instance
and then the first three steps is really
about the os volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called security group for
the ec2 instance and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
summit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an new computer or a new vm
or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined amis are called amazon
provided amis the other one would be
custom amis the amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal called ami marketplace
there we get like thousands of amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
or lots of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power i should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some applications that performs well
with cache or through cache or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cache for
re-reading or for processing you know
for lengthy processing stuff like that
for those type of application this
memory optimized instance that comes
with in memory cache is a very good use
case and the third one is the instant
that comes with the gpu otherwise called
gpu optimized gpu stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimize is the
fourth option just like the name says
this is a very good use case for storage
servers and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose if you're not
particular about the family then you
generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual cpu and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
compute optimized memory optimized gpu
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
i have a lot of options about
purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a reserved instance do i want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where i'm
going to put the ec2 instance do i want
and public ipads assigned to it do i
want an iam role attached to it im role
is authentication what kind of
authentication am i going to provide and
the shutdown behavior the shutdown
behaviors include do i want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do i want to
simply terminate the instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance a
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or advanced tab under configure instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage which is free or i can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called ebs which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else i can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is free subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
uh provisioned volume is it going to be
and general purpose volume is it going
to be a magnetic volume stuff like that
there are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the disk will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options are all these inputs are
received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed some time back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have 700 or 1000
vms running and security groups are the
actual firewall that sits in front of
ec2 instance and it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where i can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on port numbers and based on ip
address from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an ec2 instance but hold on we're not
done yet when we're about to launch or
before the amazon console actually
launches the ec2 instance it's going to
give us an option to create a keypad
remember i said it's key pair you know
key pair is two things one is public and
private the private key is downloaded by
the user and is kept with the user and
the public key is used by amazon to
confirm the identity of the user so just
go ahead and download the private key
and keep it for yourself and this
private key gets downloaded as a dot pem
file it's a format of the file and it
gets downloaded as dot pem file and our
next step is to access the ec2 instance
and because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's linux instance and that's going to
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we're trying to
access and linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put the
generator and we can start using it to
access the linux instance now you might
ask well i understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called ppk and puttygen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pen key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot ppk
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open puti and
try to log in and the way to login is to
open putty put that ip address here and
then click on auth
you know this is where we would input
the file that we have created so click
on auth and then click on browse and
find the dot ppk file that we have
converted and stored browse it and
upload it and then click on open now
that's going to open up a login screen
for us and the amis comes with a default
username depending on the ami that we
have picked the username might differ in
our case we have picked an ami for which
the username is ec2 hyphen user and this
is the default by the way let's put the
username ec2hyphen user and hit enter
and that's going to open up the linux
instance using cli there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that will explain it little later right
so we have successfully launched an ec2
instance and
yeah give yourself a pat on your back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution so let's actually talk
about how we can notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service or a product in amazon that
helps us to notify customers through
email so navigate to sns in your account
and create a topic and we're going to
use this topic for public notification
so let's make it public and then add
subscribers to it now these subscribers
these subscribers are the people who you
want to be notified about the newsletter
so we already have the email database in
there add them to the subscribers list
and then they will start getting new
newsletters as and when we post them to
the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 where you can store content
and in that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how it
will be set up and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
aws instance are in sync so we put some
content in the s3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because s3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
s3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the s3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me welcome you
to this new video learning where we're
going to learn about lambda one day at
office in a growing company there was
discussion going on between two it
personal it was about the new role that
his colleague jessica has taken benjamin
the guy standing here wants to know
about it and jessica's job is new
different and dynamic and interesting
too she scale and manage servers and
operating systems and apply security
patches onto them and monitor all of
these at the same time to ensure the
best quality for application is given to
the users and benjamin was awestruck
with the amount of work jessica is doing
and with the time it would take to
complete all of them but jessica being a
very dynamic person very suitable for
the job said it was easy for her to
handle all of it and even more but that
easiness on the job did not last longer
as the environment grew more and more it
being a startup company jessica was
getting drained and was not really happy
about all her job as she used to be
jessica's manual way of scaling and
environment did not last long and she
was also finding out that she missed to
scale down some of the resources and
it's costing her a lot she needs to pay
for the service that she was not at all
using she sort of felt that she was at
the end of the road and there was no way
out from this manual task she was very
desperate and that's when benjamin
suggested something and that brought
back the peace and joy jessica initially
had benjamin suggested about a service
called lambda that can ease the work
that jessica is doing at the moment and
lambda as happy as it looks like it's a
solution that solves the manual
repetitive work and lot more and lambda
introduced itself as the problem solver
and started to explain the following
things the very same thing that we're
going to learn about in this series so
in this section we're going to learn
about the features of aws lambda and
we're going to talk about what lambda is
and then we're going to talk about where
lambda is being used in the it or in the
cloud environment as we speak and then
we're going to talk about how lambda
works and some use cases of lambda and
we're going to be particularly
discussing about the use case about
automatically backing up the data that's
put in the cloud storage let's talk
about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to lambda and lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working aws lambda also automatically
scales our application by a running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in lambda is metered
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with aws lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
aws lambda now lambda is one of the
servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that aws provides along with
ec2 ebs elastic load balancer lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
aws and lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with aws
lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that aws lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by aws lambda are node.js
java c-sharp go and python and lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c sharp etc now let's talk about
where is lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for lambda and there
are many ways aws lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
aws lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an s3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
sd bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and aws lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that would be reading the data it
could be an pc it could be an apple
machine it could be an android phone it
could be an apple phone it could be a
tablet what not so based on the devices
different formats lambda can get
triggered and convert the video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires another use case
for lambda is to analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's uh added
into the kinesis stream to feed into the
amazon environment and lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by
businesses for later analysis and some
of the companies that have gotten
tremendous benefit using lambda are
thomson routers bench links
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works in other words let's
look at how the complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way so here clients send
data clients send data to lambda and
clients could be anyone who's sending
requests to aws lambda it could be an
application or other amazon web services
that's sending data to the lambda and
lambda receives the request and
depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the run
times the system tools the system
libraries and any other settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charged for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and
as a system to backup the data as soon
as the data is uploaded which is a near
real time backup now a near real time
manual backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real time
that's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there's no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use aws lambda and
set things up so aws lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that aws lambda comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where the
data will be uploaded and the other one
is and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an iam
role and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an lambda function
to copy the files from the source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the lambda function the lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
buckets well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s3 that's a feature
that comes along with s3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an iem role
that lets you access to pull data from
the source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
lambda files or lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
lambda gets triggered copies the data
from the source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the iam role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible all
right that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through this
lab so to begin with we need two buckets
so i have here a source bucket and a
destination bucket and the source bucket
as of now do not have any data in it so
as the destination bucket all right so
that's one down the second would be to
create an im role right so let me create
an im role and the role is going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's allowing put object
on the destination bucket and here i'm
going to use or i'm going to paste my
source and destination buckets arn all
right go to services go to s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket drn
so that would be the source bucket arn
all right on on the destination bucket
copy the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this i'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to im
and create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn and a policy is
available with the name s3 bucket copy
lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name
and then create a role now i have a role
created as well
right copy lambda and that's having the
policy that we have created some time
back now create a lambda function right
so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use
right that's the role that we want to
use copy one two
create a function
all right
and in here
we're going to use node.js code right i
have a sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggered now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the evil triggers
lambda and lambda checks the source s3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here
and click on save
right now before you click on save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
roles defined
that's all you got to do click on save
all right now i i already have
created
a lambda function
all right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and
in theory those data should be present
in the destination bucket as well
there you go it's all done by lambda i'm
going to be touring you with different
s3 features and technical details in
this section so what are we going to
learn we're going to learn about what is
cloud storage in general and then the
types of storage available in general in
the cloud and how things were before
anybody adopted using s3 that's
something we're going to learn and then
we're going to immediately dive into
what is s3 and then the benefits of
using s3 over other storage and then
we're going to do a couple of
labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how amazon s3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of promise um how does this
all work how does amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the amazon s3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data can be easily accessed and
the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in chart if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could back up
your data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use and no commitment no
pre-provisioning is you know
pay-as-you-go type subscription and the
best part is we pay on a monthly basis
you know we don't rent a hardware for
the year or we don't give commitment for
the whole year it's pay as you go and
pay on a monthly basis and these cloud
storages are very reliable meaning once
you put the data in it it's never going
to get lost and these cloud storages are
scalable assuming i have a requirement
to store 100 times of what my actual
data size is and i want it now it's
available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secure and amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is a cloud storage in aws
and then we have elastic block store now
elastic block store is actually the ssd
hard drives that gets attached to our
ec2 instance you know it's like the c
drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from ebs in a way
that ebs can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the d volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
efs are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they're
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well glacier is actually
the archiving solution in the cloud if
you want to dump a data and try to keep
them in
the low cost as possible then glacier is
the product we should be using and then
we have storage gateway if i want to
safely move my data from my local
environment to the cloud environment and
also want to keep a copy of the data
locally so users locally can access them
and you know cloud users or internet
users can access the data from the cloud
if that's your requirement then storage
gateway is the one we would be choosing
and then we have snowball snowball is
really an
data import and export system but
it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our premises where we can
copy our data into it and then ship it
back to amazon and amazon would copy the
data into whatever destination we give
them in our account and if the data is
really huge then i can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where amazon would
send me and truck loaded with the data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity and electricity uh ac and lot
more so they get come parked near our
data center and cables run into our data
center we can copy data into it send it
back to amazon and they would copy it to
our account in whatever storage that we
advise them so if the data is really
really huge then i would be calling
snowmobile snowmobile is not available
in all the regions all right let's take
this example how things were before s3
was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
companies grow and we are living in an
era where data is everything we want
data to back up every idea we want data
to back up every proof of concept that
we provide so data is everything so in
this era it's all about
collecting data analyzing them and
saving you know not losing logs you know
saving them analyzing stuff like that so
coming back to our discussion here one
person finds it very difficult to store
and manage all the data that they have
so some of the data that this person is
having problem storing is data that
applications use to running and then
data that gets sent to the customers and
data's that the websites require the
data that are because of the email
backups and a lot more other storages
that an enterprise can have and this
person is having problem backing up all
those data and even if
we think of
increasing the local storage capacity
and that's going to cost the fortune and
few things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is uh you
know we will have to go and pay heavy to
buy hardware and software to run these
storages and we need to hire a team of
experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to s3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to
estimate in other words all the
scalability all the
data security all the
not being able to provision hardware and
software components are all available
with s3 so that actually brings us to
the discussion about what s3 is s3 is
simple storage service it actually
provides an object storage service let
me talk to you about object and block
storage object storage is where you can
store things into drive all right you
can't install anything in it and this
object storage can be accessed directly
from the internet whereas block storage
is something that needs to be attached
to an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's a high
level difference between object storage
and block storage and s3 is an object
storage what does that mean we can store
data from the internet we can retry from
the internet but uh we can't install
anything in s3 all right so so s3 is an
object based storage and it's it's
really built for storing and recovering
or retrieving any amount of data or
information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about s3 is that this s3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing s3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from s3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be five terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as 5 terabytes in size and s3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into s3 or drive logs
anytime they want instead of storing
locally in the server they can use s3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and a lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about s3 and on
top of all these s3 provides 11 9
durability and 4 9 availability meaning
durability is if i store the data will
it get lost amazon is like no it's not
going to get lost you're going to have
the data because we provide 11.9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s3 s3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability s3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is very
scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
uh once you're done some data needs to
be removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well s3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one availability
zone going down with an amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access s3
storage and s3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then mfa authentication are possible
with s3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in s3 and not only that
this s3 is very flexible in terms of
cost flexible in terms of where i want
to store the data in terms of cost there
are a lot of pricing tiers within s3
s3 itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability so i can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in region i can always choose any of the
region available in the console or in
the s3 console to put my data to there
is no restrictions on where i can or
cannot put the data in the cloud as long
as there are regions available for me to
move the data to and data transferring
with s3 is very simple all i have to do
is
browse to the bucket upload the data and
the data gets uploaded and we can also
upload data using cli commands are very
similar to linux commands are very
similar to what we would use in the run
command prompt in windows and what we
would use in the run command prompt uh
in the powershell all right let's talk
about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it a jpeg
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata all right so object is actually
data plus metadata and bucket is
actually a container that receives the
data and safely stores in it and when we
add a data in a bucket amazon s3 creates
an unique version id and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and sc is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn
will be available let's
let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it simplylearn.samuel.com
and i'm going to put this in
my or i can choose oregon
let me choose oregon
oregon
yes
let me choose oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and
you know these objects can be as big as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file plus what type of file it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added
and the storage class it is in at the
moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this s3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions amazon provides s3
service you know beat north virginia
beat mumbai beat tokyo beat sydney beat
argonne and we chose argonne to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we picked the
default which was a s3 standard as we
saw on the object data it was on s3
standard so that's the basic thing later
once the object gets added we can always
add a bucket policies you know policies
define who access it and who should not
access it what can they access are we
going to allow users only to read or to
read write as well stuff like that so
that's bucket policy we're defining the
life cycle or the lifespan of the data
in the s3 bucket now over the time do
you want the data to automatically move
to a different storage tier and at any
point do you want to sort of expire the
data you know get the data flushed out
of your account automatically and those
things can be configured in lifecycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're going to use
s3 for a code repository creating
multiple versions let's say if you want
to roll back to whatever you had before
a month how are you going to do it if
you kept updating the file and never
took a version of it so version control
helps us to keep different versions and
it helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime there is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3 begins with s3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so that's a good use
case to store data in s3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example and
the the different data is present in a
school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and there are
different storage options in s3 let's
take s3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in s3 standard let's talk
about that so s3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example or the good candidate file that
can be stored in s3 is a data that
needs to be frequently accessed and that
needs to be retrieved quickly something
like students attendance report or
student attendance sheet which we access
daily and then it needs to be retrieved
immediately as and when we need it the
other type of storage tier in s3 is
infrequent access or infrequent data
access just like the name says the use
case for that is less frequently
accessed data i mean the candidate data
that should go in infrequent access data
is a student's academic record you know
which we don't need to access on a daily
basis but if there is a requirement we
might want to go and look at it and
that's going to be quick so it's not a
data that we would access on a daily
basis but it's data that needs to show
up on your screen real quick and the
third option is amazon glacier now
glacier is really an archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance is not a requirement so
let's talk about some candidate data
that can go into archives something like
students admission fee and it's not
critical also now anytime if you want to
look at the data you can always wait to
retrieve the data so in other words you
know put it in the archive and
retrieving from the archive all takes
time so students old record are a good
candidate to be put in the archives the
other options are one zone ia storage
class where the data is infrequently
accessed and the data is stored in a
single availability zone for example you
know by default amazon stores data in
multiple availability zones and uh there
is a charge for that now it's not an
option but the charge includes storing
data in multiple availability zones but
if your data requirement is you want to
keep the charges in a low even further
you can choose a one zone ia storage
class where it stores data in one
availability zone and the candidate data
that can go in a one zone infrequent
access is students report card and the
other option with amazon s3 is standard
reduced redundancy storage it is
suitable for cases where the data is not
critical and the data can be reproduced
quickly for example you know take
a copy of the library book take a copy
of the pdf library book for example now
we would have a source pdf and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage uh here the use case is data
that's not critical and data can be
reproduced quickly for example books in
the library are not that critical and we
always have a copy of the book we're
talking about pdf so if the customer
facing or the student facing book gets
deleted i can always copy the same pdf
put it in the destination folder and
make it available for the users to read
that would be a very good use case for
reduced redundancy storage all right
let's summarize everything that we
learned about
different storage options in s3 so s3
standard it's for frequently accessed
data it's the default storage if you
don't mention anything the data gets
stored in s3 standard it can be used for
cloud applications you know content
distribution gaming applications big
data analytic dynamic websites they are
a very good use case for s3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is s3 standard
infrequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is infrequently
accessed and the vault lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier with an s3 the other options are
one zone infrequent access storage class
just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here in one zone
the fifth storage tier is reduced
redundancy storage this is good for data
that's frequently accessed it's good for
data that is non-critical and that can
be reproduced if it gets lost and
reduced redundancy storage or rrs is a
highly available solution designed for
sharing or storing data that can be
reproduced quickly all right let's
compare and contrast a couple of other
features that are available in
s3 for example durability availability
ssl support first byte latency and
lifecycle management so in standard the
durability is 11.9 durability it's the
same for standard standard ia one zone
ia glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is 11.9 and availability
of all the storage classes is all the
same except for one zone ia where the
availability zone is
99.5 percentage all of these products
support ssl connection and
the first byte latency of these products
are most of them provide access with
millisecond latency except for glacier
it provides a retrieval time of couple
of minutes to a maximum of hours and all
of them can be used for a life cycle
management you know moving data from one
storage tier to another storage chair
that's possible with all of these
storage options all right now that we've
understood the different types of
storage options available in s3 let's
talk about some of the features that are
available on s3 lifecycle management now
life cycle management is a service that
helps us to define a set of rules that
can be applied to an object or to the
bucket itself life cycle is actually
moving the data from one storage tier to
another storage chair and finally
expiring it and and completing the life
cycle of the object with life cycle
management we can manage and store our
objects in a very cost effective way it
has two features basically transition
actions and expiration actions let's
talk about transition actions with
transition action we can choose to move
the objects or move the data from one
storage class to another storage class
with life cycle management we can
configure s3 to move our data from one
storage class to another storage class
at a defined time interval or at a
defined schedule let's talk about
transition actions in
more detail let's say we have our data
in s3 at the moment and we haven't used
the data for quite some time and it's
that's how it's going to be for the rest
of the time so that data is a very good
candidate to move to the infrequent axis
because s3 standard is a bit costlier
and s3 in frequent access is a bit
cheaper than s3 standard so the kind of
usage sort of fits very well for moving
that data into infrequent access so
using lifecycle transition or lifecycle
management i can move the data to s3
infrequent access after 30 days and
let's say that
the data stayed in infrequent access for
30 more days and then now i realize that
nobody is looking into the data so i can
find an appropriate storage tier for
that particular data again and i can
move it to that particular storage chair
which is glacier so in this case after
30 days or in a total of 60 days from
the time the data got created the data
can be moved to glacier and what does
this really help us with the lifecycle
management help us to automatically
migrate our data from one storage cost
to another storage cost and by that it
really helps us to save the storage cost
life cycle management can also help us
with um object expiration meaning
deleting the object or flushing it out
after a certain amount of time let's say
that our compliance requirement requires
that we keep the data for seven years
and we have like thousands and thousands
of data like that it would be humanly
impossible to check all those or keep
track of all the dates and you know when
they need to be deleted stuff like that
but with life cycle management it is
very much possible i can simply create a
data and set up lifecycle management for
the data to expire after seven years and
exactly after seven years the data is
going to expire meaning it's going to be
deleted automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it it's actually done so i'm
into the bucket that we have created and
here's our data into the bucket assume
we have thousands and thousands of data
in the bucket and that requires to be
put in a different storage tier over
time and that requires to be expired
after seven years let's say so the way i
would create a lifecycle management is
go to management from inside the bucket
and click on lifecycle and then add and
lifecycle rule just give it a name name
like expire so all the objects that's
present in this bucket meaning the
current version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in s3 so here i would
like to put them in infrequent access
after 30 days and then
after it's been an infrequent access for
30 days i would like to move it to
glacier all right plus 30 days so how do
you read it so for the first 30 days
it's going to be in glacier so how do we
actually read it
after i put the data in s3 the data is
going to get moved to standard ia and
then it's going to stay in standard ia
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to glacier so on
the 31st day it's going to move to
standard ia on the 61st day it's going
to move to glacier let's say if i want
to
sort of delete the data if i want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do i go about doing it let me open
up a calculator
365 into 7 that's
2555 days
right after that the data is gonna get
deleted pretty much i have created a
life cycle so
after on the 31st day it's going to get
moved to infrequent access and on the
61st day glacier and after seven years
is over any data that i put in the
bucket it's going to get deleted all
right let's talk about bucket policies
bucket policies are some permission
files that we can attach to an bucket
that allows or denies access to the
bucket based on what's mentioned in the
policy so bucket policy is really an im
policy where you can allow and deny
permission to an s3 resource with bucket
policy we can also define security rules
that apply to more than one file in a
bucket now in this case you know we can
create an user or let's say there's
already a user called simply learn we
can allow or deny that user connection
to the s3 bucket or connecting to the s3
bucket using bucket policy and bucket
policies are written in json script and
let's see how that's done all right
there are tools available for us to help
us create bucket policies what you're
looking at is a tool available online
that helps us to create a bucket policy
so let's use this tool to create a
bucket policy i'm going to create a deny
statement i'm going to deny all actions
to the s3 bucket and what is the arn to
which we want to attach the arn of the
resource is actually the name of the
bucket but it really expects us to give
that key in a different format so the
arn is available right here copy bucket
arn so this is actually going to deny
everybody now we wanted to deny a user
just one user now look at that now we
have a policy that has been created
that's denying access to the bucket and
it's denying a user called simply learn
pretty much done so i can use the policy
and go over to
bucket policies so once i save it only
the user called simply learn won't have
access
to the bucket and the rest of them will
have access to it
so once you save it it gets added and
only the user simply learn will not have
access to the bucket because we're
denying them purposefully
the other features of s3 include
data protection we can protect our data
in s3 with now one of which is bucket
policy i can also use encryptions to
protect my data i can also
use im policy to protect my data so
amazon s3 provides a durable storage not
only that it also gives a as unprotected
and scalable infrastructure needed for
any of our object storage requirements
so here the data is protected by two
means one is data encryption and the
other one is data versioning data
encryption is encrypting the data so
others won't get access or even if they
get access to the file they won't be
able to access the data without the
encryption key and versioning is making
multiple copies of the data so let's
talk about them in detail what's data
encryption now data encryption refers to
protecting the data while it is being
transmitted and
protecting the data while it is at rest
now data encryption can happen in two
ways one is client encryption encryption
at rest and server side encryption
encryption that's in motion client-side
encryption refers to when client sends
the data they encrypt the data and send
it across
to amazon and server-side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted and stay encrypted
throughout the transfer
versioning is another security feature
let me it helps us so our unintentional
edits are not actually corrupting the
data
for example let's say you edited the
data and now you realize that the data
is incorrect and you want to roll back
now how do you roll back without
versioning it's not possible in other
words only with versioning it's possible
so versioning it can be utilized to
preserve recovery and restore any early
versions of every object that we stored
in our amazon s3 bucket unintentional
erasers or overrides of the object can
be easily regained if we have versioning
enabled and it's possible only if we
have
one file
with the same key name and anytime we
update the file it keeps the file name
but creates a different version id
take this bucket and data for example
you know photo.pmg is a file that was
initially stored it attached a version
id to it and then we edited it let's say
we added some watermark we you know
added some graphic to it and that's now
the new version of it when we store it
we store it with the same file name it
accepts the same file name but creates a
new version id and attaches it anytime
we want rollback we can always go to the
console look at the old versions pick
the version id and roll back to the old
version id
all right let's take this example now
i'm in a bucket that we've been using
for a while and let me upload an object
now before we actually upload an object
this bucket needs to be versioning
enabled so let me version enable this
bucket from this point onwards this
bucket is going to accept versioning so
let me upload an object photo.jpg let me
upload it alright it successfully got
uploaded
good enough it's uploaded
now
let me
upload another object
with the same file name now look at that
it was uploaded at 7 40 35 am let me
upload another object with the same file
name
that i have it stored right here that
got up to uploaded but with the same
name
all right so that's the other photo
now what if if i want to switch back the
way i would switch back is simply switch
back to the older version look at that
this is the latest version and this is
the
old version that i have i can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time and
i can open it
that's going to open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that i create as long as it's
with the same name and
at any point i can go and roll back to
the original data this is a very good
use case if you want to use s3 for
storing our codes let's talk about other
feature like cross region replication
now cross region replication is an very
cool feature if you want to
automatically keep a copy of the data in
a totally different region for you know
data durability for any additional data
durability or if you want to serve data
to your customers who live in another
country or who are accessing your data
from another country if you want to
serve the data with low latency cross
region replication is a very cool
feature that you can use and get
benefited from and let's see how that's
done so before we actually do a lab on
cross region replication let's put
together a proper definition for it
cross region duplication is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket source bucket and it
automatically copies the data to the
destination bucket which is in a
different aws region as you see here in
the picture i put data only in region 1
it's going to copy the data to region 2.
and for us to use cross region
replication versioning must be turned on
so it creates versions and copies the
versions as well if tomorrow the
original region goes down let's say the
other region will be active and it has
the complete data that was present in
the original region or at any point if
we want to simply uh you know cut the
region replication and use the other
bucket as in standalone bucket it can be
used as well because it already has all
the data that was present in the master
or all the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how that's done so there are two things
needed one is worsening and
another one is roll when we transfer
data from a one bucket to another bucket
we need proper permissions to do so and
these roles they give us proper
permissions to transfer data from one
bucket to another bucket let's see how
that's done right so here's my bucket
a bucket in usr again
let's create another bucket
in
mumbai
call it dot mumbai
dot com
and put it in uh
put it in mumbai
or create that bucket in mumbai there
you go we have one in oregon we have one
in mumbai we're planning to replicate or
create replication between these two
right create application between these
two buckets so go to the first bucket go
to management and start a replication
add a rule so all content in this bucket
is going to get replicated this is my
source bucket it's quite simple select
the destination bucket now my
destination bucket is going to be simply
learn.samuel.mumbai.com
all right it says well you have
versioning enabled in your source bucket
but not on your destination bucket do
you want to enable it now without which
we won't be able to proceed further so
let's go ahead and enable versioning
through the console that shows up and
then
like i said it it's going to require
permission to put data onto the other
bucket now i can create different roles
these are different roles that are used
for different other services i can also
choose to create a role that
specifically uh gives permission only to
move the data from one bucket to another
bucket three months it's done so if i go
over to my source bucket and if i
add some data to it let's say index.html
assuming i'm adding some files to it in
theory
they should
move to the other region automatically
they go i'm in the mumbai region and the
data's they got moved to the other
region automatically let's talk about
the other feature called transfer
acceleration now it's a very handy and a
helpful tool or a service to use if we
are transferring data which is very long
distance from us meaning from the client
to the s3 bucket let's say from my local
machine which is in india if i transfer
the data over to
oregon let's say it's a long distance if
it is going to go to the internet it's
going to go through high latency
connections and my transfer might get
delayed if it is an uh one gigabit file
it's okay but if we're talking about
anything that's uh you know five
terabyte size now if you're talking
about anything that's a five terabyte in
size then uh it's not going to be a
pleasant experience so in those cases i
can use transfer accelerator uh with
which in a secure way but in a fast way
or a fastest way transfers my data from
the laptop or from client to the s3
bucket and it makes use of a service
called cloudfront to transfer or to
enable the data acceleration so the way
it would do it is instead of copying the
data directly to the location instead of
copying the data directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally into a cloudfront location which
is available very local to whatever
place we are in and from there
it copies the data directly to an s3
bucket not going through the internet it
helps eliminate a lot of latency that
could get added when transferring the
data so let's see how that's done
right here i'm in the s3 bucket and
under properties
i can find transfer accelerator and if i
enable transfer accelerator so i'm in
another bucket
let me go to properties and let me go to
transfer accelerator and enable transfer
accelerator so now if i put data into
this bucket they're going to get copied
to the local cloudfront location and
from there they're going to get copied
to the s3 bucket from the cloudfront now
if i need to compare you know how the
speed is going to be compared to
directly putting the data to the
internet and using cloudfront there is a
tool available that actually runs for a
while and then comes with a report that
tells me
how much will be the improved speed if i
use transfer accelerator and it shows
for all the regions available in amazon
so from the source to the destination if
you want to put you know what's the
normal and what's the accelerated speed
when you transfer the data those results
we will get in the screen so at the
moment this tool is going through it
testing like uploading some file through
the internet and uploading some file
using cloudfront and it has come up with
the calculation that if i'm uploading
file to
san francisco compared to uploading
through the internet and through
cloudfront it's 13 times faster so
similarly it's going to calculate for
all the regions available and it's going
to give me a result welcome to this new
learning
series called i am a service and aws for
security here in this section we're
going to talk about what is security in
aws and then we're going to slowly or
gradually move on to the other topics
like types of security available in aws
out of all the services why im is the
most preferred one and then we're going
to talk about what is im in general how
it works the building blocks or
components in iam and the features it
the the attractive features that it
provides that makes iam stand out from
the rest of the services available we're
going to talk about that and then we're
going to end today's session with a demo
about how iam gets well interacted with
the other services in amazon and help
create a secure environment in the cloud
let's talk about aws security now cloud
security is the highest priority in aws
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay-as-you-go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
that we need to pay and the cost for
using the service is a lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so aws cloud provides and a
secure virtual platform where we can
deploy our application now compared to
the on-premises with aws the security
level is very high and the cost involved
in using or attaching that type of
security to our application is very low
compared to on premises there's really
no upfront cost and the cost is very
lower whatever cost that we pay is very
lower than what it would be in on
premises and all this contributes to the
secure environment we can get through im
in aws cloud there are really many types
of security services available in aws to
name a few are to name the familiar ones
im stands first followed by a key
management system kms and then we have
cognito that's another service and web
access firewall vaf is another security
service in aws now let's start our
discussion by talking about im and
that's what this whole series is about
now i am or identity and access
management it really enables us to
manage access to aws services and aws
resources in a very secure manner with
im we can create uh groups we can
actually allow those users or groups to
access some service or we can sort of
deny them uh to access the servers
whichever we want that's all possible
through identity and access management
and this feature comes with no
additional charge now let's talk about
how things were before aws before aws or
before im
in general it was not that safe in a
corporate to share the password over the
phone or through the email that was the
practice that was existed at that time
now we all can remember the days when we
need to switch to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and any time or
we need to log in we call the person ask
for the admin password or the phone and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then now somebody
could walk by and sort of eavesdrop you
know get the password now they walk away
with the password with them so they're
all possible when we share the password
over the phone and through the internet
or email now with aws a lot of options
are available that i'm not sharing
password over the unsecure medium now a
slack is a third-party product available
with aws it's not an aws product but
slack is in third-party application
that's hosted on aws and it's really a
communication tool that helps people to
share documents so now we're not sharing
the password over the phone rather
through the applications and no
eavesdrop person can really catch the
password and you know try it in their
system to access our environment that's
not possible so you see the difference
now back then sharing password was only
through phone and email and you would
write it on a paper and you gave it to
somebody but now technology is providing
provisions enough for us to share the
password in a secure way we're still
talking about i am im as an web service
for securely controlling access to the
aws resource now it really helps us to
authenticate or sort of limit access to
a certain set of users accessing the aws
account or certain set of users
accessing a certain set of resources in
aws account now you see this picture we
have an im administrator who is trying
to allocate permissions to different
group of people so we have group one on
the top and group two in the middle and
group three towards the end the
administrator using iam or
empowers the administrator allow access
to certain group to certain resources
that's what i am is all about now let's
talk about the building blocks or let's
talk about the elements that make and
complete i am so the elements are
categorized into six
different elements we have the principle
in iam the authentication the request
the actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy to do is it rds is it s3 bucket so
what resource these actions are applied
to so they are the basic elements of an
iem workflow let's talk about principle
for example an action on aws resource
can only be performed by a principal an
individual user they can be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well in other words a principle is an
entity that can take an action on an aws
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principle
trying to access the aws environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as per what's in the record so all
principle must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is cli or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key
the other component that makes up im is
request when a principal tries to use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the aws
environment and the request will have
the principal actually wants to perform
is it a put request or is it a get
request or is the delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource the
action needs to be done is it done easy
to one is it on s3bucketsimplylearn.com
stuff like that so it has a specific
action that it wants to perform and the
resource on which it wants to perform
and also some information about from
where the request is originating from is
it within an aws environment or is it
with another cloud service provider or
is it with on-premises stuff like that
so these information will be present in
the request authorization now this iam
uses information from the request
context to check for matching policies
and it determines it takes a decision
whether to allow or to deny the request
now here it has a logic by default all
the resources are denied and im
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic and that says by
default all requests are denied and if
there is an explicit allow
then it overrides the default deny and
if you are explicitly denying a service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets overreturned and this explicit deny
stands by default only the aws account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request aws approves the action that we
are about to take now using action we
can view the content we can create a
content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance i can edit content or even
i can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that i'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an im role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of iam so the other
components are im are the basic building
block is an user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection you know based on
policy one gets to access or gets no
access to a resource and then roles
roles are another component rules are
temporary credentials i would say that
can get assumed to an instance as in
when needed let's talk about this
component called user in an im with im
we can securely manage access to aws
services and
we can create an im user anytime there
is a new employee joining our corporate
so it's a one-to-one mapping you know
one user or one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that aws
account that we are using so for in
detail an iem user is an entity that
we create in an aws environment to
represent a person or a service that
interacts with aws environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have
a password and they do not have any
access key or secret access key attached
to them in fact literally no credentials
of any kind now we must create an user
and we must create the type of
credential that gets attached to the
user do they want to access
cli so based on that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized to perform any action in
aws and the advantage of having
one-to-one user is that we can assign
permissions individually to that user
for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our aws environment
and users are entity within an aws
account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using
their servers and that get bills under
the account they are attached to so
separate users doesn't mean that
separate payment for those users they
are just users in our account and you
know the whole account gets to pay for
the resources that they provision again
the im user does not always represent a
person an iem user is really just an
identity with associated credential and
permissions attached to it it could be
an actual person who is a user and it
could be an application also a who is a
user next we'll talk about groups
talking about groups or understanding
group is very easy a collection of user
forms an iem group and we can use iam
group to specify permission for multiple
users so that any permission that's
applied to the group is also applied to
the users who are at add to that group
now there are a few things you might
want to know about group a group can
have
many users and a user they can belong to
many groups but groups can't be nested
meaning group can only have users a
group cannot have a group inside a group
that's not possible and there's nothing
called a default group that sort of
automatically includes all users in the
aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of an small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are
people users who are application that
interact with aws environment so the
different types of users we have are
jim is a user brad is a user and
dev app one is a user and and so on so
each users have an individual set of
security credential like i said it's one
to one and the uh
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if i add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with im
alright the next thing we will want to
discuss is policy a policy sets
permission and controls the access to
aws resource and the policies this
permissions and controls are stored in
json format a policy is a very clear
document it defines who has access to a
resource and what are all the actions
they can perform so in other words
policy is an entity in aws that when a
policy gets attached to an identity or a
resource you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and aws it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes a
request and the permission statement in
the policy it really defines whether the
user is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this
example now we have a task the task is
to give paul who's a developer access to
amazon s3 environment and what you're
looking at is a snippet of what a policy
would look like so these are some
questions we will have to answer or
these are some questions the policy
tries to answer and once it found an
answer then it becomes a complete policy
so who wants access to the service it's
paul who wants access to the service and
what action do paul want now paul wants
to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in json language it's otherwise
called paul wants to get information
paul wants to put information otherwise
paul wants to get object paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in history so which resource it's all
bucket in s3 so we can start reading
already from the data present here so
who wants access paul wants access what
action does he want he wants to get he
wants to put and what's the resource
that he's trying to access or you want
to give him access it's all the bucket
in aws and when does he want these
additional statement that goes in a
policy so since when does he want that
access he wants access till march 2nd
2019 so all this who all this action all
this resource you know till the time all
this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now does
this all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had deny here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means paul is allowed to
get and put access in an s3 bucket and
all the buckets in s3 till march 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a json format this is
how it's going to look like so
the effect is
allow or deny here it's allowing and the
principle
is any now who can access it it's any an
action it's any bucket in s3 any action
in s3 put get request and the resource
is any bucket in s3 so that's how a
basic policy would look like or that's
how basic policy is formed by answering
those basic questions so let's talk
about the types of policies so we have
two broad categories managed policy and
inline policy now manage policy it's the
default policy that we attach to
multiple entries beat users beat groups
and beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
i need to brief
it a little bit more then a managed
policies are standalone identity based
policies that we can attach to multiple
users groups and roles in our aws
account we can use two types of managed
policies in other words managed policies
they themselves have two categories one
is aws managed policies which is created
and managed by aws and the other one is
customer managed policies just like the
name says it's managed by the customer
now we can create and edit an im policy
in visual editor or simply create a json
policy document directly and uploaded in
the console and start using them so
that's manage policy on the other hand
inline policies are policies that we
create and manage and that are embedded
directly into a single user group or
role let's talk about this next
component called role now this role is
very similar to everything that we
discussed so far it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an aws console the role is
very similar to an user i said very
similar i didn't say it's the same as
the user but i said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard coded user permissions are hard
coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know beat a
user or a beat and aws service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an aws entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in aws
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have a
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have a
long long-term credentials it only has
temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account access to your resource that
they do not normally have or grant users
in one aws account access to resource in
another aws account now this is
something that we don't have by default
and this is something we may not need
all the time or you might want to allow
a mobile app to use aws resource but you
do not want to save the key or save the
credential or save the passwords in the
mobile app or sometimes you might want
to give access to resources who already
have identities defined outside of aws
like a user who's already and google or
facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our aws resources
remember they're not permanent users
just templar users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission to
other services so here is a scenario
where where an ec2 instance
wants access to an s3 bucket by default
though both of them were created by the
same username or the same admin they do
not have access by default so by default
they don't have access and i also do not
want to give permanent access you know
one-on-one hard-coded permanent access
instead i would like to create and share
access so that's possible to roll so
coming back to the discussion uh the
scenario here is that an ac2 instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to create a role or a
permission we saw how that's done right
using policies roles use policies policy
is the actual working engine for any
permission related actions right so
create a role with an appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's bucket and
then
launch an ec2 instance with the role
attached to it we said
roles are assumed by any entity right it
could be user it could be an application
it could be a service it could be
another resource in aws account so here
it's another resource in aws account
right so we create a role and we attach
it to an ec2 instance so now the ec2
instance can assume the role now the
same role can be attached to another ec2
instance the same rule can be attached
to
another user the same role can be
attached to another database service we
get the idea right roles can be assumed
by anyone so when the ec2 instance wants
to communicate with s3 it contacts the
role and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the
s3 bucket and access the file with the
credential that it already has and that
credential is a temporary one and the
credential will expire after one hour or
how much ever time the admin sets it to
be and then the next time when is when
an ec2 instance wants to contact s3 it
will have to contact the role and the
role will propose a new access key and
secret access key in other words a new
credential with that new credential the
second time the ec2 instance will be
able to contact the s3 bucket and get
the information so the password is not a
permanent or a one time or a hard coded
password it keeps rotating it's a token
it's a secure token that an ec2 instance
or any application that uses the role
gets to access the resources on the
other end well let's talk about the
features of iam the main feature of im
is that i can create separate username
and password for individual users or
resources and i can delegate access now
those days where we had just one
username and password for admin and we
need to call the other person to get the
username and password over the phone
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone i can
create separate username and password
for all thousand users in my account no
more username and password sharing i can
manage access to all those thousand
accounts in a very simple and an easy
way so im provides shared access for all
the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get requests you know we can allow a
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the im policies that we looked
at some time back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances i
can create a role and assign that role
to the ec2 instance and all the
applications running on the ec2 instance
get a secure access to the other
resources use the role credential that's
provided to that ec2 instance now
besides username and password im also
supports multi-factor authentication
where we provide our credential the
username and password plus an otp from
our phone or an uh randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before amazon console or before amazon
cli would authenticate and
lets us access some of the servers in
the account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have im also provides identity
federation if a user is already
authenticated with a copyright ad or
facebook or google you know iam can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on-premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in a every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the
cloud username and password now with
identity federation we can sort of
federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on premises
and im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there is no additional charge for im
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account im is an pci dss
compliant product now im comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely and we can set rules
like how a user should pick an password
it should not be the one that was used
in the past any of the past three times
stuff like that so you get the idea
right how the features of iam help us to
build and a secure authentication and
authorization system in or for our aws
account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the knowledge that
we have earned so far together and apply
it and try a lab and solve the problem
so here's a problem statement
we need to create an s3 bucket for a
company where users can read or write
the data only if they are multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account but a user is
allowed to read or write a data in an s3
bucket only if the user is multi-factor
authenticated you know this is a very
good use case if we have a sensitive
data in an s3 bucket and you only want
privileged or mfa authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would enable
multi-factor authentication so let's see
how that's done before that let me talk
to you a bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by aws
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an
rsa token key that generates the
one-time password that's possible as
well but in this case it's the mobile
phone now that's going to be very
similar to how we log in to our gmail
account sometimes when we log into a
gmail account and i mean if you have the
proper setting enabled it's going to
send an one-time password to the mobile
phone and only after we put that
information it's going to let us log in
let's see how all this is done in an aws
account so the first thing is to log in
to the aws account create a user and
attach the user to the virtual mfa
device now we're going to use google
authenticator here and we're going to
attach the user to
google authenticator and make the user
use the google authenticator one-time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that
he or she already has right so the first
thing is to log into the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws username and password now when we
sync there will be an one-time password
that gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the aws console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the mfa code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step or security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the aws resources
all right so in order to test im mfa s3
together this is what we're going to do
so we're going to create
a bucket and we're going to have two
users and we're going to allow or deny
access to the s3 bucket to those two
users based on whether they are mfa
authenticated or not and on purpose uh
we gonna assign mfa to one user and
no mfa to the other user like you might
have guessed by now the user with mfa
will have access to the bucket and the
user with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket both of them are
going to have full s3 services but mfa
like i said is one layer above the other
permissions mfa stands at all time so
irrespective of whether the underlying
policy says but they have full access to
the s3 bucket they're not going to
because mfa stands on top of it let's
see how that's done to begin with
firstly we need a bucket so let's create
a bucket
so i'm in my
aws console so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn mfa bucket and
let me put it in north virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now i'm going to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where i'm planning
to keep my tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the sd side it's partially done so
let's go back to im
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior employee and another one
and a senior employee the senior
employee is the one who's going to have
mfa access and
more access to the s3 bucket and the
junior employee is the one who's not
going to have access to that particular
bucket so let's get
started let's create an user under iam
click on users
and let's create a user call as user
junior
right so he's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and
the user who creates the username and
the user are the same person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have
full s3 bucket access all right this is
really the policy
and we should be familiar
with this dslr document by now it says
effect is allowed and what action any
action in s3 and
what resource anybody who is attached to
it
review
and create a user
so this user is having
s3 full access now let's create another
user call them as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so
both of them have s3 full access as we
see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior employee now we're
going to attach
mfa to this employee so the way we would
do it is under the summary section of
that particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an mfa to this user so let's
attach mfa to this user
for mfa i can use both virtual mfa or
hardware mfa this being in lab
environment we're going to use virtual
mfa now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that i'm using
at the moment called google
authenticator
so once we have installed the
application now once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running i can scan the code
using the google authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's going to give us
codes that we can use and we will have
to put in those codes here twice we'll
have to wait for some time and it would
generate a second set of key that we can
put so my first set of key is four zero
two three five one right i'll have to
wait for some time and then it would
throw me a second set of key it's like
validating twice right here so let me
put in my second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for mfa anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the mfa key along with it all right so
we're done with iam what have we done
with im we have created two users both
of them have actually full access
but
one of them have mfa access and the
other one does not have mfa access and
based on whether the user is having mfa
or not you know we're identifying
privileged users by this mfa all right
so based on whether the user has mfa or
not are we going to allow deny access in
the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged
folder part here i would like to
restrict access based on whether the
user is having mfa or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here is a policy that i have written
the policy
says that you know under tax document
folder give access only if the user is
mfa authenticated right if the user is
not mfa authenticated simply deny the
access to that user so as you might
guess right now the user one will not
have access or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then you know
junior employee might tend to delete
them unknowingly and only privileged
users get access to the tax document
because it's confidential because it's
privileged because if it gets deleted we
won't be able to get it back for those
reasons right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the im url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfa code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough i'm able to upload content
into it will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder
which we want to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing
to add content to this bucket it shows
error because the bucket policy is
requiring mfa and this user is not mfa
and we did that in iam or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with welcome to this new video lesson
where we're going to learn about cloud
formation in this section we're going to
learn about why we need a solution
called cloud formation or why we need a
product called cloud formation and we're
going to talk in detail about what is
cloud formation and then how cloud
formation works and the concepts
involved in cloud formation like i know
templates and stacks there are some
concepts involved in cloud formation
we're going to talk about that and how
do we maintain access control over cloud
formation we're going to talk about that
as well in this video and then we're
going to go through a demo or a lab
where we create an lamp stack
environment from a template through
cloud formation and then we're going to
talk about some use cases one of which
include
being able to create an redeployable
template using cloud formation that's a
very good use case we're going to talk
about that in this video so let's talk
about why cloud formation so when the
number of products and services grow
more and managing them and maintaining
them
becomes and tedious work and cloud
formation it sort of eases that
environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code and
it sort of solves all the problem that
we discussed sometime back and with
cloud formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily ember in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes a bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment and if we need
to redeploy the same environment again
and again the same happens in a cycle
again in a new environment we start from
the scratch build environment and then
put application on top of it now that
can be avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of aws
resources by provisioning and updating
them in and very orderly and in a
predictable way if i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation
cloudformation is an service that really
helps us to model and set up our amazon
web services or resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an rds instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is vetted and
validated cloudformation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short at the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and backend resources they run on
aws in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and more time on the core
business and the application that runs
on top of it and we're still talking
about what cloud formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or aws resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that
in a moment you know it's either a json
or an yml file and that file is called
as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called the stack all right so the
abstract of the code is called the
template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be i mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
i'm including two more servers if i'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
i'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
i said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the ec2
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region and i can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region i can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about parameters mapping and
conditions down the line we're still
talking about aws how aws cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
would be in json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on whether they want
and a windows server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an s3 bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
validates template and then it
identifies the
dependencies between them and then it
starts provisioning the resource one
after the other for example if you need
a five servers in a new vpc obviously
it's going to create the vpc first and
servers second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together the
aid or the complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed and
that eases the job of the administrator
who's managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a template in
cloud formation is an text file or a
formatted text file in json or yml
language and that the code or the
template or the text file that actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provision
and for us to create the template or for
us to
modify an existing template we can use a
tool available called cloud formation
designer from the console or any text
editing tool that's available but i
would recommend the cloud formation
designer though that has rich graphics
in it and these templates are built off
or they consist of nine main objects the
first of which is the format version and
this really identifies the capabilities
of the template based on the version
number and then the second object in a
template would be description and this
helps us to include any arbitrary
comments about the template for what
reason are we building this template
what's the purpose of it stuff like that
and then we have the object called
metadata in a template and that includes
a details about the template details of
the resources in the template and then
we have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example uh aws
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required
section called resource that declares
the aws resource that you want to
include in the stack for example if you
want to include an ec2 instance if you
want to include a nested bucket we would
be using the resource object in our
stack and then we have object called
output this output object it's an
optional object in the template and it
helps us to sort of uh declare the
outputs that we can import into other
stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want the output of the or the name of
the s3 bucket that got created in
response to a cloudformation template
now we can have that outputted into an
output section in the cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources that the
template provisioned so with all of
those objects put together this is how a
full-blown cloudformation template with
all the objects included is going to
look like now this includes optional and
mandatory object let's talk about those
objects in detail in the upcoming
section all right let's now discuss each
and every object of this template
structure and let's begin our discussion
with the format version the format
version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be and
string and if we really don't specify
the format version cloudformation
automatically assumes the latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that help
ourselves that we want to ember in the
template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string the
length of the string can be between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide any additional information
using the json and yaml objects and
metadata holds some implementation
details of a specific
resource and parameters are really a way
to customize the template each time we
create or update our stack these
parameters are the ones that helps us to
give some custom value to the template
during runtime in the example shown
below the parameter named instance type
parameter it lets us to specify the ec2
instance type for the stacks to use when
creating or updating the stack by
default as we see uh it's picking t2
micro and this is the value that will
get picked if we don't provision another
value to it and mapping mapping really
enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can detrive the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map instrict function let's take
this example let's say based on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that uses a key
and holds the value that you want to
specify for each region
and the object conditions can be used
when we want to reuse the templates by
creating resources in a totally
different context for example in a
template during stack creation all the
conditions that we mentioned in the
template are evaluated and any resources
that are associated and that come up to
be true are created and any condition
that fails or invalid are kind of
ignored automatically and the check
moves forward to the next condition and
conditional is an optional object and it
includes statement that define when a
resource is created or when a property
is actually defined for example you can
create whether for example you can
compare whether a value is equal to
another value and based on the result of
that condition we can conditionally
create resources if you have multiple
conditions then they are generally
separated with commands sometimes
conditions are very helpful when we want
to create
templates and we want to reuse those
templates which was created for one
environment to another environment for
example if you want to use a template
that was created in a test environment
in a dev environment conditions would be
helpful for example in a production
environment we might want to include
instances with certain capabilities and
in a test environment we might want to
include instances with some reduced
capability in them for saving money and
condition helps us to sort of create
resources based on the environment it
will be used in we can also use
intrinsic functions to define conditions
like equals we can also use r conditions
we can use not functions intrinsic
functions in a condition and when put
together the syntax is going to look
like the one that you see on the screen
now the optional object called transform
it specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple declarative
language of aws cloud formation
with a powerful macro system that helps
us to
reuse the templates or the template
components and they really help us to
condense or simplify our codes by
enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
aws resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within the template and the logical id
name it actually referenced the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example i know
if we want to map an elastic block store
volume or if you want to map and
name of the bucket in another place in
the template then we would use the
logical id and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical id with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case my s3 bucket was named as mybucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource is an s3 bucket and the
properties are the additional
optional information that we can specify
to our resource for example if it is an
ec2 instance let's say we would like to
know which ami it used then property
section really defines the ami that was
used or ami as the property of the
instance so this section describes the
output value that needs to be imported
to other stacks or the output value that
needs to be shown in the console for the
user to easily navigate to the resource
that are being created for example for a
s3 bucket name we can declare an output
and once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and
going to s3 and searching for the bucket
name this can be made available in the
cloud formation console itself and the
output fields it can include some of
these followings like the logical id uh
it's actually the identifier of the
current output and it's very unique
within the template and it can also
include a description description is
really a string type that describes the
output value and it can also include
value and value is the property that was
returned by the aws cloud formation
describe stacks command all right let's
talk about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to
talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have i mean if we need
to name them we have a creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on metadata attribute update
policy attribute let's talk about each
of them separately when we associate the
create policy attribute with the
resource it actually delays the resource
configuration actions before proceeding
with the stack creation i mean the
attribute stack creation is delayed till
the time the cloud formation receives
some number of success signals back i
mean this is a very good use case when
we do auto scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances some of the
use cases would be if you want to
install and software application on an
ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal after the applications
are installed and configured then cloud
formation goes to the next step here in
the syntax that we're looking at the
auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting
deleted and by default if you don't have
a delete policy the uh data gets deleted
just like that but if you use an
deletion policy we would be able to
preserve the data by taking a snapshot
of it or
just letting the resource and moving on
with deleting the other resources in the
stack and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy mentioned for a
particular resource the cloud formation
simply deletes the resources as that's
its default behavior and if you want to
keep the resource when the stack is
deleted we use we we mention retain in
the delete policy and that simply
retains the resource from getting
deleted so in this example we're
actually retaining a dynamodb table rest
of the resources in the stack will get
deleted and using that depends on
attribute we actually
create a an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if i map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another when we
add the depends on attribute to a
resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource x
depends on y we've said that x depends
on y so in this case when cloud
formation is executing it's going to
deploy y first because it has some
resources that depends on it so it's
going to create y first and then it's
going to create the resource called x on
the same context let's say in the
template we say that an ec2 is going to
depend on s3 and when the cloud
formation is executing it's going to
create an s3 bucket first and then the
ec2 winston that's probably because the
codes needed for the ec2 instance are
stored in the s3 bucket and and what
we're looking at is the syntax of how
the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the bucket the other template
resource attribute is metadata metadatas
are the one that really helps us to
associate our resources with the the
structured data and by including this
attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
vpc and the metadata explains or
metadata defines that the vpc is part of
the region us east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling group for example you're
looking at this uh sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that the
update policy will replace the instance
or will replace the auto scaling group
itself when it's doing enrolling
deployment now that we've discussed
about templates let's talk about aws
stacks as well now we know that aws
stacks are the actual resources that
gets generated or that gets created
because we ran a template right so stack
is a collection of aws results that we
can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack
update a stack or delete a stack and
that would actually create update delete
the collection of resources within the
stack and all the resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required to run a web application such
as a web server a database server and
some networking rules that come along
with it all that gets embedded in a
stack and let's say if we want to delete
all the resources that were created by
template that is in a separate stack we
can simply delete the stack and that
would sort of delete all the resources
that is in the stack so it sort of helps
us to manage all the resources in a
single unit or as a single unit so to
summarize stack is a collection of aws
resource and it can be managed as a
single unit and the cloud formations
template defines a stack in which the
resource can be created deleted or
updated in a very predictable way and a
stack can have all the resources like
web server database server vpc the
network and the security configurations
in a vpc
all that is required to run a web or a
database application now stack could be
nested as well with cloud formation we
can actually
nest a stack with another stack and
that's going to create an hierarchy of
the stacks for example i mean this is a
very good picture that explains how the
stacks are nested in an hierarchical way
let's say stack p is the
root stack and that could be a parent
stack for the stack called r and the
stack call cube and the same way the the
stack called r is a parent stack for the
stack s and the stack s is the pattern
stack for d and q you get that right so
stacks can always be nested it's
possible cloudformation allows us to
create a microsoft windows stack based
on amazon ec2 windows amis and provide
us with the ability to install software
and use remote desktop to access our
stack and update the configuration of
our stack and these stacks can be run on
windows server instances there are a
number of pre-configured templates
available and it's directly available to
use from the aws website itself to name
a few we have templates available for
sharepoint uh running on an
windows server 2008 r2 we also have
templates that create a single server
installation of active directory running
on a windows server and in fact we have
templates available for elastic bean
stock and some sample applications that
runs from an windows server 2008 r2
let's talk about stack sets stack sets
actually has taken the stack level
implementation to the next level using
the aws cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in aws account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can define and manage an aws
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with im i can specify the
list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
formation template who can create update
and delete stack so that's how im helps
me with having or putting a layer of
control over the cloud formation service
and we can also use service roles
service roles are the one that allows
aws cloud formation to make a call to a
resource in a stack on the user's behalf
and i can also have stack policies and
these stack policies are applied to the
users who already have access to the
cloud formation service and these
policies are the ones that help the
users who attempt to update the stack
all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mysql database for
storage now we can do the other way as
well i can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we're
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and uh
cloudformation helps us to do that so
this is what we're going to do we're
going to create or we have a
cloudformation template already and
we're going to use that template the
provision web instance and that is going
to have look at that that's going to
have mysql installed in it that's going
to have php that's going to have httpd
servers installed in it and running and
it's also going to have an a php website
running from it so that's going to
receive information from the website and
that's going to store that information
in the database that's very local to it
this is the template that defines
that environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision
this environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and
which region is it this is in
california is that
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the mumbai region or let me switch to
north virginia region
north virginia and from here
actually let me switch to mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same
template that we are provisioning
all right let's give this a name so it's
gonna be great this could be simply long
simply learn lamp stack and what could
be the db password
and db root password
and what could be the db user
i'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and i'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
password should only have alpha
numeric characters
get that
so let's go back and create a new
password
all right it also needs to have
eight characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen
we can see the template that we used to
deploy the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about
instant
types in parameters right the default
instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was
used to receive information from us like
the db name
the db password the db root password the
user instance type key name and the ssh
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually uh created
right looks like it's rolling back
why would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption
that it could not proceed it would
simply roll back and delete all the
resources that it had provisioned and
that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix i have switched
the regen because i had some issue with
the vpc that's going to take time for me
to analyze and fix it so here we're
going to understand
about cloud formation so i thought i'll
run the cloud formation from another vpc
that
i know is working fine that's in not
virginia
all right let's provision a lamp server
which
is running out of linux which has apache
installed in it which has php and my sql
already installed in it so one server
gonna act as web and db server
all right so i'm gonna create a stack
and from here i'm gonna pick a sample
stack if we look at if you look at it in
the designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security attack security group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us what could be the db
password
and the db user
and
let's select the key name
right i'm going to keep the rest as
a defaults
and i'm going to create
a stack
all right so us stack
that we run from the template
at the moment it's getting created it's
in progress
from here i can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like i said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out
their dependencies you know which one
needs to get created first which one
needs to get created second
all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted
and a resource
tab
is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group at the moment it's
creating an instance and
output
uh it's empty as of now we're gonna come
back and see it
now output is where
we can
get outputs of a finished job let's say
uh here i wanted an uh url
of the
server that got created so instead of me
uh you know going to a couple of other
places within the console
and
find the
output of
the url
or
the the output of the resource that was
created i can simply get it from here
well this needs to be defined in the
templates first
once we define it in the template it's
going to be made available
like here
right so i can
open it up
and there you go so it has it already
has
a database locally installed and it's
connected to it if i launch an
application on top of it
that will get connected to the database
which is very local
and
my single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
creating an environment like this which
has elastic load balancer a vpc
a server running in an auto scaling
group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ec2
instance directly but they should be
able to access
the ec2 instance or the data only
through the elastic load balance so this
is a bit complicated than the
environment that we've already created
let's see how this is done all right in
this lab we're going to create elastic
load balance to auto scaling group which
is going to create a load balancer and
an auto scaling group and that auto
scaling group receives
traffic only from the load balancer so
here's the template and here's the
architecture that we're going to
provision
let me call it
right and the key pair it's going to use
is
simply learn key pair
now this is where the problem was now
we were selecting few subnets
so now if i provision it
now this is going to take its
short time to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good
no back no no deletes and
the resource section shows the resource
that
it is creating so previously created a
target group now it's creating the
application load balancer itself
all right so it created an um
load balancer and that had created a
security group it created a launch
configuration it at the moment it's
creating an web server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or roll back errors
so it looks good all right it took a
while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they're in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the url
there you go
and remember there was another feature
of the cloud formation that was it
should restrict access i mean direct
access to ec2 instance let's see if that
has been done
if i try to access using the load
balancer it lets me access
but if i try to access it using
the ec2 instance ip or the dns name my
connection won't go through because it's
blocked through the security group but
direct access through the load balancer
is allowed and that's what we wanted to
achieve through that template here we're
going to talk about amazon ecs a service
that's used to manage docker containers
so without any further due let's get
started in this session we would like to
talk about some basics about aws and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why amazon ecs and what is amazon
ecs in general and then it uses a
service called docker so we're going to
understand what docker is and there are
competitive services available for ecs i
mean you could ecs is not the on and
only service to manage docker containers
but why ecs advantage of ecs we will
talk about that and the architecture of
ezs so how it functions what are the
components present in it and
what are the functions that it does i
mean each and every component what are
all the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of amazon acs and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ecs what were the challenge and how ecs
helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy
docker containers on an amazon ecs so
let's talk about what is uh aws amazon
web service in short called as aws is an
web service in the cloud that provides a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content
delivery and a lot of other resources so
you can scale your business and grow not
focus more on your it needs and the rest
of the id demands rather you can focus
on your business and let amazon scale
your it or let amazon take care of your
it so what is that you can do with aws
with aws we can create deploy any
application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also create your
application in the cloud it has all the
tools and services required the tools
and services that you would have
installed in your laptop or you would
have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be
installed and used from the cloud so you
can use cloud for creating and not only
that you can use the same cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be could be in the internet
the end user could be kind of spread all
around the world it doesn't matter so it
can be used uh to create and deploy your
applications in the cloud and like you
might have guessed now it provides
service over the internet that's how
your users worldwide would be able to
use the service that you create and
deploy right so it provides service
over the internet so that's for the end
customer and how will you access those
services that's again through the
internet it's like the extension of your
data center in the internet so it
provides all the services in the
internet it provides compute service
through the internet so in other words
you access them through the internet it
provides database service through the
internet over the internet in other
words you can securely access your
database through the internet and lot
more and the best part is this is
pay as you go or pay only for what you
use there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment
here most of the services does not have
any commitment so there is no long term
and beforehand commitment you only pay
exactly for what you use there's no
overage there's no overpaying right
there's no buying in advance right you
only pay for what you use let's talk
about what ecs is so before ecs before
containers right ecs is a service that
manages docker containers right it's not
a product or
it's not a feature all by itself it's a
service that's dependent on docker
container so before docker containers
all the applications were running on vm
or on a host or on a physical machine
right and that's memory bound that's
latency bound the server might have
issues on and on right so let's say this
is alice and she's trying to access her
application which is running somewhere
in her on premises and the application
isn't working what could be the reason
some of the reasons could be memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons so a lot of reasons why
the application wouldn't be working in
on premises some of them are memory full
issue and server down issue very less
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if i if i need to tell it
correctly with easiest the services can
kind of breed free right the services
can run seamlessly now how how is that
possible those things we will discuss in
the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and ecs managing containers
the applications can run in a high
available
mode they can run in a high available
mode meaning if something goes wrong
right there's another container that
gets spun up and your application runs
in that particular container very less
chances of your application going down
that's what i mean this is not possible
with
a physical a host this is very less
possible with an vm or at least it's
going to take some time for another vm
to get spun up so
why ec is or what is ecs amazon ecs
maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one container
running your application
or one container hosting your
application should be running all the
time so to meet that high availability
availability is making sure your service
is running 24 7. so container makes sure
that your services run 24 bar 7 not only
that not only that suddenly there is an
increase in demand how do you meet that
demand right let's say you have like
thousand users suddenly the next week
there are like 2000 users all right so
how do you meet that demand container
makes it very easy for you to meet that
demand in case of vm or in case of
physical host you literally will have to
go buy another physical host or
add more ram add more memory add more
cpu power to it all right or kind of
club two three uh hosts together
clustering you would be doing a lot of
other things to meet that high
availability and also to meet that
demand but in case of ecs it
automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular r so
what is amazon
ecs the full form of ecs is elastic
container service right so it's
basically a container management service
which can quickly launch and
exit and manage docker containers on a
cluster so what's the function of ecs it
helps us to quickly launch and quickly
exit and manage docker containers so
it's kind of a management service for
the docker containers you will be
running in amazon or running in the aws
environment so in addition to that it
helps to schedule the placement of
container across your cluster so it's
like this you have two physical hosts
you know joined together as a cluster
and ecs helps us to place your
containers now where should your
container be placed should it be placed
in host one should be placed in host two
so that logic is defined in ecs we can
define it you can also let ecs take
control and define that logic most cases
you will be defining it so schedule the
placement of containers across your
cluster let's say two containers want to
interact heavily you really don't want
to place them in two different hosts
right you would want to place them in
one single host so they can interact
with each other so that logic is defined
by us and these container services you
can launch containers using aws
management console and also you can
launch containers using sdk kits
available from amazon you can launch
through a java program you can launch
container using and.net program you can
launch container using an node.js
program as in when the situation demands
so there are multiple ways you can
launch containers through management
console and also programmatically and
ecs also helps to migrate application to
the cloud without changing the code so
anytime you think of migration the first
thing that comes to your mind is that
how will that environment be based on
that i'll have to alter my code what's
what's the ip what is the storage that's
being used what what are the different
parameters i'll have to include the
environment parameters of the new
environment with containers now that
worry is already taken away because we
can create and pretty exact environment
that the one that you had an on-premises
the same environment gets created in the
cloud so
no worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application but
you can be like if it ran in my laptop a
container that i was running in my
laptop it's definitely gonna run in the
cloud as well because i'm gonna use the
same container in the laptop and also in
the cloud in fact you're going to ship
it you're going to move the container
from your laptop to amazon ecs and make
it run there so it's like the same the
very same image the very same container
that was running in your laptop will be
running in the
cloud or production environment so what
is docker we know that it ecs helps to
quickly launch exit and manage docker
containers what is docker let's let's
answer that question what is docker now
docker is a tool
that helps to automate the development
of an application as a lightweight
container so that the application can
work efficiently in different
environments this is pretty much what we
discussed right before the slide i can
build an application in my laptop or in
on premises in a container environment
docker container environment and anytime
i want to migrate right i don't have to
kind of rewrite the code and then rerun
the code in that new environment i can
simply create an image a docker image
and move that image to that production
or the new cloud environment and simply
launch it there right so no compiling
again no relaunching the application
simply pack all your code in a docker
container image and ship it to the new
environment and launch the container
there that's all so docker container is
a light weight package of software that
contains all the dependencies so because
you know when packing you'll be packing
all the dependencies you'll be packing
the code you'll be packing the framework
you'll be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
gonna run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's going to run in that
container so you can be rest assured
that they are going to run in that new
environment and these docker containers
are highly scalable and they are very
efficient suddenly you wanted like 20
more docker containers to run the
application think of adding 20 more
hosts 20 more vms right how much time
would it take and compared to that time
the amount of time that docker
containers would require to kind of
scale to that amount like 20 more
containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's an highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short boot up time because
it takes a it's not going to load the
whole operating system and these docker
containers you know they use the
linux kernel and features of the kernel
like c groups and name spaces to kind of
segregate the processor so they can run
independently any environment and it
takes very less time
to boot up
and the data's that are stored in the
containers are kind of reusable so you
can have an external
data volume and i can map it to the
container and whatever the space that's
occupied by the container and the data
that the container puts in that volume
they are kind of reusable you can simply
remap it to another application you can
kind of remap it to the next successive
container you can kind of remap it to
the next version of the container next
version of the application you'll be
launching and you don't have to go
through building the data again from the
scratch whatever data the container was
using previously or the previous
container was using that data is
available for the next container as well
so the volumes that the containers users
are very
reusable volumes and like i said it's
isolated application so it kind of
isolates by its nature it kind of by the
way it's designed by the way it is
created it isolates one container from
another container meaning anytime you
run applications on different containers
you can be rest assured that they are
very much isolated though they are
running on the same host though they're
running on the same laptop let's say
though they're running on the same
physical machine let's say running 10
containers 10 different applications you
can be sure that they are
well disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ecs the advantage of ecs
is improved security its security is
inbuilt in ecs with ecs we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where
all your images are stored and those
images are accessed only through https
not only that those images are actually
encrypted and access to those images are
allowed and denied through identity and
access management policies iam and
in other words let's say two container
running on the same instance now one
container can have access to s3 and the
others or the rest of the others are
denied access to s3 so that kind of
granular security can be achieved
through containers when we mix and match
the other security products available in
amazon like iam encryption accessing it
using https these containers are very
cost efficient like i already said these
are lightweight uh processors right we
can schedule multiple containers on the
same node and this actually allows us to
achieve high density on an ec2 instance
imagine an ec2 instance that that's very
less utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dense
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ecs not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost
efficient way of using it right and
anytime an application fails and that
has a direct impact on the revenue of
the company and he's just make sure that
you're not losing any revenue because
your application has failed and easies
and pretty extensible services it's like
this in many organizations there are
majority of unplanned work
because of environment variation a lot
of firefighting happens when we kind of
deploy the code from one or kind of move
the core or redeploy the code in a new
environment a lot of firefighting
happens there right this docker
containers are pretty extensible like we
discussed already environment is not a
concern for containers because it's
going to kind of shut itself inside a
docker container and anywhere the docker
container can run the application will
run exactly the way it performed in the
past so
environment is not a concern for the
docker containers in addition to that
ecs is
easily scalable we have discussed this
already and it improves it has improved
compatibility we have discussed this
already let's talk about the
architecture of ecs like you know now
the architecture of ecs is the ecs
cluster itself that's group of servers
running the ecs service and it
integrates with docker right so we have
a docker registry docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ecs is of three
components one is the ecs cluster itself
right when i say easiest itself i'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository where the images
will be stored right the repository
where the images will be stored and the
image itself so container image is the
template of instructions which is used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the os what is the version of
node that should be running and any
additional software do we need so those
question gets answered here so it's the
template template of instructions which
is used to create the containers and
then the registry is the service where
the docker images are stored and shared
so many people can store
there and many people can access or if
there's another group that wants to
access they can access the image from
there or one person can store the image
and rest of the team can access them the
rest of the team can store image and
this one person can pick the image from
there and kind of ship it to the
customer or ship it to the production
environment all that's possible in this
container registry and amazon's version
of the container registry is ecr and
there's a third party docker itself has
a container registry that's docker hub
ecs itself which is the the group of
servers that runs those containers
so these two the container image and the
container registry they kind of handle
docker in an image format just an image
format and in ecs is where the container
gets live and then it becomes and
compute resource and starts to handle
requests now starts to serve the page
and starts to do the batch job you know
whatever your plan is with that
container so the cluster of servers ecs
integrates well with the familiar
services like vpc vpc is known for
securing vpc is known for isolating the
whole environment from rest of the
customers or isolating the whole
environment or the whole infrastructure
from the rest of the clients in your
account or from the rest of the
applications in your account on and on
so vpc is a service that provides or
gives you the network isolation ecs
integrates well with vpc and this vpc
enables us to launch aws resources such
as amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private network that we specified this
is basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at
the ecs how does ecs work let's find
answer for this question how does ecs
work ecs has got a couple of components
within itself so these ecs servers can
run across availability zone as you can
see there are two availability zones
here they can actually run across
availability zones and ecs has got two
modes far gate mode and the ec2 mode
right here we're seeing fargate mode and
then here we're seeing nothing that
means it's an ec2 mode and then it has
got different network interfaces
attached to it because they need to be
running in an isolated fashion right so
anytime you want network isolation you
need separate ip and if you want
separate ip you need separate network
interface card and that's what you have
elastic network interface card separate
elastic network interface card for all
those tasks and services and this runs
within an vpc let's talk about the far
gate service tasks are launched using
the far gate
service so we will discuss about task
what is forget now fargate is a compute
engine in ecs that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ecs is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be and full-time job so easy manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ecs that's the basic service but if you
want amazon to manage ecs and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so farget is a compute engine in ecs
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ecs
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see task right here so they have two
components we have
ecs container instance
and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
ecs container instance is actually an
ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ecs container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that
the version
needed is present so it's all part of
that agent or it's all job of that agent
container instances container instances
is part of amazon ec2 instance which run
amazon ecs container agent pretty
straightforward definition and then a
container agent is responsible for
communication between ecs and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running containers kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the content is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and
then elastic network interface card is a
virtual interface network that can be
connected to an instance in vpc so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of
ecs container instances it's not
something that's very difficult to
understand it's simply a group of ec2
instances that runs that ecs agent and
this cluster in cluster handles the
process of scheduling monitoring and
scaling the request we know that ecs can
scale the containers can scale how does
it scale that's all monitored and
managed by this ecs cluster let's talk
about the companies that are using
amazon ecs there are variety of
companies that use
ecs clusters to name a few octa users
easiest cluster and octa is a product
that use identity information to grant
people access to applications on
multiple devices at any given point of
time they make sure that they have a
very strong security protection so octa
uses amazon ecs to run their octa
application and serve their customers
and abima abhima is an uh tv channel and
they chose to use microservices and
docker containers they already had
microservices and docker containers and
when they thought about a service that
they can use
in aws ecs was the only service that
they can immediately adapt to and
because in abima tv the engineers have
already been using docker and docker
containers it was kind of easy for them
to adapt themselves to ecs and start
using it along with the benefits that
ecs provides previously they had to do a
lot of work but now ecs does it for them
all right similarly remind and ubisoft
gopro are some of the famous companies
that use amazon ecs and get benefited
from its scalability get benefited from
its cost gets benefited from its
amazon managed services get benefited
from the portability that ecs and the
migration option that ecs provides let's
talk about how to deploy a docker
container on amazon acs the way to
deploy docker container on ecs is first
we need to have an aws account and then
set up and run our first ecs cluster so
in our lab we're going to use
the launch wizard to run an ecs cluster
and run containers in them and then task
definition task definition tells the
size of the container the number of the
container and when we talk about size it
tells how much of cpu do you need how
much of memory do you need and talking
about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container are you going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some advanced configuration on ecas like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow when you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
ip that you want to allow and deny
requests from on and on and this is
where we would also mention the name of
the container so to differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the service you know is it an a backup
job is it a web application is it a data
container
is it going to take care of your data
data back end and the desired number of
tasks that you want to be running all
the time those details go in when we try
to configure the ecs service right and
then you configure cluster you put in
all the security in the configure your
cluster step or configure cluster stage
and finally we will have an
instance and bunch of containers running
in that instance all right let's do a
demo so here i have logged in to my
amazon portal and let me switch to the
appropriate region i'm going to pick not
virginia north virginia look for ecs and
it tells ecs as a service that helps to
run and manage docker containers well
and good click on it i'm in north
virginia just want to make sure that i'm
in the right region and go to clusters
and here we can create cluster this is
our far gate and this is our ec2 type
launching for linux and windows
environment but i'm going to launch
through this walkthrough portal right
this gives a lot of information here so
the different steps involved here is
creating a container definition which is
what we're going to do right now and
then a task definition and then service
and finally the cluster it's a four step
process so in container definition we
define the
image the base image we are going to use
now here i'm going to launch an uh httpd
or a simple http webpage right so a
simple httpd 2.4 image is fair enough
for me and it's not a heavy application
so 0.5 gigabit of memory is enough and
again it's not a heavy application so
0.25 virtual cpu is enough in our case
right you can edit it based on the
requirement you can always edit it and
because i'm using hdpd the port mapping
is already port 80 that's how the
container is going to receive the
request and there's no health check as
if now when we want to design critical
and complicated environments we can
include health check right and this is
the cpu that we have chose we can edit
it and i'm going to use some bash
commands to
create an html page right this page says
that you know amazon ecs sample app
right and then it says amazon ecs sample
app your application is running on a
container in amazon ecs so that's the
page the html page that i'm going to
create or index.html so i'm going to
create and put it in an appropriate
location so those pages can be served
from the container right if you replace
this with any of your own content then
it's going to be your own content ecs
comes with some basic
logs and these are the places where they
get stored that's not the focus as of
now all right so i was just saying that
you can edit it and customize it to your
needs we're not going to do any
customization now we're just getting
familiar with ecs now and the task
definition name of the task definition
is
first one task definition and then
we are running it in a vpc and then this
is an far gate mode meaning the servers
are completely handled by amazon and the
task memory is 0.5 gigabit and the tar
cpu is 0.25 virtual cpu
name of the service
is it a batch job is it an you know a
front-end is it a back-end or is it a
simple copy job what's the service name
of the service goes here again this you
can edit it and here's a security group
as of now i'm allowing 480 to the whole
world if i want to restrict to a certain
ip i can do that the default option for
load balancing is a no load balancer but
i can also choose to have a load
balancer and use port 80 to map that 480
to the container put 80 right i can do
that the default is no load balancer all
right let's do one thing let's use load
balancer let's use load balancer and
port 80 that receives information on
port 80 http uh what's going to be the
cluster name we're in the last step what
is the cluster name cluster name can be
simply learn ecs demo next we're done
and we can create so it's launching a
cluster as you can see and it's picking
the task definition file that we've
created and it's using that to launch
and service and then these are the log
groups that we discussed and it's
creating a vpc remember ecs clubs well
with the vpc it's creating a vpc and
it's creating two subnets here for high
availability it's creating that security
group port 80 allowed to the whole world
and then it's putting it behind
and load balancer it generally would
take like five to ten minutes so we just
need to be patient and let it complete
its creation and once this is complete
we can simply access these servers using
the load balancer url and when this is
running let me actually take you to
the other products or the other services
that are integrated with the ecs it's
getting created our service is getting
created as of now ecr repository this is
where all our images are stored now as
of now i'm not pulling my image from ecr
i'm pulling it directly from the
internet docker docker hub but all
custom images all custom images they are
stored in this repository so you can
create a repository call it
app one create a repository so here's my
repository so any image that i create
locally or any docker image that i
create locally i can actually push them
push those images using these commands
right here and they get stored here and
i can make my ecs connect with ecr and
pull images from here so they would be
my custom images and as of now because
i'm using a default image it's directly
pulling it from the internet let's go to
ec2 and look for
a load balancer because we wanted to
access the application from behind a
load balancer right so here is a load
balancer created for us
and anytime i put the url so cluster is
now created you know you see there's one
service running all right let's click on
that cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the tasks the
different containers that
we are running and if you click on it we
have an ip right ip of that container
and it says it's running it was created
at such and such time and started at
such and such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
uses meaning the template the details to
all the version details they all come
from here and it belongs to the cluster
called
simply learn ecs demo right and you can
also get some logs container logs from
here so let's go back and there are no
ecs instances here because remember this
is forget you're not managing any ecs
instance all right so that's why you're
not seeing any ecs instance here so
let's go back to tasks and go back to
the same page where we found the ip pick
that ip put it in the browser and you
have this
sample html page running from an
container so let me go back to load
balancer ec2 and then under ec2 i'll be
able to find a load balancer find that
load balancer pick that dns name put it
in the browser and now it's accessible
to the load balancer url right now this
url can be mapped to other services like
dns this url can be embedded in any of
your application if you want to make
that application connect with this
container now using ip is not all that
advisable because these containers can
die and then a new container gets
created and when a new container gets
created it gets a new ip right so a hard
coding ip is
not hardcoding dynamic ips are not
advisable so you would be using load
balancer and putting that url in that
application that you want to make it
interact with this container instance it
was a wonderful experience in walking
you through this ecs topic and in here
we learned about what aws is and why
we're using ecs and what is easiest in
general what is docker in specific and
we also learn about the advantages of
ecs the architecture the different
components of ecs and how ecs works when
they're all connected together and we
also looked at the companies that use
ecs and their use cases and finally a
lab how we can launch ecs fargate
through the portal i'm very glad to walk
you through this lesson about route 53.
so in this section we are going to talk
about
basics of aws and then we're going to
immediately dive into
why
why we need amazon route 53 and then
we're going to expand and talk about the
details of amazon route 53 the benefits
it provides over its competitors and the
different types of routing policy it has
and some of amazon ralph 53's key
features and we're going to talk about
how to access route 53 i mean the
different ways the different methods you
can access route 53 and finally we're
going to end with an a wonderful demo in
drought 53 so let's talk about what is
aws amazon web services or aws in short
is a cloud provider that offers a
variety of services such as a variety of
id services or infrastructure services
such as a compute power database content
delivery and other resources that helps
us to scale and grow our business and
aws is hard aws is picking up aws is
being adapted by a lot of customers
that's because aws is easy to use even
for a beginner and talking about safety
the the aws infrastructure is designed
to keep the data safe irrespective of
the size of the data with small data be
it
very minimal data be it all the data
that you have in terabytes and in
petabytes amazon can keep it safe in
their environment and the wonderful
thing and the most important reason why
a lot of customers move into the cloud
is that the pay-as-you-go pricing there
is no long-term commitment and it's very
cost effective what this means is that
you're not paying for resource that
you're not using in on-premises you do
pay for resources you're not using a lot
meaning you go and buy a server you do
the estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60 days 70
80 and then 100. so what you have done
is that even though you're not using the
full capacity you still have bought it
and are and are paying for it from day
one but in the cloud it's not like that
you only pay for the resources that you
use anytime you want more you scale up
the resource and you you pay for the
scaled up resource and anytime you want
less you scale down the resource and you
pay less for that scaled down resource
let's talk about why amazon route 53
let's take this scenario where rachel is
trying to open her web browser and
the url that she hit isn't working a lot
of reasons behind why the url isn't
working it could be the server
utilization that went high it could be
it could be the memory usage that went
high a lot of reasons and she starts to
think is there an efficient way to scale
resources according to the user
requirements or is there an efficient
way to kind of mask all those failures
and kind of divert the traffic to the
appropriate active you know active
resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is tom tom is an i.t guy and he
comes with an idea and he's answering
rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using amazon rod 53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more high availability to our customers
with the use of route 53 and then he
goes on and explains amazon rough 53 is
a dns service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key amazon
route 53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers would experience you
still will have downtime in your server
and your application but your customers
will not be made aware of it and then
rachel is kind of interested and she's
like yeah that sounds interesting i want
to learn more about it and tom goes on
and explains the important concepts of
amazon rock 53 that's everything that
i'm gonna explain it to you as well all
right so what is amazon rat53 amazon
drop 53 is a highly scalable dns or
domain name system web service this
service this amazon raw 53 it functions
three main things or it has three main
functions so the first thing is if a
website needs a name route 53 registers
the name for the website domain let's
say you want to buy google.com you want
to buy the domain name let's say you
want to buy that domain name you buy
that through rot53 secondly a route53 is
the service that actually connects your
server which is running your application
or which is holding which is serving
your web page so that's the service that
actually route 53 is the service that
connects the user to your server when
they hit google.com in the browser or
whatever domain name that you have
purchased so you bought a domain name
and the user types in yourdomainname.com
and then roth53 is a service that helps
the user to connect their browser to the
application that's running in an ec2
instance or any other server that you
are using to serve that content and not
only that route53 checks health of the
resource by sending automated requests
over the internet to a resource so
that's how it identifies if there is any
resource that has failed can i say
resource i'm referring to any
infrastructure failure any application
level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before the customer notices it and then
it does the match it kind of shifts the
connection from a one server to the
other server we call it routing we will
talk about that as we progress so the
benefits of using route53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased ralph 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by amazon uh the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
without you interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that
it's very consistent it has the ability
to route the users to the appropriate
application through the logic that it
has it's very easy to use when we do the
lab you're gonna see that it's very easy
easy to use you buy the domain name and
then you simply map it to the
application you simply map it to the
server by putting in the ip or if you
you can simply map it to another load
balancer by putting in the load balancer
url you can simply map it to another
s3 bucket by simply putting the s3
bucket name or the s3 bucket url it's
pretty straightforward easy to set up
and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of
money here so the billing is set up in
such a way that you are paying only for
the amount of requests that
you have received right the amount of
traffic the amount of requests that you
have received and couple of other things
the the number of uh
posted zones that you have created right
and a couple of other things it's very
cost effective in such a way that you
only pay for the service that you are
using and it's secure in a way that
access to route 53 is uh integrated with
identity and access management iam so
you only have authorized users
gain access to route 53 the trainee who
just joined us today won't get access
and the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that particular
person because he's not the admin or
he's not a privileged user in your
account so only privileged users and
admin gain access to route 53 through
iam now let's talk about the routing
policies so when you create a record in
in route 53 recorder is nothing but an
entry so when you do that you choose a
routing policy right routing policy is
nothing but it determines how route 53
responds to your queries how the dns
queries are being responded right that's
that's a record or that's a routing
policy so the first one is a simple
routing policy so we use simple
routing policy for a single resource in
other words simple routing allows to
configure dns with no special route 53
routing it's kind of one to one you use
an single resource that performs a given
function to your domain for example if
you want to simply map an url to a web
server that's pretty straightforward
simple routing so it routes traffic to a
single resource example web server to a
website and with simple routing multiple
records with the same name cannot be
created
but multiple values can be created in
the same record the second type of
routing policy is failover routing so we
would be using failover routing when we
want to configure active passive
failover if something failed right you
want to fail over to the next resource
which was previously the backup resource
now the active resource or which was
previously the backup server now it's an
active server so you would be failing
over to that particular resource or that
particular ip if you want to do that you
use failover routing so failover routing
routes traffic to a resource when the
resource is healthy or to a different
resource when the previous resource is
unhealthy in other words anytime a
resource goes unhealthy i mean it does
all that's needed to shift the traffic
from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can draw
traffic to
anything from an
amazon
s3 bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of records now when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that route 53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can route traffic to amazon s3
bucket or to a website that has complex
tree of records geo location routing
policy now geo location routing just
like the name says it uh takes that
routing decision based on the geographic
location of the user in other words you
know when you want to roll traffic based
on the location of the user that's your
primary criteria for you know sending
that request to the appropriate server
we will be using geo location routing so
it localizes the content and presents a
part or the entire website in the
language of the user for example a user
from us you would want to direct them to
an english website and a user from
german if you want to send them to the
german website and a user from france
you know you want to send those requests
or you want to show content specific to
a customer who lives in france a french
website so this is if that's your
condition this is the routing policy we
would be using and the geographic
locations are specified by either
continent or by country or by state in
the united states so only in the united
states you can actually split it to
state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be your proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity
routing so geoproximity routing routes
traffic to the resources based on the
geographic location of the user and the
resources they want to access and it
also has an option to route more traffic
or less to a given resource by
specifying a value known as
bias kind of weight but we also have
weighted routing that's different so
we've chosen different name bias you can
send more traffic to a particular
resource by having a bias on that
particular routing condition and a bias
expands or shrinks the size of the
geographic region from which traffic is
routed to a resource and then we have
latency based routing just like the name
says we use latency based routing if we
have resources in multiple aws regions
and if you want to route traffic to the
region that provides the best latency at
any given point of time so
let's say if one single website needs to
be installed and hosted on multiple aws
regions then latency routing policy is
what is being used it improves the
performance of the users by serving the
request from the aws region that
provides the lowest latency so at any
given point if performance is your
criteria and at any given point of time
irrespective of what happens in amazon
infrastructure irrespective of what
happens in the internet if you want to
route your users to the best performing
website best performing region then we
would be using latency based routing and
for using latency based routing we
should create latency records for the
resources in multiple aws regions and
then the other type of
a routing policy is a multi-value
routing policy where we can make route
53 to respond to dns queries with up to
eight healthy records selected at
random so you're not kind of loading
one particular server we can define
eight records and on a random basis
route 53 will respond to queries from
these eight records so it's not one
server that gets all the requests but
eight servers
gets the request in a random fashion so
it's multi-value routing policy and what
we get by this is that we are
distributing the traffic to many servers
instead of just one server so
multi-value routing configures route 53
to return multiple values in response to
a single or multiple dns queries it also
checks the health of order sources and
returns the multiple values only for the
healthy resources let's say out of the
eight servers we have define one server
is not doing healthy it will not respond
to the query with the details of the
unhealthy server right so now it's going
to treat it as only seven servers in the
list because one server is unhealthy and
it has the ability to return multiple
health checkable ip addresses to improve
availability and load balancing the
other type of routing policy is weighted
routing policy and in here we use
to route traffic or this is used to
route traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a sub domain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you're doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of the software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you have launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
will be using weighted routing now let's
talk about the key benefits or key
features of route 53 some of the key
features of route 53 are a traffic flow
it routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right it uses a routing policy
a latency based routing policy and jio
based routing policy and then failover
routing policy so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of route 53 is we
can buy domain names using a roth 53
using route 53 console we can buy it
from here and use it in route 53
previously it was not the case but now
we can buy it directly from amazon
through route 53 and we can assign it to
any resources that we want so anybody
browsing that url the connection will be
directed to the server in aws that runs
our website a health checks it monitors
health and performance of the
application so it comes with an health
check attached to it health check are
useful to make sure that the unhealthy
resources are retired right the
unhealthy resources are taken away or
your customers are not kind of hitting
the unhealthy resources and they see an
service down page or something like that
we can have weighted
round robin load balancing that's
helpful and spreading traffic between
several
services or servers we are round robin
algorithm so no one server is fully hit
or no one server kind of fully absorbs
all the traffic you know you can shift
you can split and shift the traffic to
different servers based on the weight
that you would be configuring and also
weighted routing also helps with
a soft launch soft launch of your new
application or the new version of your
website there are different ways we can
access amazon route 53. so you can
access amazon route 53 through aws
console you can also access amazon route
53 using aws sdks and we can access it
using we can configure it using the apis
and we can also do it through the
command line interface that's linux type
linux flavor aws command line interface
we can also do that using windows
command line windows powershell flavored
command line interface as well now let's
look at some of the companies that are
using ros 53 so some of the famous
companies that use route 53 are
medium medium is an online publishing
platform and
it's more like a social
journalism it's kind of having hybrid
collection of
professionals people and publications or
exclusive
blogs or publishers on medium it's kind
of an blog website and that uses roth 53
for the dns service reddit is an
social news aggregation or web content
rating and discussion website that uses
wrought 53 so these are some websites
that that are accessed throughout the
world and they are using roth 53 and
it's highly scalable certainly there is
a new news right their website will be
accessed a lot and
they need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise
customers will end up in a broken page
and
the number of customers who will be
using the website will come down so it's
very critical these sites these
companies are very critical you know
they're being highly available their
page their site being highly available
and the internet is very critical and
crucial for them and they rely and use
route 53 to meet that particular demand
and airbnb is
another company
in staccard kozara is another company
stripe is another company that uses
route53 to as their dns
provider for the dns service they use
route 53 so their customers get best
performance they use raw 53 so their
website is highly available they use
route 53 to kind of shift to the traffic
between the resources so their resources
are properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly used
now let's quickly look at a demo i'm in
my aws console and i'm in rot53 so let
me click on rot53 so in this lab we're
actually going to simulate buying a
domain name and then we're going to
create an s3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this
dns name right so the procedure is the
same for mapping load balancer the
procedure is the same for mapping
cloudfront the procedure is the same for
mapping ec2 instances as well we're
picking s3 for simplicity right but our
focus is actually on route 53. so let's
go in here and we'll see if we can
we will buy a domain name here so let's
first check the availability of a domain
name called simply learn hyphen demo
hyphen route 53 let's check its
availability it is available for 12
dollars so let me add it to cart and
then come back here and then once you
continue it'll ask for personal
information once you give the personal
information you finally check out and
then it gets added to your shopping list
once you pay for it amazon takes like 24
to 40 hours to make that a dns name
available so the next stage would be
contact details and then the third stage
would be
verify and purchase so once we have
bought the domain name it will become
available in our dns portal and i do
have a domain name which i bought some
time back and it's now available for me
to use so i can go to hosted zone and
simply start creating i can go to hosted
zone and then here it's going to list
all the domain names for me right click
on the domain name and then click on the
record set and here
again actually map elastic load balancer
s3 website vpc endpoint api gateway and
cloudfront elastic bean stock domain
names right all that gets mapped through
this portal quite simple like four or
five step button clicks and then it'll
be done so i have an
domain name bot and then i'm going to go
to s3 and now i'll show you what i've
done in s3 so i've created a bucket name
called as
a dns name let me clear the content in
them so i've created a bucket and then
permissions i've turned off public
access blocking and then i've created
and a bucket policy so this bucket is
now publicly accessible and then i went
on the properties and created the static
website hosting right and i've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that i'm going to put or name of
the file that's going to be my index
file that i'm going to put in this s3
bucket so put the index file.html saved
it and
we're going to create a file now we're
going to create an index file so this is
a sample code it says amazon.53 getting
started routing internet traffic to s3
bucket for your website and then a
couple of other information so save it
as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital i so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that i spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this url and it does
it's running through the static website
url we're halfway through so now let me
go back to route53 go back to route53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and i i
see my s3 static website endpoint there
let's click on it and create it has now
created an record that's pointing my
domain name to the s3 endpoint that i
have created and my static website is
running from it so let me test it right
so let me go to the browser put the
domain name in there and sure enough the
domain name when my browser queried for
the domain name a route53 returned a
response saying this domain name is
actually mapped to the s3 bucket static
website hosting enable s3 bucket and
this is the url for that static website
hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that s3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser all right so it's that
simple and pretty straight forward
today's session is on aws elastic bean
stock so what's in it for you today
we'll be discussing about what is aws
why we require aws elastic bean stock
what is aws elastic bean stock the
advantages disadvantages the components
of uh mean stock along with that the
architecture and the companies that are
primarily using the aws bean stock so
let's get started and first understand
what is aws aws stands for amazon web
services it's a cloud provider and that
offers a variety of services such as
compute power database storage content
delivery and many other resources so we
know that aws is the largest
cloud provider in the market and so many
services are available in the aws where
you can apply the business logics and
create the solutions using the cloud
platforms now why aws elastic bean stock
now what happened earlier and that
whenever the developer used to create
the software or the modules related to
the softwares it has to be joined
together to create a big application now
one developer creates a module that has
to be shared with another developer and
if the developers are geographically
separated then it has to be shared over
a medium probably an internet so that is
going to take some time uh it would be a
difficult process and in return it uh
makes the application or a software
development a lender
the building of the software development
lend their process so there were
challenges which the developers were
facing earlier and to overcome that uh
we have the mean stock as a service
available in the aws so why aws elastic
bean stock is required
aws elastic being stock has made the
life of the developers quite easy
in terms of that they can share the
applications across different devices at
a shorter time duration now let's
understand what is aws elastic bean
stock
aws elastic bean stock is a service
which is used to deploy and scale web
applications by developers not only web
application any application that is
being developed by the developers this
is a simple representation of the aws
elastic beam stock now along with that
the aws elastic beam stock supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net php
node.js python rubygo and docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with aws to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic bean stock first advantage
is that it's a highly scalable service
now when we talk about a scalability it
means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic bean
stock is a highly scalable service now
that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second advantage
associated with the beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the bean stock what the beanstalk is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the bean stock it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the url or
through the ip address the third
advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you're
good to go the other advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have a
virtually isolated environments created
on the bean stock and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
a separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then it is a flexible also now coming to
the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the beanstalk then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
beanstalk services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the aws services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the aws mean stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the aws bean
stock and it has to be created in the
form of a sequence manner so aws elastic
bin stock consists of few important
components which are required while
developing an application now what are
these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment tier and we have to progress
while deploying our applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand what are the different
components of the beanstalk are the
application it refers to a unique label
which is used as a deployable code for a
web application so generally you deploy
your web application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically
used as a unique label then the second
component is application versions so it
resembles a folder which stores a
collection of components
such as environments versions and
environment configurations so all these
components are being stored using the
application version the third most
important component is the environment
in the environment only the current
versions of the applications runs now
remember that elastic means stock
supports multiple versions as well and
using the environment you can only run
the current version of the application
for if you wanted to have another
version of an application to be running
then you have to create another
environment for that then comes the
environment here and in the environment
here it is basically it designates the
type of application that the environment
runs on now generally there are two
types of environment here one is the web
and the other one is the worker node and
that's something which we'll be
discussing later as well now let's
understand how does elastic beam stock
in aws works so first we have to create
an application and this is a task that
would be done by the developers and for
that you can actually select any runtime
environment or a programming language
like java docker ruby gopal or python as
well and once you select that
environment
you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the aws and after that
once the version is uploaded and then
you have to launch your environment so
just have to click on the buttons that's
it nothing more you have to do once the
environment is
launched then you can actually view that
environment using a web url or using the
ip address now what happens in that case
is when you launch an environment in the
back end the elastic bean stock runs
automatically runs an ec2 instance and
using a metadata the mean stock deploys
our application within that ec2 instance
that is something which you can look
into the ec2 dashboard as well so you
don't have to take care of the security
groups you don't have to take care of
the ip addressing and even you don't
have to log in into the instance and
deploy your application it would be done
automatically by the bean stock it's
just that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the beanstalk
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the
cloudwatch logs as well now in case if
you wanted to update any kind of a
version then you just upload a new
version and then just deploy that and
then monitor your environment so these
are the essentials to create a local
applications for any platform whether
it's a node.js python etc these are the
things that you have to actually take
care and this is the sequence you have
to follow while creating an environment
so you can say that it's a four steps
creation offer or deployment of your
application that's it now after users
upload their versions the configuration
is automatically deployed with a load
balancer yes and with the load balancer
that means you can access the
applications using the load balancer dns
also and apart from load balancer if you
wanted to put any other feature that
includes the auto scaling for example if
you wanted to create your ec2 instances
where the application will be deployed
within the virtual private cloud or in a
particular subnet within the vpc all
those features that are available and
you can select them using the mean stock
itself you don't have to move out to the
vpc you don't have to actually go to the
ec2 dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the url so once the environment is
created there will be a url defined now
you can put a url name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
url and then you have to use that url to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
monitored provided capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and multi
features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
aws elastic bean stock now there are two
types of environments that you have to
select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment so based on the
client requirement beanstalk gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front end
facing that means the client should be
accessing this environment directly
using a url so mostly web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the backend
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the http request from
the client so that's why we use the web
server environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the http https requests so it's
not only the http you can use the https
as well the worker environment it
process background task and minimizes
the consumption of resources so again it
is just like a kind of a micro service
or an application services that are
running in the back end to support the
web server environment now coming to the
understanding of the aws mean stock so
this is how the architecture of the aws
bean stock is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the amazon route 53 sends this request
to the elastic load balancer now
obviously we discussed here that the web
server environment is primarily an
environment which receives the http
request it's a kind of a client-facing
environment now if the application
receives a client request amazon from
the amazon route 53 this route 53 is a
service which is primarily used for dns
mapping it's a global service and it may
route you can route the traffic from the
route 53 matching your domains towards
the load balancer and from the load
balancer you can point that traffic to
the web server environment obviously the
web server environment is nothing it's
just the ec2 instances that would be
running in the back end now here in the
diagram you can see that there are two
web server environments and they are
created in the auto scaling group that
means there is some kind of scaling
options that are defined as well and
these instances are created in an
availability zone or they can be created
in a different availability zone also
for the redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
rds database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests amazon route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
requests among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ac2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own security group they
can have a common security group also
they can have their own security group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this auto scaling group is
would be defined from the beanstalk
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability resource
obviously there will be an internal
health check that the load balancer will
be first doing before distributing the
real time traffic to this instances
created by the mean stock now what does
autoscaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
auto scaling you might have the scaled
down option also scaled down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic beanstalk and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default
security group and the security group
acts as a firefall for the instances now
here in this diagram it says about the
security group auto scaling also you
might create it in a default vpc also
you might create it in your custom vpc
also where you can have the additional
level of security is also created you
can have the nacls knuckles also defined
here before the security groups so that
would give you the additional filtering
option or the firewall option now it
says that with these groups with these
security groups it allows establishing
security groups to the database server
as well so every database would also
have its own security group and the
connection can be created between the
web servers environment that is created
by the beanstalk to the database
security groups as well now let's
discuss about the worker environment now
understanding the worker environment
what happens is that the client the web
server environment is the client facing
the client sends a request for an access
to the web server and in this diagram
the web server further sends it to the
sqs which is a simple queue service and
the queue service sends it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the back
end that environment initiates and
then send back uh the results to this
sqs and vice versa so let's understand
the architecture of a aws elastic bean
stock with the worker environment so
when a worker environment here is
launched aws elastic mean stock installs
the server on every ec2 instance so that
is in the case of a web server
environment also and later the server
passes the request to the simple queue
service now this service is an
asynchronous service instead of a simple
queue service you can have other
services also it is not necessary that
you need to have the sqs also this is an
example that we are discussing about and
the sqs shares those message via a post
request to the http path over the worker
environment and there are many case
studies also with respect to this kind
of an environment that is being created
that has been done on many customers
and you can search for these kind of a
case studies available on the internet
now the worker environment executes the
task given by the sqs with the http
response after the operation is
completed now here what happens is a
quick recap the client request for an
access of an application to a web server
using an http request the web server
passes that request to the queue service
the queue service shares the message
with the worker probably a worker might
be
the manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
via the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
http response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as i said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on zillow jelly button games then you
have league of women voters ebari
these are some of the few listed
companies and obviously you search on
the aws site and you'll find many more
organizations that are using the elastic
bean stock primarily for
deploying their applications now the
next thing is to go with the practicals
that how actually we use the elastic
bean stock so let's look into the demo
using the aws elastic bean stock now
first you have to login into the aws
console and i'm sure that you might be
having the accounts created or you can
use the im credentials as well and then
you have to select the region also now i
am in the north virginia region likewise
you can select any of the regions that
are listed here now click on the
services and you have to search for the
elastic bean stock you can find the
elastic bean stock under the compute
section so here itself you'll find the
elastic bean stock as a service now open
this service and there it will give you
an option to create an environment you
have to specifically select an
environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic bean stock
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a bean stock now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment
now the environment the application name
xyz is created you just have to select
an environment so click on create one
now and it is going to ask you that what
kind of an environment here you wanted
to select so as we discussed that there
are two types of environments one is the
web server and the other one is the
worker involved let's look into it what
is defined by the aws aw says that it
has two types of environment tiers to
support different types of web
applications web servers are standard
applications that listen for and then
process http request typically over port
number 80. workers are specialized
application that have a background
processing task that listens for message
on an amazon sqs queue workers
application post those messages to your
application by using the http response
so that's what we saw in the case of the
beanstalk slides also now the usability
of a worker environment can be anything
now we'll do a demo for creating a web
server environment so just click on
select and you we have the environment
name created now we can define our own
domain it ends with the region dot
elastic beanstalk.com let's say i look
for a domain which is xyz only that's
the environment name now i'll check for
the availability whether that domain
name is available with us or not and it
says we don't have that domain name so
probably i'll try to make it with some
other name and let's look for the
availability xyz abc and it says yes it
is available now once i deploy my
application i would be able to access
the application using this complete dns
so you can put a description
it's a demo
app that we are creating and then you
have to define a platform as well now
these are the platforms that are
supported by the aws let's say i wanted
to run a node.js environment so i'll
just click on the node.js platform the
application codes is something which is
basically developed by the developers
and you can upload the application right
now or you can do that later as well
once the environment is ready now either
you can select to create an environment
if you wanted to go with all the default
settings otherwise if you wanted to
customize it more you can click on
configure more options so let's click on
configure more options and here you
would be able to define various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the beanstalk can deploy
our applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is t2.micro but
in case if your application requires a
larger type of an instance then you can
actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can define your emi
ids also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular ami id for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features
that you can actually define here from
the dashboard and you don't have to go
to the ec2 dashboard to do the
modifications now let's go and create an
environment let's assume that we are
going with the default configuration so
this is going to create our environment
the environment is being created and you
can get the environment and the
logs defined in the dashboard itself so
you see that the beanstalk environment
is being initiated the environment is
being started and in case if there would
be any errors or if it is deployed
correctly you'll get all the logs here
itself now the environments are
basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that
it has created an elastic ip it has
checked the health of the environment
now it has created the security groups
and that would be an auto security
groups created by the bean stock and the
environment
creation has been started you can see
that elastic bean stock has amazon s3
storage bucket for your environment data
as well this is the url through which
you will be accessing the environment
but right now we cannot do that since
the environment is being created let's
click on the application name and here
you can see that it is in a gray color
that means right now the build is being
done it is being created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the url
now if i move to the ec2 instances and
see in the ec2 dashboard if i see
whether the instance is being created by
the beanstalk or not so let's see and
let's see what are the differences in
terms of creating an instance manually
and getting it created from the bean
stock so click on the easy to let's go
to the old ec2 experience that's what we
are familiar with and let's see what's
there in the dashboard so here you can
see one running instance let's open that
and the xyz environment which was
created from the beanstalk is being
initiated the instance is being
initiated and that is something which is
being done by the mean stock itself we
have not gone to the dashboard and
created it manually now in the security
groups if you see that here the aws mean
stock security groups are defined it has
the elastic ips also defined so
everything is being created by the
beanstalk itself right now let's go back
to the beanstalk and let's look into the
status of our environment whether the
color coding has been changed from gray
to green or not and here you can see the
environment is successfully created and
we have that environment colored in
green we'll access the environment and
it says it's a web server environment
its uh platform is node.js running on
64-bit amazon linux ami and it says
employs app sample application health
status is okay now the other thing is
that if you do not want to use the web
console the management console to access
the main stock then the beanstalk offers
you the elastic beanstalk cli as well so
you can install the command line
interface and then you have the command
references cli command references that
you can actually play with and get your
applications deployed using the
beanstalk itself so this is one of the
sample cli commands that you can
actually look into now let's look into
the environment let's click on the
environment and we'll be represented
with the url it says health is okay
these are the logs that you have to
follow in case if there are any issues
the platform is nodejs that is what we
selected now the next thing is you just
have to upload and deploy your
applications so just click on upload and
deploy select the version label or the
name select file and wherever your
application is hosted at just select
that upload it and deploy your
application you'll see that the like
your environment is created similarly
your application will be deployed
automatically on the instance and from
this url you will be able to view the
output it is as simple as just like you
have to follow these four steps now
let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application
so we'll just click on this url since
the beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or http port 80 for all
we can actually view that output
directly from the url so we have the
node.js running that's visible here and
after that you just have to upload and
deploy your application and then from
that url you can get the output now this
url you can map it with the root 53
service so using the root 53 dns
services the domain names can be pointed
to the elastic bean stock url and from
there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance whether you wanted to point it
to the url directly using the mean stock
you can do that otherwise as we saw in
the slides you can use the root 53
pointed to the load balancer and then
point it to the instances directly also
once it is created by the mean stock so
that was the demo guys with respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments apart from that the
operational task like system operations
you can manage all these things from the
environment dashboard itself so you have
the configurations you have the logs you
can actually check the health status of
your environment you can do the
monitoring and you can actually get the
alarms and the events here so let's say
if i wanted to if i wanted to see the
logs i can request for the logs here
itself and i'll be represented with the
full log report and i can now download
that log file and i can view the logs so
it's in the so we have this bundle locks
in the zip file all right so if you want
to see some kind of
logs with respect to elastic bean stock
activity it's in the form of a notepad
and here you can see what all
configurations the beanstalk has done on
your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring alarms events and all those
things if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
hi this is the fourth lesson of the aws
solutions architect course migrating to
the cloud doesn't mean that resources
become completely separated from the
local infrastructure
in fact running applications in the
cloud will be completely transparent to
your end users
aws offers a number of services to fully
and seamlessly integrate your local
resources with the cloud
one such service is the amazon virtual
private cloud
this lesson talks about creating virtual
networks that closely resemble the ones
that operate in your own data centers
but with the added benefit of being able
to take full advantage of aws
so let's get started
[Music]
in this lesson you'll learn all about
virtual private clouds and understand
their concept
you'll know the difference between
public private and elastic ip addresses
you'll learn about what a public and
private sudden there is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's
used you'll learn what route tables are
and when they are used
you'll understand what and that gateway
is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at network acls
and how they're used in amazon vpc
we'll also review the amazon vpc best
practices
and also the costs associated with
running a bpc in the amazon cloud
welcome to the amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section
in this section we're going to have an
overview of what amazon vpc is and how
you use it
and we're also going to have a
demonstration of how to create your own
custom virtual private cloud
we're going to look at ip addresses and
the use of elastic ip addresses in aws
and finally we'll take a look at subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
amazon vpc
and here are some other terms that are
used in vpcs
there's subnets
root tables elastic ip addresses
internet gateways nat gateways network
acls and security groups and in the next
sections we're going to take a look at
each of these and build our own custom
vpc that we'll use throughout this
course
amazon defines a vpc as a virtual
private cloud that enables you to launch
aws resources into a virtual network
that you've defined this virtual network
closely resembles a traditional network
that you'd operate in your own data
center
but with the benefits of using the
scalable infrastructure of aws
a vpc is your own virtual network in the
amazon cloud which is used as the
network layer for your ec2 resources
and this is a diagram of default vpc now
there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default vpc over the
coming lesson
but what you need to know is that a vpc
is a critical part of the exam and you
need to know all the concepts and how it
differs from your own networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own vpc from scratch which
you'll need to replicate at the end of
this so you can do well in the exam
each vpc that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the aws cloud
it's fully customizable you can select
the ip address range create subnets
configure root tables set up network
gateways define security settings using
security groups and network access
control lists
so each amazon account comes with a
default vpc that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section a vpc
can span multiple availability zones in
a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a vpc
it isn't this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default amazon vpc
which looks kind of complicated
but what we need to know at this stage
is that the cidr block for the default
vpc is always a 16 subnet mask so
in this example it's 172.31.0.0.16.
what that means is this vpc will provide
up to 65
536 private ip addresses
so in the coming sections we'll take a
look at all of these different items
that you can see on this default vpc but
why wouldn't you just use the default
vpc
well the default vpc is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing aws
but creating a custom vpc allows you to
make things more secure and you can
customize your virtual network as you
can define your own ip address range you
can create your own subnets that are
both private and public and you can
tighten down your security settings
by default instances that you launch
into a vpc can't communicate with your
own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center using something
called hardware vpn access so that you
can effectively extend your data center
into the cloud and create a hybrid
environment
now to do this you need a virtual
private gateway and this is the vpn
concentrator on the amazon side of the
vpn connection
then on your side in your data center
you need a customer gateway which is
either a physical device or a software
application that sits on your side of
the vpn connection
so when you create a vpn connection a
vpn tunnel comes up when traffic is
generated from your side of the
connection
vpc peering is an important concept to
understand
appearing connection can be made between
your own bpcs
or with a vpc in another aws account as
long as it's in the same region
so what that means is if you have
instances in vpca they wouldn't be able
to communicate with instances in vpc b
or c unless you set up a peering
connection
peering is a one-to-one relationship a
vpc can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs
but and this is important transitive
peering is not supported
in other words
vpca can connect to b and c in this
diagram but c wouldn't be able to
communicate with b unless they were
directly paired
also vpcs with overlapping cidrs cannot
be paired so in this diagram you can see
they all have different ip ranges which
is fine but if they had the same ipo
ranges they wouldn't be able to be
peered
and finally for this section
if you delete the default vpc you have
to contact aws support to get it back
again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so and
know what you're doing
this is a demonstration of how to create
a custom vpc
so here we are back at the amazon web
services management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is i'm going to click on vpc
and the vpc dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom vpc there's something called
the vpc wizard
which
will build vpcs on your behalf from a
selection of different configurations
for example a vpc with a single public
subnet or a bpc with public and private
subnets now this is great because you
click a button type in a few details and
it does the work for you however you're
not going to learn much or pass the exam
if this is how you do it so
we'll cancel that and we'll go to your
vpcs
and we'll click on create a vpc
and we're presented with the create the
vpc window so let's give our vpc a name
i'm going to call that simply learn
underscore vpc
and this is the kind of naming
convention i'll be using throughout this
course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classless inter domain routing
block
so we're going to give it a very simple
one 10.0.0.0
and then we need to give it the subnet
mask so you're not allowed to go larger
than 15. so if i try to put 15 in it
says no not going to happen
for a reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you
around 131 000 ip addresses
and
subnet 16 will give you 65
536 which is probably more than enough
for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy
there's two options default and
dedicated
if you select dedicated then your ec2
instances will reside on hardware that's
dedicated to you so your performance is
going to be great but your cost is going
to be significantly higher
so i'm going to stick with default
and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our vpc dashboard we can see
our simply learn vpc has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new vpc we
can see it has a route table associated
with it
which is our default route table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the vpc again
we can see it's been given a default
network acl
and we'll click on that and have a look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound
now if we go to the subnet section
and just
widen the vpc area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the vpc we just created
so that means we won't better launch any
instances into our vpc
and to prove it i'll just show you we'll
go to the ec2 section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson
and we'll just quickly try and launch an
instance we'll select any instance it
doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section
if i try and select simply learn vpc
it's saying
no subnets found
this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our vpc
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private ip addresses are ip
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet
and they're used for communication
between instances in the same network
when you launch a new instance is given
a private ip address and an internal dns
hostname that resolves to the private ip
address of the instance but if you want
to connect to this from the internet
it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public ip address
which is reachable from the internet
you can use public ip addresses for
communication between your instances and
the internet
each instance that receives a public ip
address is also given an external dns
hostname
public ip addresses are associated with
your instances from the amazon pool of
public ip addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public i p address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public ip address
you need to use something called an
elastic i p address
an elastic ip address is a static or
persistent public ip address is
allocated to your account and can be
associated to and from your instances as
required
an elastic ip address remains in your
account until you choose to release it
there is a charge associated with an
elastic ip address if it's in your
account but not actually allocated to an
instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic ip address
so we're back at the amazon web services
management console we're going to head
back down to the networking vpc section
and we'll get to the vpc dashboard on
the left hand side we'll click on
elastic ips
now you'll see a list of any elastic ips
that you have associated in your account
and remember any the elastic ip address
that you're using that isn't allocated
to something you'll be charged for
so i have one available and that is
allocated to an instance currently so we
want to allocate a new address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it i'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds
and there's our new elastic ip address
now we'll be using this ip address
to associate with the nat gateway when
we build that
aws defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your vpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select
you can use a public subnet for
resources that must be connected to the
internet and a private subnet for
resources that won't be connected to the
internet
the netmask for the default subnet in
your vpc is always 20 which provides up
to 4096 addresses per subnet and a few
of them are reserved for aws use
a vpc can span multiple availability
zones but the subnet is always mapped to
a single availability zone this is
important to know
so here's our basic diagram which we're
now going to start adding to
so we can see the virtual private cloud
and you can see the availability zones
and now inside each availability zone
we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your vpc
so it's good to spread them across
availability zones for redundancy and
failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private you use a public
subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet for example
web servers
a public subnet is made public because
the main route table sends the subnets
traffic that is destined for the
internet to the internet gateway and
we'll touch on internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom vpc in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and vpc
wait for the vpc dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create
and i'm going to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names
so i'm going to call this first one for
the public subnet 10.0.1.0
and i'm going to put this one in
the u.s east
1
b availability zone
and i'm going to call that
simply learn
public
so it's quite a long name i understand
but at least it makes it clear for
what's going on in this example so we
need to choose a vpc so we obviously
want to put it in our simply learn vpc
and i said i wanted to put it in us east
1b i'm using the north virginia region
by the way
so we click on that
then we need to give it the cidr block
now as i mentioned earlier when i typed
in the name
that's the range i want to use and then
we need to give it the subnet mask
and we're going to go with
24
which should give us 251
addresses in this range which obviously
is going to be more than enough if i try
and put a different value in that's
unacceptable to amazon it's going to say
it's going to give me an error and tell
me not to do that
let's go back to 24
and click kind of cut and paste this by
the way just because i need to type
something very similar for the next one
click create
and it takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and i
just widen this
you can see so that's
the ip range
that's the availability zone
it's for simply learn and it's public
so now we want to create
the private
so put the name in i'm going to give the
private the ip address block
of that
i'm going to put this one in usd 1c
and it's going to be the private
subnet
obviously i want it to be in the same
vpc
better that is the zone of us east 1c
and we're going to give it
10.0.2.0.
and we'll click yes create
again it takes a few seconds
okay so we sort by name
so there we are we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public server
all right let me just type in simply
then there we are so now you can see
them both there
and you can see they're both in the same
vpc
simply learn vpc
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the route table associated with
these vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access
so that's what we need to do next in the
next lesson you're going to learn about
internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section
in this section we're going to take a
look at internet gateways root tables
and nat devices
and we'll have a demonstration on how to
create each of these aws vpc items
so to allow your vpc the ability to
connect to the internet you need to
attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway per vpc
so attaching an internet gateway is the
first stage in permitting internet
access to instances in your vpc now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the internet
to your vpc
but before you can configure internet
correctly there's a couple more steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected you have to adhere to the
following rules
firstly you have to attach an internet
gateway to your vpc which we just
discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public ip addresses or
elastic ip addresses
so they're able to connect to the
internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnets root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and security group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance so you need to allow
the rules to let in the traffic you want
for example http traffic
after the demonstration for this section
we're going to look at how root tables
access control lists and security groups
are used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom vpc
so let's go to networking vpc
bring up the vpc dashboard and on the
left hand side we click on internet
gateways
so here's a couple of internet gateways
i have already
but i need to create a new one so create
internet gateway i'll give it a name
which is going to be simply learn
internet gateway igw and i'm going to
click create so this is an internet
gateway which will connect a vpc to the
internet because at the moment our
custom vpc has no internet access
so there it's created
simply then i gw
but it's state is detached because it's
not attached to anything so let me try
and attach it to a vpc
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no
internet gateway attached to them
currently
so i only have one which is simply then
bpc
yes attach
now you can see our vpc has internet
attached and you can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our vpc
but before any instances in our vpc can
access the internet we need to ensure
that our subnet root table points to the
internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
route table and that's what you're going
to learn about next
a root table determines where network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only be
associated with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated with the same root table
every vpc has a default root table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new route
table to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your vpc
so here's our example
and we've added two route tables the
main route table and the custom route
table
the new route table or the custom route
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
associated to the default route table
the main route table which does not
allow internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom route table
associated with our internet gateway and
associate our public subnet with it
so let's go to networking and vpc
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to
route tables
now our vpc only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given at the time it was created
so we want to create a new route table
and we want to give it a name so we're
going to call it simply learn
and we call it root table rtb for sure
and then we get to pick which vpc we
want to put it in so obviously we want
to use simplylearnedvpc
so we click create
which will take a couple of seconds and
here you are here's our new root table
so what we need to do now
is change its route so that it points to
the internet gateway so if we go down
here to roots
at a minute you can see it's just like
our main route table it just has local
access
so we want to click on edit
and we want to add another route
so the destination is
the internet which is all the zeros
and our target and we click on this it
gives us the option of our internet
gateway which we want to do
so now we have internet access to this
subnet sorry to this route table
and we click on save
save was successful so now we can see
that as well as local access we have
internet access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main route table
which doesn't have internet access
so we want to change this we'll click on
edit
and we want our public subnet to be
associated
with this route table
so click on save
so it's just saving that
so now we can see that our public subnet
is associated with this route table
and this route table
is associated with the internet gateway
so now anything we launch into the
public subnet will have internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nat device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but prevent the internet from initiating
connections with the instances in the
private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from being directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public subnet in your database in
the private subnet which has no internet
connectivity
however your private subnet database
instance might still need internet
access or the ability to connect to
other aws resources
if so you can use a network address
translation device or an app device to
do this
and that device forwards traffic from
your private subnet to the internet or
other aws services
and then sends the response back to the
instances
when traffic goes to the internet the
source ip address of your instance is
replaced with the nat device address
and when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private ip
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated and if you look in
the public subnet you can see we've now
added a nat device and you have to put
that devices in the public subnet so
that they get internet connectivity
aws provides two kinds of nat devices
and that gateway and a nat instance
aws recommends a nat gateway as it's a
managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances
each nat gateway is created in a
specific availability zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a nat
ami and amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your vpc so it's
something else you have to look after
whereas in that gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed you can pretty much forget
about it
and that gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity
it also needs an elastic ip address
which you can select at the time of
launch
once created you need to update the
route table associated with your private
subnet to point internet bound traffic
to the nat gateway
this way the instances in your private
subnets can communicate with the
internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom route table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main route table
to the nat gateway so the private subnet
also gets internet access but in a more
secure manner
welcome to the create and that gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a nat gateway so that the
instances in our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and vpc
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets and you'll
see why shortly so here are our simply
learn subnets so this is the private
subnet that we want to give internet
access but if you remember from the
section
that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets so i'm just going to copy
the name of this subnet id
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new nat gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what i'm going to do
is just paste in
the subnet id which i copied earlier
so there's no confusion
then we need to give it an elastic ip
address now if you remember from the
earlier demonstration we created one so
let's select that but if you hadn't
allocated one you could click on the
create new eip button
so
we'll do that
okay so it's telling me my nat gateway
has been created and in order to use you
on that gateway ensure that you edit
your route table to include a route with
a target of and then on that gateway id
so it's giving us the option to click on
our edit root tables so we'll go
straight there
now here's our here's our route tables
now
here's the custom route table that we
created earlier and this is the default
the main route table which was created
when we launched our when we created our
vpc
so we should probably give this a name
so that we know what it is so let me
just call this simply learn
rtb
main
so now we know that's our main route
table
so if you take a look at the main route
table
and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a route in
here that points to the nat gateway so
if we click on routes and edit
and we want to add another route
and we want to say that all traffic
can
either go to the simpson
internet gateway which we don't want to
do we want to point it to our nat
instance which is this nat id here
and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet will be able to get
internet access via on that gateway
welcome to the using security groups and
network acl section
in this section we're going to take a
look at security groups and network acls
and we're going to have a demonstration
on how you create both of these items in
the amazon web services console
the security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that about traffic to or from its
associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic for one or
more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and vpc dashboards in the aws web
management console we're going to cover
them here in this section and you'll see
them crop up again in the ec2 lesson
and here is our diagram and you can see
we've now added security groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting inside the security groups and
the security groups will control what
traffic flows in and out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server
now obviously a web server needs http
and https traffic as a minimum to be
able to access it
so here is an example of the security
group table and you can see we're
allowing http and https
the ports that are associated with those
two
and the sources and we're allowing it
from the internet we're basically
allowing all traffic to those ports
and that means any other traffic that
comes in on different ports would be
unable to reach the security group and
the instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server security group
now imagine you have a sql server
database
then you would need to open up the sql
server port so that people can access it
which is port 1433 by default so we've
added that to the table and we've
allowed the source to come from the
internet now because it's a windows
machine you might want rdp access so you
can log on and do some administration
so we've also added rdp access to the
security group now you could leave it
open to the internet but that would mean
anyone could try and hack their way into
your box so in this example we've added
a source ip address of
10.0.0.0 so only ipa ranges from that
address
can rdp to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups
by default security groups allow all
outbound traffic so if you want to
tighten that down you can do so in a
similar way to you can define the
inbound traffic
security group rules are always
permissive
you can't create rules that deny access
so you're allowing access rather than
denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound security group rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time and the rules
are applied immediately
welcome to the create security group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one the host
db servers and one the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tear your applications
into security groups and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so if we go to networking and vpc to
bring up the vpc dashboard
on the left hand side under security we
click on security groups
now you can also get to security groups
from the ec2 dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create
a new security group and we're going to
call it
simplylearn
web server
sg security group and we'll give the
group name as the same and our
description is going to be simply learn
web servers
security groups
okay and then we need to select our vpc
now it defaults to the default vpc but
obviously we want to put it in our
simply learn vpc so we click yes create
takes a couple of seconds
and there it is there's our new security
group
now if we go down to the
rules the inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules if you
remember from the lesson
a new security group by default allows
all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic
has destination of everywhere so all
traffic is allowed we want to add some
rules so let's click on inbound rules
click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http
so you can either choose custom tcp rule
and type in your own port ranges or you
can just use the ones they have for you
so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if i click on it it's giving me the
option of saying
allow
access from different security groups
so you could create a security group and
say i only accept traffic from a
different security group which is a nice
way of securing things down you could
also put in here just your ip address so
that only you could do http request to
the instance but because it's a web
server
we want
people to be able to see our website
otherwise it's not going to be much use
so we're going to say all traffic so all
source
traffic can access our instance on port
http 80.
i want to add another rule because we
also want to do https
which is
hiding from me
there we are
and again we want to do
the same
and also because this is going to be a
linux instance we want to be able to
connect to the linux instance to do some
work and configuration so we need to
give it ssh access and again it would be
good practice to tie it down to your
specific ip or an ip range
but we're just going to do all for now
and then we click on save
and there we are there we have our
ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our db servers
so let's click create security group
and then we'll go through and give it a
similar name
simply learn
db servers
sg
and
the description it's going to be simply
learn db servers security group
and our vpc is obviously going to be
simply learn vpc
so let's click yes create wait a few
seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound rules by
default and outbound rules allow all
traffic
so this is going to be a sql server
database server
and so we need to allow sql server
traffic into the instance
so we need to give
it microsoft sql port access now the
default port for microsoft sql server is
1433.
now in reality i'd probably change the
port the sql server was running on to
make it more secure
but we'll go with this for now and then
the source so we could choose the ipa
ranges again but what we want to do is
place the db server in the private
subnet and allow
the traffic to come from the web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display on its web on the website or
if people are entering information into
the website we want the information to
be stored in our db server so basically
we want to say that this the db servers
can only accept sql server traffic from
the web server security group
so we can select the simply then web
server security group as the source
traffic
for microsoft sql server data
so we'll select that now our sql server
is obviously going to be a windows
instance so from time to time we might
not might we might need to log in
and configure it so we want to give rdp
access
now again you would probably put a
specific ip range in there
we're just going to do all traffic for
now
then we click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
db servers and web servers
a network acl is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
you might set up network acls with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your vpc
here is our network diagram and we've
added network acls to the mix now you
can see they sit somewhere between the
root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
acl sits in between a route table and a
subnet
and also you can see an example of the
default network acl
which is configured to allow all traffic
to flow in and out of the subnets to
which is associated
each network acl includes a whose rule
number is an asterisk
this rule ensures that if a packet
doesn't match any of the other numbered
rules it's denied
you can't modify or remove this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound
some traffic would come in and it would
look for the first rule which is 100 and
that's saying i'm allowing all traffic
from all sources
so that's fine the traffic comes in
if that rule 100 wasn't there it would
go to the asterix rule and the aztecs
rule is saying
traffic from all sources is denied
let's take a look at the network acl
rules
each subnet in your vpc must be
associated with an acl
if you don't assign it to a custom acl
it will automatically be associated to
your default acl
a subnet can only be associated with one
acl however an acl can be associated
with multiple subnets
an acl contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest as soon as a rule
matches traffic it's applied regardless
of any higher numbered rules that may
contradict it
aws recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100 so there's plenty of
room to implement new rules at a later
date
unlike security groups acls are
stateless responses to allowed inbound
traffic are subject to the rules for
outbound traffic
welcome to the network acl demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ocls where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam we just need to
know how they work and where they are
so let's go to networking and vpc
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left-hand side under security there's
network acls so let's click on that
now you can see some acls that are in my
my aws account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learned vpc
so if we extend this vpc
column
that's our network acl simply then vpc
now let's give it a name because
it's not very clear to see otherwise
also i'm kind of an obsessive tagger so
let's call it simply learn acl and click
on the tick so there we are so now it's
much easier to see
so we click on inbound rules so this is
exactly what we showed you in the lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying allow all traffic from all
sources
and the outbound rules are the same
so if you wanted to tighten down the new
rule you could click edit would give it
a new rule number say which would be 200
so you should always increment them in
100 so that means if you had 99 more
rules you needed to put in place you'd
have space to put them in in between
these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say you know we are
allowing http access from
all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're going to
deny it so this is the way of
blacklisting traffic into your vpc
now i'm not going to save that because
we don't need it
but this is where network acls sit and
this is where you would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your acl
so we have two subnets in our simply
learn vpc so we would expect to see both
of them associated with this network acl
because it's the default
and there they are as both our public
and our private subnets are associated
and you can also see up here on the
on the dashboard it says default so this
is telling us this is our default acl
if you did want to create a new network
acl you would click create network acl
you'd give it a name
just say new acl
and then you would associate it with
your vpc so we would say simply then dpc
takes a few seconds
and there we are there we have our new
one now you can see this one says
default no because it obviously isn't
the default acl for our simply learn vpc
and it has no subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of networked acls
welcome to the amazon vpc best practices
and costs
where we're going to take a look at the
best practices and the costs associated
with the amazon virtual private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available to the internet such as
database services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets you should provide a nat device
when using nap devices you should use a
nat gateway over nat instances because
they're a managed service and require
less administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully
amazon vpc can contain from 16 to 65
536 ip addresses so you should choose
your cidr block according to how many
instances you think you'll need
you should also create separate amazon
vpcs for development staging test and
production or create one amazon vpc with
separate subnets with a subnet each for
production development staging and test
you should understand the amazon vpc
limits there are various limitations on
the vpc components for example you're
allowed 5 vpcs per region
200 subnets per vpc
200 route tables per vpc
500 security groups per vpc
50 in and outbound rules per vpc
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with aws
support
you should use security groups and
network acls to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your vpc
amazon advises to use security groups
for white listing traffic and network
acls for black listing traffic
amazon recommends tiering your security
groups
you should create different security
groups for different tiers of your
infrastructure architecture inside vpc
if you have web tiers and db tiers you
should create different security groups
for each of them
creating tier wise security groups will
increase the infrastructure security
inside the amazon vpc
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group that means
they'll automatically all have http and
https open conversely the database
security group will have sql server
ports already open
you should also standardize your
security group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows amazon vpc operation
and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your amazon vpc across
multiple subnets in multiple
availability zones inside a region
this helps in architecting high
availability inside your bpc
if you choose to create a hardware vpn
connection to your vpc using virtual
private gateway you are charged for each
vpn connection hour that your vpn
connection is provisioned and available
each partial vpn connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard aws data
transfer charges for all data
transferred via the vpn connection
if you choose to create a nat gateway in
your vpc you are charged for each nat
gateway hour that your nat gateway is
provisioned and available data
processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through the net
gateway
each partial nat gateway hour consumed
is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom vpc where you'll
create a custom vpc using the concepts
learnt in this lesson
using the concepts learnt in this lesson
recreate the custom vpc as shown in the
demonstrations
the vpc name should be simply learned
vpc
the cidr block should be 10.0.0.0.16.
there should be two subnets one public
with a range of 10.0.1 10.0.1.0
and one private with a range of 10.0.2.0
and they should be placed in separate
availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that gateway and also one custom
route table for the public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server security group and
simply learn dv server security group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
amazon virtual private cloud or vpc
enables you to launch aws resources into
a virtual network that you've defined
this virtual network closely resembles a
traditional network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of aws
there are three types of ip address in
aws
a private ip address this is an ip
address that's not reachable over the
internet
and it's used for communication between
instances in the same network
a public ip address is reachable from
the internet which you can use for
communication between your instances and
the internet and there's an elastic ip
address this is a static public
persistent ip address that persists
after an instance restarts whereas a
public ip address is raised associated
after each restart
amazon defines a subnet as a range of ip
addresses in your bpc
you can launch aws resources into a
subnet that you select and a subnet is
always mapped to a single availability
zone
use a public subnet for resources that
must be connected to the internet and a
private subnet for resources that won't
be connected to the internet
to allow your vpc the ability to connect
to the internet you need to attach an
internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one internet gateway per vpc
a route table determines where network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only have an
association with one root table however
multiple subnets can be associated to
the same root table
and you can use a nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the internet or other aws services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic to or from its
associated instances
a network access control list or network
acl is an optional layer of security for
your vpc that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
today's session is on aws sagemaker
let's look into what we have in our
today's session
so what's in it for you we would be
covering what is aws
why do we need aws sage maker
what is aws sage maker services
what are the benefits of using the aws
sagemaker
machine learning with aws sagemaker how
to train a model with aws stage maker
how to validate a model with aws
and the companies that are using aws
shmaker along with that we will be
covering up one live demo on the aws
platform
now let's understand what is aws
so
what is aws it's an amazon web services
it's a largest
or
most widely used public cloud platform
offered by amazon it provides services
over the internet
aws services can be used to build
monitor
and deploy any type of application in
the cloud
aws also uses the subscription pricing
model that means you only pay for
whatever the services you use for
now why do we need aws sagemaker let's
look into it so
let's consider an example of one of the
company that is proquest
now
before aws shmaker
the proquest is a global information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers etc to the users
before awsch maker the proquest
requirement was to have a better user
experience maximum relevant search
results now after aws sage maker they
were able to achieve those
results
so they achieved more appealing video
user experience they achieved more
relevant search results for the users
now what do we mean by aws age maker why
this service is primarily used
so
amazon sage maker is a cloud machine
learning platform
that helps users in building training
tuning and deploying machine learning
models in a production ready hosted
environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
aws platform now what are the benefits
of using aws sagemaker
the key benefits of using aw sagemaker
are
it reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization
while running
this particular service on the aws
all ml components are stored in a
particular place in a dashboard so they
can be managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable on
you can scale
this particular service on the fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains the uptime so you can be
assured that your workloads will be
running all the time it will be
available all the time
high data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms and
it ensures that you have the high data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different aws services
like s3 bucket and all
with these simple data transfer
techniques
now machine learning with aws sagemaker
let's look into it
so machine learning with aws sage maker
is a three-step function
so one is to build second is to test and
tune the model and third is to deploy
the model now with the build it provides
more than 15 widely used ml algorithms
for training purpose
now to build a model you can collect and
prepare training data or you can select
from the amazon s3 bucket also choose
and optimize the required algorithm so
some of the algorithms that you can
select are k-means linear regressions
logistic regression sagemaker helps
developers to customize ml instances
with the jupiter notebook interface
in the test and tune you have to set up
and manage the environment
for training so you would need some
sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model
with the amazon sagemaker
sagemaker implements hyper parameter
tuning
by adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters also it divides the
training data and stores that in the
amazon s3 s3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data hence it is used
for storing and recovering data over the
internet and
below you can see that aws sagemaker
uses amazon s3 to store data as it's
safe and secure also it divides the
training data and stores in amazon s3
where the training algorithm code is
stored in the ecr ecr stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and dockers ecr
helps users to save monitor and deploy
docker and the containers later
sagemaker sets up a cluster for the
input data
trains it and stores it in the amazon s3
itself so this is done by the sagemaker
itself after that you need to deploy it
so suppose you want to predict limited
data at a time
you use amazon sage maker hosting
services for that okay but if you want
to get prediction for an entire data set
prefer using amazon sagemaker batch
transform now the last step that is to
deploy the model
so once tuning is done models can be
deployed to sagemaker endpoints
and in the end point real time
prediction is performed so you would
have some data
which you would reserve and
validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not now evaluate
your model and determine whether you
have achieved your business goals
now the
other aspect is how we can train a model
with aws sagemaker
so this is basically a flow
diagram which shows you how to train a
model with the aws sagemaker and
here we have used couple of services of
an aws to get that done
so model training in aws sagemaker is
done on machine learning compute
instances
and here we can see there are two
machine learning compute instances used
as helper code and the training code
along with that we are using 2s3 buckets
and the ecr for the container registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
so below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements to train a model
the url of an amazon s3 bucket where the
training data is stored that is
mentioned
the compute resources on machine
learning compute instances so these are
all your machine learning compute
instances
then the url of an amazon s3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of aws elastic container
registry
where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the
elastic container registry now what are
these calls these are called as the
training jobs
now when a user trains a model in amazon
sage maker he she creates a training job
so we need to first create a training
job and then the input data is fetched
from the specified amazon s3 bucket
once the training job is built amazon
sage maker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the training job
is built then it trains the model with
the training code and the data set and
it shows the output and model rt crafts
in the aws s3 bucket so this is done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry
consists of multiple linear sequence
containers
that process the request for inference
on data
the ec2 container registry is a
container registry that helps users to
save monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified amazon s3 bucket
so here you can see the output will be
stored here to prevent your algorithm
being deleted save the data in amazon
sagemaker critical system
which can process you on your ml compute
instances now how to validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data so first thing is that you can do
the offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or real time streams coming you
can validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a hold out set
and also you can validate using the
k-fold validation now use historical
data to send requests to the model
through the jupiter notebook in amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation online
testing with livedata deploys multiple
models into the endpoints of amazon
sagemaker and directs live traffic to
the model for validation validating
using a holdout set
is part of the data is set aside
where which is called holdout set so
the part of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training
so later when the model is trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learnt initially so whatever the data
which is left out
will be used for
validating a model because we have not
used the data
while training a model the k-fold
validation
is
the input data is split into two parts
one part is called k
which is the validation data for testing
the model and the other part is k minus
one
which is used as a training data
now based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates the
final output now
the companies that are using aws
sagemaker one is the adp so you must be
knowing about adb zelando
dow jones which is on the stock market
proquest
and the intuit
now let's look into the demo that how we
can actually run the aws sagemaker
so we'll use the r algorithm and then
package the algorithm as a container for
building training and deploying a model
we are going to use the jupiter notebook
for that for model building for model
training for model deployment and the
code for the demo is in the below link
so you can see here that from this link
you can
get the code for the demo
let's try to
do a demo on the aws
now i would be using a link which is
provided by amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sage maker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code python codes into your
awschmaker jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model and
for that we will use the popular xt
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the aws console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance
so in this tutorial you will be creating
a notebook instance you will prepare the
data train the model to learn from the
data
deploy the model
evaluate your ml modules performance and
once all those activities are done then
we will see how we can actually remove
all the resources in order to prevent
the extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the amazon sage maker console so here
you can see i am already logged into the
sagemaker console you can click on the
services
search for the sagemaker here
and here you get the amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is
that we have to create a notebook
instance so we will select the notebook
instance from the sagemaker service
and then
after the notebook instance is selected
we'll put a name to our instance
and we'll create a new iam role for that
so let's wait for the sagemaker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on the
notebook instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created one of them is in service so
this is the notebook instance that we
are going to use for
creating the
demo model
i'll show you how you can create a
notebook instance you just have to click
on create notebook instance button
and put your notebook instance name so
you can put something like demo dash
sage maker 987 or we can put it as model
we'll go with notebook instance type as
default which is
mlt2.medium
and in the permission and encryptions
under the im role we will click on
create a new im role
now why we are creating a new im rule so
that we can allow the sage maker
to access any s3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see
that the new im role will be created
with the set of permissions
then rest of the things we'll keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on create a notebook instance
the notebook instance creation takes
some time so you just have to wait for a
couple of minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created so we
will be using
that to create a demo
now going back to the steps so these are
the steps that we have already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so
in this step we will be using the
sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data that would require
to train the machine learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
jupiter notebook
and then we have to select an
environment a kernel environment in the
jupiter notebook that would be conda
underscore python 3.
so let's
follow these steps
go back to the sage maker click on the
notebook instances
select the running notebook instance and
here you would select the open jupiter
lab
now here you would see that the
sagemaker would try to open up the
jupiter notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that jupiter notebook and
executing the results there itself so
just wait for the notebook to open
now here you can see the jupiter lab
notebook has been open so i would be
selecting one of the notebook that has
been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also how you can do
that
first of all let me select the kernel
environment so i would be selecting
corner underscore python 3
and just click on select so how you can
create your own notebook just have to
click on file click on new and here you
can select the notebook just name your
notebook select the environment conda
underscore python 3 to run this demo
so i have my notebook open so in the
tabs i would be putting up the python
codes and i would be executing those
codes to get the output directly
so the next step
is to prepare the data train the ml
model and deploy it we will need to
import some libraries
and define a few environment variables
in the jupyter notebook environment
so i would be copying this code
which you can see that would try to
import numpy pandas these are all
required to run the python
syntax
so just
copy
this code
and paste it into your
notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see
that
you get the output which is
that it has imported all the necessary
libraries that have been defined in the
code
now the next step is we would create an
s3 bucket
into the s3 service and for that you
have to copy this python code
just that you have to edit it so you
have to specify
this
bucket name that you want to get created
so here i would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap
so something like sage maker
dash
demo
is the name that i have selected for the
bucket and now you have to execute that
code
it says that the s3 bucket has been
created successfully with the name sage
maker dash demo 9876 so this is
something which you can verify so you
can go to the s3 service and there you
can verify whether the bucket has been
created or not
now the next task is that we need to
download the data
to the aws sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame and for that we
have to
follow this url so from this url
which is
build train deploy machine learning
model would have a data in the form of
bank underscore clean.csv
and this will be deployed onto our
sagemaker instance
we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and execute the code
so it says that it has successfully
downloaded bank underscore clean.csv
which is which has the data inside it
and that has been loaded into the
sagemaker data frame successfully
now we have a data to
build and train our machine learning
model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it one into the training data set
and the other one into test data stack
so for the training data set we are
going to use 70 of the customers that
are listed in the csv file and 30
of the customers in the csv file data we
will be using it as a test data to train
the model
so we will copy the following code into
a new code cell and then we are going to
run that
code cell
so i'll just
copy it
for training the data so that we can
segregate
the data model 70
for building the model and 30 for
testing the data
so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output successfully
now
we have to train the model from the data
so how we are going to train that model
and for that we will use sagemaker
pre-built xgboost model which is an
algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and first column of the training data
and load the data from the s3 bucket so
what i'll do is i'll copy
this syntax
and paste it
in the note cell
so it has the trained data it would
train
the model
click on run execution
now it is
changing the s3 input class which will
be renamed to training input because now
we are training the model with the
training data
so we just have to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sage maker session to
create an instance of the xgboost model
so here we are going to create
this sagemaker session say we are going
to create an instance of the xt boost
model which is an estimator
so just copy that copy that code
and paste it here
execute it
and here you can see that
it will start it has basically changed
the parameter image name to the
image underscore uri in this sagemaker
python sdk v2
now we will follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the xt boost
estimator we'll set up train the model
using gradient optimization
and
we'll copy the following code and that
would actually start the training of
the model
so copy
this code
and
this would actually
start training the model using our input
data that we have reserved 70 of that
data that we have reserved for training
the model
so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job
now we'll deploy the model and for that
i would copy the deploy code put that in
the cell
and execute it
so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image uri and using already existing
model so xd boost was deployed already
uh if you have not done that
if you're doing it the first time so it
will initiate another xt boost instance
so where you can find your xt boost
endpoints created you just have to
scroll down and here under the inference
click on the endpoints
and you should find the extreme boost
endpoints defined here
so here you can see that today i have
created one xt boost
endpoint
and that is uh now in process of
creating so just refresh it
so it is
still created is going to take some time
to get that in service
now our endpoint is in service state so
now we can use it so
going forward with the next steps we'll
try to predict whether the customer in
the test data enroll for the bank
product or not for that we are going to
copy this code put that in the jupiter
cell function
and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has actually evaluated and the same
output we got in the screenshot
of the demo as well
now we are going to evaluate the model
performance so what we are going to do
we are going to get the prediction done
so based on the prediction we can
conclude that you predicted a customer
that will enroll for a certificate of
deposit accurately for 90 of the
customers in the test data with the
precision of 65 percent for enrolled and
90
which are which haven't enrolled for it
so for that we are going to copy this
code
and execute it here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is working absolutely
fine so here you can say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate
prediction that has been made by the
model and that's what the output we can
see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been built deployed and
trained correctly
now the next thing is that once you are
done with that you terminate your
resources and for that you just have to
copy
uh this code and put that in the cell
function so that the additional
resources and the endpoints and the
buckets that have been created by the
jupiter notepad should be
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the extra costing so just
execute it and here you would see that
it has tried to it would try to
terminate all the additional resources
that we have created from the jupyter
notebook today's tutorial is on aws
cloudfront let's look into what we have
today in the cloud front
so what's in it for you
we would be covering up the concept of
what is aws
what was earlier uh before aws
cloudfront after aws cloudfront what
were the services that were introduced
how it benefited what do we mean by aws
cloudfront benefits of the using aws
cloudfront and how aws cloudfront
actually is known as a content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using aws cloudfront and we would be
covering up on live demo
now aws is the amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple services variety of
services such as
compute power database storage
networking and other resources so that
you can
create your solutions on the cloud and
help the business grow now with aws you
only pay for whatever the services you
use so for example if you are using a
service for a couple of hours then you
pay for only that many hours that you
have used that service
before aws cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be
aware of an application called spotify
so when you used to access spotify and
when you click on it it kept on loading
and at the end you used to get the error
and the error was that the connection
failed and why you received that error
because of a latency issue probably a
network error right so how you can solve
these kind of a latency issues and that
is also going to these kind of an issues
are also going to impact the performance
of an application
so
with the introduction of aws cloud from
this problem of loading the application
got resolved so after aws cloud front
with the help of adobe snow front
spotify gives the facility of updating
new features access to million songs
that you can access instantly
so with the use of aws cloud front or
the latency issues were solved and
successfully you can
basically access your application now
what we mean by aws cloudfront so aws
cloudfront is a globally distributed
network that is offered by aws amazon
web services which securely delivers
content to the end users across any
geography
with a higher transfer speed and an
improve or a low latency now what are
the benefits of aws cloudfront there are
multiple benefits one is the cost
effective so
it helps you to do the cost optimization
when you use the cloud front it is time
saving so
it is implemented easily
and also lot of issues with respect to
accessing the application
with respect to latency and all can be
resolved
content privacy so
the content is placed to the end users
and also to
the cloudfront servers
in a secured manner in a secured way
it is highly programmable and you can
make the changes amend the changes on
the fly and you can target any location
any geography across the globe along
with that it helps you to get the
content deliver quickly
now how aws cloudfront delivers the
content let's look into the architecture
so
this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first access a website by typing
a url on the browser and in the step one
it acts tries to access the application
then the client requests
when the website is open the client
request for an object to download such
as for example a particular file
now
at that time the dns
routes user request to download that
file to aws cloudfront
the aws cloud front connects to the
nearest edge locations edge locations
are basically the servers
where it caches
the files documents and the web codes
aws cloud front connects to its nearest
edge location in order to serve the user
the request
at edge location
aws crowdfund looks for its requested
cache file
once the file is found let's say if the
file is available in the cache of an
edge location
aws cloudfront then sends the file
to the user otherwise if the file is not
found in the cache memory of an edge
location
aws cloudfront compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds
to the edge location by sending the file
back to the cloud front edge location
and then as soon as the aws cloud front
receives the file
it shares with the client also adds the
file to the cache of an edge location
for a future reference this is how the
flow of a cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the aws cloud front
so one of them is jio7
app which is which is a very popular app
so it uses amazon cloudfront to deliver
15 petabytes of audio and video to its
subscribers globally which is a huge
data sky news uh it uses the service in
order to unify the content for faster
distribution to scrub subscribers
the discovery communications uh also
uses the cloud front it uses the service
for delivering api
static asset and also the dynamic
content
and then
the tv one eu streaming europe is
basically also uses uh the cloudfront
service that helps in improving latency
and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve
private s3 bucket as a website
now i'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the aws console
and
we basically try to deliver the content
from a private s3 bucket
and then map that with the domain name
using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need
a domain url we would need
a route 53 service
we would need
cloudfront
we have to create a cloudfront
distribution
and that will be linked with our s3
bucket the private s3 bucket
right
and in the s3 bucket we would have
one html file the index.html file
so let's uh move into aws console
so right now i have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see
that couple of distributions have
already been created
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is
rtmp
rtmp stands for real time
audio or video distribution
it's basically
used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the s3
bucket
here
we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols http
or the https
so you have to click on get started
and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify
the bucket where your code is available
so
i have a bucket already created
here you can see
and what you need to do is you have to
create a bucket
with the url name or the domain name
which you would be mapping with the
route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so
here you have to go to the storage under
the storage
you have to select the s3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into
how we can create the s3 buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created i have created one bucket with
the domain name that i'm going to use
and map it with the root 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an html webpage the
index.html has been
already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there
now again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
have to click on create distribution
select a web delivery method
select an origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.in
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin id is this one
so basically when you define an origin
domain name automatically the origin id
appears
you can customize this origin id as per
your requirement also so rest of the
things primarily we keep it as a default
settings only until and unless if we
require some customized settings to be
done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either
select use all edge locations for the
best performance so what does aws
basically do here
it uses all the edge locations
which are associated with aws across the
globe
otherwise you can specify based on the
regions also right
apart from that if you want to enable
firewalls or the access control list you
can specify here
and then
what you need to do is
in the default root object here you have
to specify your index.html
page which is in the s3
bucket the distribution state has to be
enabled and if you want to use ipv6 as
well you need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here
a distribution has been created it's in
progress and it is enabled
[Music]
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution
completed the reason is that the web
codes the web pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done
right now let's move on to route 53
service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type root 53 here scalable dns
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our url the
domains pointed to
the name servers that will be provided
by the root 53 so we have to create a
hosted zone
let's wait for it
so now
the root 53 dashboard is open and you
can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the aws
you have to first point the domains
traffic to the
uh hosted zone in the route 53
so
i'll click on create hosted zone but
before that i will
first delete the existing one
and then i'll
create another record
another hosted zone
right
put your domain name let's say i put us
sunshine learning n
and it is acting as a public hosted zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted zone
now it gives you four name servers and
these four name servers has to be
updated
in the domain so you have to update
these name servers in a platform from
where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the
cloudfront distribution hence we are
going with a simple routing right now
click on next
here you have to specify the record sets
so we are going to create the records
uh just click on default simple record
put here as world wide web
and you have to select an end point so
end point we are selecting for the
cloudfront distribution so we have to
specify
alias for the cloudfront distribution
now here we are going to put
the cloudfront distribution url
and then we are going to define the
simple report set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution url
which you can find it uh
from the cloudfront service itself
and you can find uh the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
and then
just click on define simple records
again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated
now this domain is basically
pointed towards these name servers which
are further pointed
towards the cloud front distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that within the domain from wherever
you have purchased the domain
you should update these phone name
servers and
then you can see the live traffic coming
on this domain
will have an output from the cloudfront
distribution today's topic is on aws
auto scaling so this is akil i would be
taking up a tutorial on the auto scaling
let's begin with our tutorial and let's
look into what we have in today's
session
so
i would be covering up
why we require aws auto scaling
what is aws auto scaling
what are the benefits
of
using the scaling service
how this auto scaling works
the different scaling plans we have
what is the difference between the
snapshot and the ami
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that i would be covering up a
real life demo on the aws
let's begin with why we require aws auto
scaling
now before aws cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of enterprises that
they were spending a lot of
money on the purchase of the
infrastructure
if they have to set up some kind of a
solution so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and one time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server hardware software
and then
having a team of experts to manage all
those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources
if there was a cost efficient solution
for their project that was the project
manager used to think
now after the aws cloud scaling that was
introduced
automatically the auto scaling maintains
the application performance
based on the user requirements at the
lowest possible price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
required it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is aws auto scaling let's look
into deep so aws auto scaling is a
service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers and
automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure
to maintain the steadiness so they can
increase the capacity they can even
decrease the capacity also for the cost
optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost
now what are the benefits of auto
scaling
it gave the better fault tolerance
applications you can get the servers
created and you can have a clone copy of
the servers so that you don't have to
deploy the applications again and again
better cost management because the
scalability is decided by the aws
automatically based on some threshold
parameters
it was a reliable service and
whenever the scaling is created or
initiated you can get the notifications
onto your mail ids or to your cell
phones
scalability as i mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down as well
and it has the flexibility the
flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number
you can always make the changes on the
fly
and the better availability
now
with the use of the auto scaling we come
around with the terminology called
snapshot and the ami let's look into the
difference between the snapshots and the
ami
snapshots versus ami
so in a company there was one of the
employee that was facing an issue with
launching the virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question
is it possible to launch multiple
virtual machines with a minimum amount
of time because it takes a lot of time
in terms of creating the virtual
machines
the other colleagues said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the ami on the aws
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
ami
let's look into the difference now the
snapshots basically kind of a backup of
a single ebs volume
which is just like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the ami it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance only
the snapshots
opts for this when the instance contain
multiple static ebs when you opt for the
snapshot whenever the instance contains
multiple static evs volumes
ami this is widely used to replace the
failed
ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the ami you pay only for
the storage that you use
the snapshots are non-bootable images on
abs volume
whereas ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an ami image will also
create the evs snapshots
now how does aws auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the aws auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then
select the service you want to scale
also for the optimization select do you
want to optimize cost or do you want to
optimize the performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have
so
in the auto scaling a scaling plan
basically helps a user to configure a
set of instructions
for scaling based on
the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of aws auto scaling on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically a kind of
the parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved
in the auto scaling
with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
now what is dynamic scaling it basically
guides the service of aws auto scaling
on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price
now with scaling strategies users can
create their plan based on the required
metrics and thresholds so a metric can
be like let's say a network in network
out or it can be a cpu utilization
memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict future workload
based on daily and weekly trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of a forecast that happens
based on the previous past experiences
it uses a machine learning technique for
analyzing that network graphic and this
scaling is like how weather forecast
works
right it provides schedule scaling
actions to ensure the resource capacity
is available for application requirement
now
with the auto scaling you would need the
load balancers also because if there are
multiple instances that are created then
you would need a load balancer to
distribute
the load to those instances
so
let's understand what do we mean by a
load balancer
a load balancer basically acts as a
reverse proxy
and it is responsible for distributing
the network or the application traffic
across multiple
servers
with the help of a load balancer you can
achieve a reliability you can achieve a
fault tolerance of an application that
is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example
when there is a high network traffic
that is coming to your application and
if that much traffic comes to your
application to the instances your
instances may crash
so how you can avoid that situation
so you need to manage the network
traffic that is coming to your instances
and that can be done with the load
balancer so thanks to the aws load
balancers which helps in distributing
network traffic across backend servers
in a way that it increases performance
of an application here in the image you
can see the traffic coming from a
different resources landing on to the
ec2 instance and the load balancer is
actually distributing that traffic to
all the three instances hence managing
the network traffic quite properly
now what are the types of load balancers
we have there are three types of load
balancers on the aws one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer
let's look into what we have in the
classic load manager so the classic load
balancer is the most basic form of load
balancing and we call it as a primitive
load balancer also and it is widely used
for the ec2 instances
it is based on the ip address and the
tcp port and it routes network traffic
between end users as well as in between
the backend servers
and it does not support host-based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task on the
application level in the osi model
it is used when there are http and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host based and
pathways routing and performs well with
the microservices of the backend
applications
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4 of the connection level
in the osi model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to route the tcp traffic
and it can manage a massive amount of
traffic and is also suitable to manage
the low latencies
let's look into the demo uh and see how
practically we can
create the auto scale
hi guys let's look into the demo for how
we can create an auto scaling on the aws
console
so right now i'm logged into the aws
console and i am in the mumbai region
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that click
on the easy to service
let's wait for the ec2 servers to come
now just scroll down
and under the load balancing there is an
option called auto scaling so there
first you have to create a launch
configuration and then after that you
have to create the auto scaling groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching and auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances
so that includes let's say if you select
a windows os or a linux os that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scaling
so there are certain set of parameters
that we have to specify during the
launch configuration so that we can have
a uniformity in terms of launching the
servers
so here i would select an amazon linux
ami
and then i would select the type of
server which will be t2.micro
click on configure details
put the name to the launch configuration
let's say we put it as a demo
and
the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage
since it's a linux ami we can go with
the 8gb storage that should be fine
click on configure security group
let's create a new security group which
has the ssh port opened and that is open
for
anywhere which is basically source ipv4
and ipv6 ips any ip would be able to
access
that click on review
just review your launch configuration if
you want to make changes you can do that
otherwise click on create a launch
configuration
you would need the key pair and this key
pair will be a unique key pair which
will be used with all the instances that
are part of the auto scaling group
so we can select an existing key pair if
you have that otherwise you can create a
new key pair
so i have an existing key pair i'll go
with that acknowledge it and click on
create launch condition
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group
so click on create an auto scaling group
using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with
it says one instance so that means at
least a single instance will always be
running and it will be initiated and
running 24 cross 7 till the auto scaling
is available
you can increase the size of the minimum
base instances also let's say you can
change it to 2 also so you would get at
least two servers running all the time
so we'll go with the one instance
the network would be the vpc default and
in the vpc particular region we can
select
the availability zones so let's say if i
select availability zone 1a
and then availability zone 1b
so how the instances will be launched so
one instance will be launched in one and
the other one in the one b the third one
and the one a fourth one and the one b
likewise it will uh be equally spread
among the availability zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it
if you want to keep this group at its
initial size let's say if you want to go
with only a single instance or two
instances and you don't want the scaling
to progress you can put it
keep this group at its initial size so
this is basically a way to hold the
scaling
but we'll use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group so
click on it and we would scale between
let's say minimum one instance that we
have and we'll scale it between one two
four instances
and
what condition on what basis these
instances will be scaled up or scaled
down would be defined in the scale group
size
so the scaling policies you can
implement
based on
a scale group size or using the simple
scaling policies using the steps
so in the scale group size you have a
certain metrics you can use average cpu
utilization you can define a metric
related to average networking average
network out or the load balancer request
counts per target
and if you create the simple scaling
policies using steps then you need to
create the alarms and there you can get
some more metrics that you can add up
as a parameter for the auto scaling
let's go with the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
cpu utilization and the target value
here you have to specify what would be
the threshold that when the instance cpu
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated
so you can put a reasonable threshold
for that let's say we put something like
85 percent and whenever the instance cpu
utilization is crossed 85 threshold you
will see that there will be a new
instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email ids or you
can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would need the sns service that is
called as a simple notification service
and
you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic using
your email id and then you should get
the notifications
click on configure tags
the tags are not mandatory you can
basically
put a tag let's say if you want to
identify the instance for the purpose it
was created otherwise you can leave it
blank also click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification tags
as well as the scaling group details
click on create auto scaling group
and here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
auto scaling
so let's wait for the details to appear
so here you can see our launch
configuration name demo
auto scaling group name test
minimum instance we want one the maximum
instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
ap south one ap south 1b
and
the instance one has been initiated and
if you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated just click
on the instances here
and here you will see
that
our single instance has been initiated
that is in service
and that has been initiated in ap south
1b
now once the threshold of this instance
crosses 85 that is what we have defined
in the scaling policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically
i have created steps to
initiate a scaling policy that means to
increase the number of servers whenever
the threshold crosses likewise here
itself you can add another policy to
scale down
the resources in case if the cpu
utilization goes to a
normal value today we are going to
discuss about amazon redshift which is
one of the data warehouse service on the
aws so let's begin with amazon redshift
and let's see what we have for today's
session so what's in it for you today
we'll see what is aws
why we require amazon redshift what do
we mean by amazon redshift the
advantages of amazon redshift the
architecture of amazon redshift some of
the additional concepts associated with
the redshift and the companies that are
using the amazon redshift and finally
we'll cover up one demo which will show
you the practical example that how you
can actually use the redshift service
now what is aws as we know that aws
stands for amazon web service it's one
of the largest cloud providers in the
market and it's basically a secure cloud
service platform provided from the
amazon also on the aws you can create
and deploy the applications
using the aws service along with that
you can access the services provided by
the aws over the public network that is
over the internet they are accessible
plus you pay only whatever the service
you use for now let's understand why we
require amazon redshift so earlier
before amazon readchef what used to
happen that the people used to or the
developers used to fetch the data from
the data warehouse so data warehouse is
basically a terminology which is
basically represents the collection of
the data so a repository where the data
is stored is generally called as a data
warehouse now fetching data from the
data warehouse was a complicated task
because might be a possibility that the
developer is located at a different
geography and the data data warehouse is
at a different location and probably
there is not that much network
connectivity or some networking
challenges internet connectivity
challenges security challenges might be
and a lot of maintenance was required to
manage the data warehouses so what were
the cons of the traditional data
warehouse services it was time consuming
to download or get the data from the
data warehouse maintenance cost was high
and there was the possibility of loss of
information in between the downloading
of the data and the data rigidity was an
issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was basically solved
with the introduction of amazon redshift
over the cloud platform now we say that
amazon redshift has solved traditional
data warehouse problems that the
developers were facing but how what is
amazon redshift actually is so what is
amazon redshift it is one of the
services over the aws amazon web
services which is called as a data
warehouse service so amazon redshift is
a cloud-based service or a data
warehouse service that is primarily used
for collecting and storing the large
chunk of data so it also helps you to
get or extract the data analyze the data
using some of the bi tools so business
intelligence tools you can use and get
the data from the redshift and process
that and hence it simplifies the process
of handling the large scale data sets so
this is the symbol for the amazon
redshift over the aws now let's discuss
about one of the use case so dna is
basically a telecommunication company
and they were facing an issue with
managing their website and also the
amazon s3 data which led down to slow
process of their applications now how
could they overcome this problem let's
say that so they overcome this issue by
using the amazon redshift and all the
company noticed that there was a 52
increase in the application performance
now did you know that amazon redshift is
basically cost less to operate than any
other cloud data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also the performance of an
amazon redshift is the fastest data
warehouse we can say that that is
available as of now so in both cases one
is that it saves the cost as compared to
the traditional data warehouses and also
the performance of this red shift
service or a data warehouse service the
fastest available on the cloud platforms
and more than 15 000 customers primarily
presently they are using the amazon
redshift service now let's understand
some of the advantages of amazon
redshift first of all as we saw that it
is one of the fastest available data
warehouse service so it has the high
performance second is it is a low cost
service so you can have a large scale of
data warehouse or the databases combined
in a data warehouse at a very low cost
so whatever you use you pay for that
only scalability now in case if you
wanted to increase the nodes of the
databases in your redshift you can
actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so this scalability is
again one of the advantage of the amazon
redshift availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create whenever you access
redshift you create a clusters in the
redshift and the clusters are created in
the you can define a specific virtual
private cloud for your cluster and you
can create your own security groups and
attach it to your cluster so you can
design the security parameters based on
your requirement and you can get your
data warehouse or the data items in a
secured place flexibility and you can
remove the clusters you can create under
clusters if you are deleting a cluster
you can take a snapshot of it and you
can move those snapshots to different
regions so that much flexibility is
available on the aws for the service and
the other advantage is that it is
basically a very simple way to do a
database migration so if you're planning
that you wanted to migrate your
databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud on the redshift it
is basically uh very simple to do a
database migration you can have some of
the inbuilt tools available on the aws
access you can connect them with your
traditional data center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the amazon redshift so architecture of
an amazon redshift is basically it
combines of a cluster and that we call
it as a data warehouse cluster in this
picture you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
representation of amazon redshift so it
has
some of the compute nodes which does the
data processing and a leader node which
gives the instructions to these compute
nodes and also the leader node basically
manages the client applications that
require the data from the redshift so
let's understand about the components of
the redshift the client application of
amazon redshift basically interact with
the leader node using jdbc or the odbc
now what is jdbc it's a java database
connectivity and the odbc stands for
open database connectivity the amazon
redshift service using a jdbc connector
can monitor the connections from the
other client applications so the leader
node can actually have a check on the
client applications using the jdbc
connections whereas the odbc allows a
leader node to have a direct interaction
or to have a live interaction with the
amazon redshift so odbc allows a user to
interact with live data of amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct access of the applications as
well as the leader node can get the
information from the compute nodes now
what are these compute nodes uh these
are basically kind of a databases which
does the processing so amazon redshift
has a set of computing resources which
we call it as a nodes and the nodes when
they are combined together they are
called it as a clusters now a cluster a
set of computing resources which are
called as nodes and this gathers into a
group which we call it as a data
warehouse cluster so you can have a
compute node starting from 1 to n number
of nodes and that's why we call that the
red shift is a scalable service because
we can scale up the compute nodes
whenever we require now the data
warehouse cluster or the each cluster
has one or more databases in the form of
a nodes now what is a leader node this
node basically manages the interaction
between the client application and the
compute node so it acts as a bridge
between the client application and the
compute nodes also it analyzes and
develop designs in order to carry out
any kind of a database operations so
leader node basically sends out the
instructions to the compute nodes
basically perform or execute that
instruction and give that output to the
leader node so that is what we are going
to see in the next slide that the leader
node runs the program and assign the
code to individual compute nodes and the
compute nodes execute the program and
share the result back to the leader node
for the final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client application for
analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slice is allotted
with specific memory space or you can
say a storage space where the data is
processed these node slices works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node slices work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with amazon redshift is there
are two additional concepts associated
with the redshift one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from the columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples uh are
mentioned here so below example show how
database tables store record into disk
block by row so here you can see that if
we wanted to pull out some kind of an
information based on the city address
age we can basically create a filter and
from there we can put out the details
that we require and that is going to
fetch out the details based on the
column storage so that makes data more
structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using amazon
redshift one is lya the other one is
equinox the third one is the pfizer
which is one of the famous
pharmaceuticals company mcdonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and philips it's an electronic company
so these are one of the biggest
companies that are basically relying and
they're putting their data on the
redshift data warehouse service now in
another video we'll see the demo for
using the amazon redshift let's uh look
into the amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we'll be doing is that
we'll be creating an im role for the
redshift so that the redshift can call
the services and specifically we'll be
using the s3 service so the role that
we'll be creating we'll be giving the
permission to redshift to have an access
of an s3 in the read-only format so in
the step one what we require we will
check the prerequisites and what you
need to have is the aws credentials if
you don't have that you need to create
your own credentials and you can use
your credit and the debit card and then
in the step two we'll proceed with the
im role for the amazon redshift once the
role is created we will launch a sample
amazon redshift cluster mentioned in the
step 3 and then we will assign a vpc
security groups to our cluster now you
can create it in the default vpc also
you can create a default security groups
also otherwise you can customize the
security groups based on your
requirement now to connect to the sample
cluster you need to run the queries and
you can connect to your cluster and run
queries on the aws management console
query editor which you will find it in
the redshift only or if you use the
query editor you don't have to download
and set up a sql client application
separately and in the step 6 what you
can do is you can copy the data from the
s3 and upload that in the red shift
because the red shift would have an
access a read-only access
for the s3 as that will be created in
the im role so let's see how we can
actually use the redshift on the aws so
i am already logged in into my account i
am in north virginia region i'll search
for redshift service and here i find
amazon redshift so just click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard and from
here itself you have to run the cluster
so to launch a cluster you just have to
click on this launch cluster and once
the cluster is created and if you wanted
to run queries you can open query editor
or you can basically create queries and
access the data from the red shift so
that's what it was mentioned in the
steps also that you don't require a
separate sql client application to get
the queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create the role so what we'll do is
we'll click on the services and we'll
move to im role section so im rule i can
find here under the security identity
and compliance so just click on the
identity access management and then
click on create roles so lets wait for i
am page to open so here in the im
dashboard you just have to click on the
rules i already have the role created so
what i'll do is i'll delete this role
and i'll create it separately so just
click on create role and under the aws
services you have to select for the
redshift because now the redshift will
be calling the other services and that's
why we are creating the role now which
other services that the redshift will be
having an access of s3 why because we'll
be putting up the data on the s3 and
that is something which needs to be
uploaded on the redshift so we'll just
search for the redshift service and
we can find it here so just click on it
and then click on redshift customizable
in the use case now click on next
permissions and here in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an s3 read-only access so you can search
here for the s3 also let's wait for the
policies to come in here it is let's
type s3 and here we can find amazon s3
read-only access so just click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my redshift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we'll move to redchat service and we'll
create one cluster so click on the
services click on amazon redshift you
can find that in the history section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
gb how much db memory you want you can
define it here itself this also gives
you the information about the costing on
demand is basically pay as you use so
they are going to charge you 0.5 dollars
per r for using the two node slicers so
let's click on launch this cluster and
this will be a dc2 dot large kind of an
instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a solid state
drive ssds which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and
the nodes two are mentioned by default
that means there will be two node slices
and that will be created in a cluster
you can increase them also let's say if
i put three node slices so it is going
to give us 3 into 0.16 db per node
storage now here you have to define the
master username password for your
redshift cluster and you have to follow
the password instructions so i would put
a password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ascii characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the role
that we created recently so in the
available im rules you just have to
click on my red shift roll and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the vpc from default
vpc to your custom vpc and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own security group so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now let's launch the
cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created now if
you wanted to run queries on this
redshift cluster so you don't require a
separate sql client you just have to
follow
the simple steps to run a query editor
and the query editor you will find it on
the dashboard so let's click on the
cluster and here you would see that the
redshift cluster would be created with
the three nodes in the u.s east1b
availability zone so we have created the
redshift cluster
in the ohio region and now what we'll do
is we'll
see how we can create the tables inside
the redshift and we'll see how we can
use the copy command so that we can
directly move the data uploaded on the
s3 bucket to the redshift database
tables and then we'll query the results
of a table as well so how we can do that
first of all after creating the redshift
cluster we have to
install sql workbench slash j
this is not a mysql which is managed by
oracle and you can find this
on the google you can download it from
there and then you have to connect this
client with the redshift database how
you can do click on file click on
connect window and after connecting a
window
you have to paste the url which is a
jdbc driver this driver link you can
find it onto the aws console so if you
open up a redshift cluster there you
would find the jdbc driver link let's
wait for it so this is our cluster
created let's open it and here you can
find this jdbc url and also make sure
that in the security groups of a
redshift you have the port 5439 open for
the traffic incoming traffic you also
need to have the amazon redshift driver
and this is the link where you can
download the driver and specify the path
once you are done with that you provide
the username and the password that you
created while creating the redshift
cluster click on ok so this connects
with the database and now the database
connection is almost completed now what
we will be doing in the sql workbench we
will be
first creating the sales table and then
in the sales table we'll be adding up
the entries copied from the s3 bucket
and then move it to the redshift
database and after that we'll query the
results in the sales table now whatever
the values you are creating in the table
the same values needs to be in the data
file and
i have taken up this sample data file
from this link which is
docs.aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticket db.zip file this
folder has basically multiple uh data
files sample data files which you can
actually use it uh to practice uploading
the data on the redshift cluster so i
have
extracted one of the files
from this folder and then i have
uploaded that file in the s3 bucket now
we'll move into the s3 bucket let's look
for the file that has been uploaded on
the s3 bucket so this is the bucket
sample and sales underscore tab dot text
is the file that i have uploaded this
has the entries data entries that will
be uploaded using a copy command onto
the red shift cluster now after
executing after putting up the command
for creating up the table then
we'll use a copy command and
copy command we have to define the table
name the table name is sales and we have
to define the path from where the data
would be copied over to the sales table
in the red shift now path is the s3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and
it has to look for the data inside the
sales underscore tab dot text file also
we have to define the
role arn that was created previously and
once it is done then the third step is
to query the results inside the sales
table to check whether our data has been
uploaded correctly on the table or not
now what we'll do is we'll execute all
these three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it
execute it
it's again gives us the error let's look
into the name of the bucket it's
redshift bucket sample so we have two
t's mentioned here right
let's connect with the database again
and now execute it so table sales
created and we got the error the
specified bucket does not exist uh
redshift bucket sample let's view the
bucket name redshift bucket sample let's
copy that put it here connect to the
window connect back to the database
right and now execute it so table sales
created
the data in the table has been copied
from the s3 bucket
to sales underscore tab.text to the
redshift and then the query of the
results now the results
from the table has been queried hi guys
i'm raoul from simplylearn and today i'd
like to welcome you all to the greatest
debate of the century today i am joined
by two giants of the cloud computing
industry they'll be going head to head
with each other to decide who amongst
them is better it's going to be one
hello fight now let's meet our
candidates on my left we have aws who's
voiced by a picture hi guys
and on my right we have microsoft azure
who's voiced by anjali hey there
so today we'll be deciding who's better
on the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
on the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market sharing
options free tier and instance
configuration
now let's listen to their opening
statements let's start with aws
launched in 2006 aws is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like adobe
netflix airbnb htc pinterest and spotify
have put their faith in aws for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number aws also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more
now let's see what azure has to say
about that azure was launched in 2010
and is trusted by almost 80 percent of
all fortune 500 companies the best of
the best companies in the world choose
to work only with azure azure also
provides its services to more regions
than any other cloud service provider in
the world azure covers 42 regions
already and 12 more are being planned to
be made azure also provides more than
100 services spanning a variety of
domains now that the opening statements
are done let's have a look at the
current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
route here we have the stats for the
market share of aws azure and other
cloud service providers this is for the
early 2018 period amazon web services
takes up a whopping 40
of the market share closely followed by
hdr at 30 percent and other cloud
services adding 30
this 40 indicates most organizations
clear interest in using aws we are
number one because of our years of
experience and trust we've created among
our users
sure you're the market leader but we are
not very far behind let me remind you
more than 80 percent of the fortune 500
companies trust azure with their cloud
computing needs so it's only a match of
time before azure takes the lead the
rest of the 30 percent that is in aws or
azure accounts to the other cloud
service providers like google cloud
platform rackspace ibm software and so
on now for our next round the comparison
route first we'll be comparing pricing
we'll be looking at the cost of a very
basic instance which is a virtual
machine of two virtual cpus and 8gb of
ram for aws this will cost you
approximately
0.0928 us dollars per hour and for the
same instance in azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 us dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options as i mentioned before aws is the
undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 percent of the market share by 2020
aws is also expected to produce twice
its current revenue which comes close to
44 billion dollars not to mention aws is
constantly expanding its already strong
roaster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great really good for you but the
research company gardner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now neck-to-neck
between azure and aws it's only a matter
of time before azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass aws this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from aws to
azure to help satisfy their business
needs azure is not far behind aws when
this comes to services as well azure
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirement
now let's compare aws and azure's free
offerings aws provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example amazon
s s sqs cloud watch etc and the valid
fourier category offers approximately 20
services for example amazon s3 ec2
elastic cache etc
both types of services have limits on
the usage for example storage number of
requests compute time etc but users are
only charged for using services that
fall under the valid for a year category
after a year of their usage
a shop provides a free tier as well it
also provides services that belong to
the categories of free for a year and
always free there are about 25 plus
always free services provided by azure
these include app service functions
container service active directory and
lots more and as of the valley for a
year there are eight services offered
there's linux or windows virtual
machines blob storage sql database and
few more azure also provides the users
with credits of 200 us dollars to access
all their services for 30 days now this
is a unique feature that azure provides
where users can use their credits to
utilize any service of a choice for the
entire month now let's compare instance
configuration the largest instance that
aws offers is that of a whopping 256 gbs
of ram and 16 virtual cpus the largest
that azure offers isn't very far behind
either 224 gbs of ram and 16 virtual
cpus and now for the final round now
each of our contestants will be shown
facts and they have to give explanations
for these facts we call it the rapid
fire round first we have features in
which aws is good and azure is better
aws does not cut down on the features it
offers its users however it requires
slightly more management on the user's
part azure goes slightly deeper with the
services that fall under certain
categories like platform as a service
and infrastructure as a service
next we have hybrid cloud where aws is
good and azure is better okay although
aws did not emphasize on hybrid cloud
earlier they are focusing more on
technology now azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers aws is
better and azure is good of course it's
better because aws supports integration
with third-party applications well azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both aws and azure are at the
same level it's good for aws because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience and
that's it our contestants have finished
giving their statements now let's see
who won surprisingly nobody each cloud
computing platform has its own pros and
cons choosing the right one is based
entirely on your organization's
requirements
guys today we've got something very
special in store for you we're going to
talk about the best cloud computing
platform available amazon web services
uh rahul i think you said something
wrong here the best cloud computing
platform is obviously google cloud
platform no it isn't aws has more than
100 services that span a variety of
domains all right but google cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well i guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys i'm
apeksha and i will be google cloud
platform and i'm rahul i'll be aws so
welcome to fight night this is aws
versus gcp
the winner will be chosen on the basis
of their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market sharing options the
things they give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about aws aws was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute database storage migration
networking and so on a very important
aspect about aws is its years of
experience now aws has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in aws they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved with
an aws service now that was great but
now can we talk about gcp i hope you
know that gcp was launched very recently
in 2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with a suite of
intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
google the intuitive user experience
that gcp provides with dashboards
wizards is way better in all the aspects
gcp has just stepped in the market and
it is already offering a modest number
of services and the number is rapidly
increasing and the cost for a cpu
instance or regional storage that gcp
provides is a whole lot cheaper and you
also get a multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that i'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017. this will tell you once and for
all that aws is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing amazon web services
contributes 47 percent of the market
share others like rackspace or verizon
cloud contribute 36 microsoft azure
contributes 10 the google cloud platform
contributes 4
and ibm software contributes 3
47 of the market share is contributed by
aws you need me to convince you any more
wait wait wait all that is fine but we
only started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and aws makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
pricing for aws a computer instance of
two cpus in 8gb ram costs a proc month
with aws you really want to do that
because gcp wins this hands down let's
take the same compute instance of two
cpus with 8gb ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp and as per my calculations that's a
25 annual cost reduction when compared
to aws talking about cloud storage costs
it is only 2 cents per gb per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now aws is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 percent of the entire market
share aws also has at least 100 services
available at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well aws understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with aws lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits across you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all cloud platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5gb of cloud storage any usage above
this always free usage limits will be
automatically built at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered is of 128 cpus
and 4 tvs of ram now other than the on
demand method like i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular r now these spot prices do
fluctuate but are adjusted over a period
of time the largest instance offered
with google cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75
tbs ram like spot instances of aws
google cloud offers short-lived compute
instances suitable for bad jobs and
fault tolerant workloads they are called
as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at eighty
percent off on on demand price hence
they reduce your compute engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price google cloud platform
is a lot more flexible when it comes to
instance configuration you simply choose
your cpu and ram combination of course
you can even create your own instance
types this way before we wrap it up
let's compare on some other things as
well telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices for
example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in analyzing services
and providing more opportunities for
improvement when it comes to application
support aws is obviously better since
they have years of experience under
their bed aws provides the best support
that can be given to the customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space as kubernetes was
originally developed by google gcp has
full native support for the tools other
cloud services are just fine tuning a
way to provide humanities as a service
also the containers help with
abstracting applications from their
environment they originally running the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies aws is better since
they have a head start of a few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws i
think i'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is the
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organization's requirement
on that note i believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up aws azure and gcp
are three of the world's largest cloud
service providers but how are they
different from each other let's find out
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chinmay and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i'm shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on aws versus
azure vs gcp talking about market share
amazon web services leads with around 32
of the worldwide public cloud share
azure owns up to 16 of the worldwide
market share and gcp owns around nine
percent of the world's market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail aws provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the internet
aws being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006. azure
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the
pay-as-you-go approach you pay only for
the individual services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aws cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services for aws elastic
bean stock is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java dot net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage aws provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
most suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud watch
and aws cloud formation for development
we have aws code star and aws code build
for security we have iam and key
management service for microsoft azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and express
route for management tools we have azure
advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
azure advisor and network watcher for
development we have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for security we
have google cloud im and google and
cloud security scanner now lets talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for aws we have netflix
unilever kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe
pixar samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw
among others use microsoft azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an it
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for
long-running workloads for example you
use the vm for a month and get a
discount gcp also provides live
migration of virtual machines live
migration is the process of moving a
running vm from one physical server to
another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for google
cloud compared to other cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
cpus as needed google cloud storage is
designed for 99.9 durability it creates
server backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs twenty nine dollars per
month business which costs more than
hundred dollars an enterprise that costs
more than fifteen thousand dollars it
has certain network connectivity issues
it also has general issues when you move
to the cloud like downtime limited
control backup protection and so on
however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of microsoft azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass echo system is not as
efficient as iaas azure management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage hey guys this is chidanan from
simply learn and i welcome you to this
short tutorial and demo on kubernetes
kubernetes specific to aws cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at our offset i would like to cover
the basics of orchestration tools as
most of you would know kubernetes is one
of the most popular orchestration tools
in recent times specifically for
applications which are cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
organization tools why would one need to
use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by this
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that i'm going to cover after that
i will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management docker
swarm versus kubernetes i'm going to
compare them with regard to the features
that they provide the use cases that
they cover what facilities that they
provide and when to use what after that
i will get into a little bit details of
the kubernetes architecture what exactly
is required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that i will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on aws platform i will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so i
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on aws all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools
the application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has
the requirement that it has in terms of
the hardware the features of fault
tolerance self-healing capabilities auto
scaling all this has complicated over
the last few years as a part of devops
one thing that everyone is interested in
is managing all this application
dependency or lifecycle management using
some or the other kind of a tool so
that's where these orchestration tools
have become very very popular so what
kind of features that they provide is
you'll have to just let them know what
are the kinds of tool sets that is
required what are the fault tolerance
mechanisms that it has to be adopted to
what kind of a self-healing capabilities
that application will have to need and
if at all there is any auto scaling
features that is required if at all you
can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a one stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management docker swarm and
kubernetes many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with apache
missiles there are many other container
management systems but i'm going to pick
docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two frameworks for the sake of
comparison i picked up docker swarm and
kubuntis just because of the reason that
both of them operate in the space of
container management they do something
very very similar to containers that's
the similarity that exists between these
two orchestration tools however there's
a big difference that exists when it
comes to the types of containers that
both of them cater to and also the
capacity of workloads they can be used
for docker swarm is a cluster management
solution that is provided by docker
container docker is one of the very very
popular containers of recent times and
in case you have your applications that
is totally powered by only docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only docker containers
docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes on
the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than docker
and including docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got docker in them which have got rkt in
them which they have got alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
2. a docker swarm can manage up to 40 50
or 60 max
nodes so in case your application is
totally written in docker containers and
the load or the expected cluster size is
about 50 16 nodes docker swarm should be
the choice of orchestration tool on the
other hand kubernetes is something that
was open sourced by google and the kind
of the scale of operations that
kubernetes can cater to is google scale
so if in case your applications are more
than a thousand nodes that is where
kubernetes comes into play that's the
big difference that exists between
docker swarm and kubernetes putting
those differences aside let me compare
docker swarm and kubernetes based upon
other features which are similar in
nature the first and important feature
that kubernetes provides is something
called as auto scaling if at all the
load on your cluster is too high and
your application is experiencing more
load so kubernetes can add new nodes to
your cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new vms or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the fly
based upon the load that exist at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of
replicas or less number of application
containers running on it it can move
them to some other node and also scale
down by deleting few nodes from your
cluster so that is the powerfulness of
auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application node balancing so docker
swarm gives you an application level
auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as i
mentioned earlier docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loosely coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the swamps on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes the way to
spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many masternodes
how many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the fly based upon the requirement on a
darker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to copper days worker
notes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
loosely coupled architecture for docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docker swarm
runs only docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and lot
of other things with each other because
they all have the same signature they
they're all from the same family so it's
very easy for them to share not just
volumes but lot of other things however
for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if your
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also
when it comes to kubernetes kubernetes
groups containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each part can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same node that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to docker's form
gui so there's not a good enough ui tool
in docker's form at least the ce edition
of it which will allow you to get to
know what is running on your containers
what is the size of the containers what
is the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like proteiner which gives
you a good visibility into your running
docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker kubernetes gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way um this is
little bit of a good ui for kubernetes
while for docker's form there isn't
anything that is provided out of the box
let me spend some time in explaining a
little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an api server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubicctl
or the command from using which anybody
can assign some workloads to the cluster
can also be run either on the same node
or on a separate node so cubectl is the
command line tool that we will be
installing and using in order to fire up
our commands to our cluster so if at all
i have to put up a job on our cluster if
i have to give out any specific commands
to my cluster all this is done using
cuba ctl there's a bunch of rest apis
which is used by cuba ctl and cubectl
will talk to the api server and fire up
the commands specific to my cluster what
runs in the master node master node
without saying it's the most important
component of any of the cluster if at
all you're running um cluster with only
one master node if your master node goes
down there's no other way that you know
you can or any user can talk to the
different nodes in the cluster so master
node is the most vital component
responsible for the complete kubernetes
cluster there's always one node that
should be running as a master node
that's the bare minimum requirement for
your cluster so what are the other
components in the master node the most
important one is called etcd so this is
nothing but a data store a value of key
value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of
workloads that is running based upon the
configuration that the user has set in
so if at all if you are aware of
something called as replication
controllers endpoint controllers
namespace controllers all these
controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
part goes on for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the part
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right epa server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the aps are work so
this is an entry point for all your
requests that come into your cluster
anybody wants to deploy something
anybody want to scale up a controller
anybody who wants to bring down a few
services anybody wants to put in a
service all this will have to come in as
a part of a rest
api endpoint and api server is the entry
point in case you don't want uh you know
somebody to access your cluster in case
you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this apa
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as i mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there is something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so slave nodes or the
worker nodes typically run these parts
so that is where the whole workload
typically gets run but there are a bunch
of other components in the in the node
which also manages what runs in the pod
who has to have access to the pod what
is the state of the pod is it in a
running state is it going down for some
reason and all the stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the node should be
the container runtime as i mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have docker running on it rkt
running or lkc running on it or any
other container environment that is
running on it you have to ensure that
the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cubelet as the name says cubelet or
cubelet is a small subset which talks to
the cube api server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qbpa server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um
affinity towards any node on which these
parts are running because pods or
containers are something called as
ephemeral they can run anywhere so how
would somebody reach out to these
applications that is running in some pod
which is running in one container now
and running in probably another
container another node altogether
tomorrow so that is where your
kubernetes proxy contains a picture and
this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these parts and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a dns server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the part on which the service
is typically running so that plays a
very very important role by acting as a
load balancer and a network proxy now
that at a very high level we know what
are all the components that make up of
our kubernetes cluster let's go ahead
and create a small cluster and spin up
this cluster on aws platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node you're
probably thinking that it's maybe pretty
hard to kind of set this up so let me
demystify that by running you with a
quick demo of how to set up a simple
pre-node kubernetes cluster using a tool
called cops and i will be doing this
whole setup on my aws
cloud okay so what is cops cops is
nothing but a simple tool this is an
admin tool that allows you to bring up
production grade kubernetes environments
as i said setting up a kubernetes
cluster on a bare metal is little
challenging so that is why i would use
something called as a cops and i will
use this on my cluster which i'll spin
up on my aws instance so i have an aws
account and what i will do first is i
will first spin up an ec2 server i will
power this with one of the
linux amis and i will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where i'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case i'll try to keep
it little small i don't want too many
nodes in my cluster i'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know aws is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what i
would do is i will create an iam role
which will attach to my ec2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that i'm going to specify
all right so once i have my cluster set
up i will also install cuba ctl which
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command line utility using
which i can kind of connect to my
cluster give it some jobs put some parts
and stuff like that so i will use cuba
ctl i will also have a pair of ssh keys
so that from this machine i would be
able to successfully get on to the
master node and submit jobs on my behalf
so let me begin by first logging into my
aws account all the steps that i will be
following to bring up my aws cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and i'll be sharing you this document in
a github repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that i would need is to
launch an aws ec2 instance now this is
an instance where i'm going to install
cops and i will use it as a base server
from where i'm going to fire some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
aws account and um let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
doesn't matter in the ways but in case
you want to try it on your free tire i
would recommend choose free tire only
and choose an ami of your choice let me
choose
this instance i will make it t2 micro
that is good for me configuration
instance details all right i don't want
to change anything here that looks good
maybe i will change this 30 gig that's
good for me let me add a tag to my
instance i will name this as my cops
server all right i would need a bunch of
posts to be opened up so what i will do
is i will create a new security group
called open to
the word i would not recommend that you
do this since i don't want to it will
take a long time for me to specifically
uh to pick and choose um the ports that
has to be open for running my cluster i
don't want to do that i will open up all
the http and https ports so that it's
quicker so i will say all tcp i would
say from anywhere just to be on the
safer side also open http and https and
i will make this anywhere and anywhere
this is good for me i will say review
and launch all right so i chose a t2
micro instance just for the sake of
easiness i've opened up all the ports
and um the instant details are you've
seen what is that i've chosen all right
now important part is like i would need
a key keyboard i need to create a new
keyboard i will call this as simply
learn keys i will download this
keypair and then i will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what i'll do is i will convert i have
this pem file which is the pair of keys
the ssh keys with which i need to log
into my ec2 instance so i'll need to
convert this because i'm trying to
connect from my windows box i would need
to convert this into a ppk file so i
have puttygen i'm going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into a
ppk key all right open all right i would
say save hang on save private key yes i
would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key and save this here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file and this is my
tpk or my private key now using the
private key i will log into my ec2
instance okay now my ec2 instance is up
and running it is running in this ohio
region and this is the ip address of my
public impedance of my machine so let me
connect to it so i use a moba x term
which is nothing but an ssh emulator you
can use putty or any of these sessions
which allow you to do an ssh this is my
ip address of my machine and since i've
spun up an amazon ami the user this is
the default user i would need to specify
the private keys for my session and this
is the private key for my session say
okay i am in my
amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that i need to
do all right so as i said i just brought
up my ec2 instance but i would need my
ec2 instance to
run few things on my behalf so that it
can spin up easy to other ec2 instances
it can also talk to an s3 bucket where
i'm going to store the instant state of
my kubernetes cluster also some sort of
an auto scaling group because i want to
spin up more and more instances i also
want to have a private hosted zone using
my route 53 so i would need my ec2
instance to have all these sort of
permissions for my server so what i
would do is i will go and create a
permission a rule in the ec2 rather in
the aws im rule and i will attach this
im rule to my ec2 instance all right so
let me go to my iam which is nothing but
the identity and access management i
will create a rule called as possibly
cobb's role i will create a role this
role will be used by my ec2 so i'm going
to click on ec2 and say next permissions
they would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here s3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what i would do is
i'll create a role with the
administrative access all right so i
don't want any tags i'm going to review
i'll create a row name i will say cops
fold for ec2 alright so i'm going to
create a role which has got
administrative access rules i'm going to
create a role so this would ensure that
my ec2 instance from which i'm going to
run my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permissions so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to s3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so i will connect
this role to my running instance all
right so this is my um easy to instant
that is running
action attach attach attach attach
replace im rolls so there is no rule as
of now i would want my corpse roll for
easy to roll that i created so i want
this new room to be assigned to my ec2
alright great now my ec2 instance which
is my cop server has got all the
required permissions so that he can
create a cluster on my behalf great now
before this let me do a sudo yum update
iphone y so that any of the because this
is a newly provisioned vm i just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when i
do install cop and cube ctl and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or packet
issues so i'm just running a sudo update
iphone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cubs is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location i
have to just copy this and ensure that i
do a curl and i install this particular
stuff all right so it is fetching uh the
cops tool it's installing for me once it
is copied down let me change the mode so
that i can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the corpse
installation let me also do one other
thing let me install something called as
cuba ctl so this is what would be you
know a tool using which i'm going to be
firing my uh commands to my kubernetes
cluster once it comes up right this is a
pretty smaller executable so
ctl all right so i have cubic ctl as
well as cops installed on my ec2 server
now okay now what i'll do next is i'm
going to create an s3 bucket in aws so
that the kubernetes cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name s3
bucket with this name so let me go to s3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name i will just say create a
bucket okay so the simply learn dot
kubernetes is the bucket that i created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a dns entry or a dns
zone or aws route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know i can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that i'm coming up so
i will create a private hosted zone and
possibility possibly i will call this as
simplylearn.net so this will be my name
of my private hosted zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
route 53 hosted zone specific for your
domain name since i don't have anyone
i'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to route
53 click on any of these and you'll get
these hosted zones out here so i'm going
to create a hosted zone here i'm going
to create a hosted zone click on create
hosted zone um this would be simply
learn lot in i want to create a public
no i don't want public i want a private
hostess zone and i'm going to associate
my vpc id uh for this hosted zone since
i'm going to try out all my exercises in
the ohio region i will associate the vpc
of the ohio region for this all right so
this is the one that is specific to the
ohio region so i will say this one i'll
say create a hosted sum great now let me
come back to my ec2 box my ec2 is all
powered with whatever it needs in order
to go ahead with the installation of my
cluster only few things that i need to
take care of is that you know now that i
put a name for my cluster i also have an
uh s3 bucket that i've configured for my
cluster i will have to ensure that i
need to put in these two configurations
as a part of my cluster building
activity so i will open my bash rc file
and i'm going to export these two
variables if at all you remember well
these two variables are nothing but the
cluster name which is nothing but the
public oh sorry the private hosted zone
that i created and the s3 bucket where
i'm going to create or rather i'm going
to store my cluster state so let me copy
these two and open up my
bash rc file all right so i will just
add these two and copy these add export
them out as my ah variable i'm going to
save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right i've got
these two that have configured and i
also ensure that these environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of ssh keys this is to ensure that
i can log into the box that i'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
ssh hyphen keygen i don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so i
created a bunch of my key pair now i'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how i would define my
corpse command how do i have copied here
so corpse create cluster the state of
the
cluster will be stored in this
particular variable which is what i have
exported out the number of node count is
two node count is the worker node count
if at all i don't specify configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if i don't specify that the
default one is one so i'm going to
create one primary or the master node
and two uh worker nodes uh size of my
master node size of the worker nodes uh
what are the zones where i want this to
be created and where do i store the
cluster information and uh okay i've
already added this master account this
is actually not required but this is the
command that i'm going to fire off so
that i bring up my cluster all right
that went off uh very fast but um this
actually did not create a cluster it is
just the definition of a cluster and
that's why this came out very fast
now that everything looks good with uh
whatever configuration that i specified
now let me go ahead and create the
cluster by saying corpse update cluster
iphone iphone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it to because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as i
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration i'm going to come up with
one master server and uh two unknowns or
the worker nodes all right so this is
the command for me to validate the
cluster and i'm going to try it out
first i'm pretty sure that it will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and
see how many servers do i have running
as of now if you see i had only one
server that i had started which was my
cop server and automatically the other
three instances one is called not start
simply not in this these two are the
nodes and this is the master node so
these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that i
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated a good five to
ten minutes so what i'll do is i'll
pause the video now and i'll come back
once the server the cluster is up and
running it's been a good uh eight to
nine minutes uh since i started my
cluster so let me validate now okay
seems good so there's a master node
minimum one max one some nodes which are
nothing but the slave nodes or the
worker nodes there are two of them due
to micro subnet so my clusters seem to
be up and running and my cluster name is
simply learn.n so what i would want to
do is now let me just log into the
master and see if i can run some parts
so let me get back to my
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me log into my
since my cluster name is simply none dot
and this is the way to log into my box
so let me get into my box so if you see
here uh this is the host name of the
machine that i'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our the scop
server this is a server now from here
i'm trying to get into the master box
all right so if you see the ip address
has changed i was in a different box i'm
in a different box now if i see host
name you'll find a different host name
so this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep it's 153 this is the
particular host so i'm getting into this
machine now so i started the cluster
from my cop server here it ran and
brought up three nodes so i'm actually
getting into my master node and see if i
can run some parts on it all right so
let me try cuba ctl uh get cluster info
try cube ctl get nodes all right so
there are three nodes here master node
and um one master node and two worker
nodes so let me see if i have some pods
here cubicle get pods so there's no port
as of now so what i'll try to do is let
me just pin up a very very simple part
just to check if my connections is
everything is correct or not correct i
have a simple
node.js application that i've built uh
i've got a container for that this is
already pushed to the docker i've
registered is called simply learn docker
hub and the image name that i have here
is called my node app and i will use
this image to power one of my parts that
i will run so this is the way in which
i'm going to launch my pod let me show
you these commands cube ctl run the name
for my deployment that i'm going to run
hyphen iphone image and this is the
image that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn docker
hub forward slash my node app hyphen f1
replica is equal to i want two replicas
to be running and the port that i want
to expose this particular part is on 8 0
8 0. so let me run this as soon as this
is run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
um i'm not really interested in the
deployment i'm interested in checking if
all the parts are up and running so i
will say cube ctl get pot all right so
that was pretty fast so i have two parts
that are running here these are two
replicas because i asked for two
replicas these parts are running so i
can run cube ctl describe pod pickup all
right i can pick up any of the pod name
and see what is the pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image name id this is actually
running my pod which is actually
spinning up a container great so far so
good so in kubernetes the pods can are
ephemeral so they can be there at any
time cannot be run time if i need to
expose my pod outside i will have to
create a service for my part so what
i'll do is i'll create a very very
simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that let me check cube
cdl get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so i'll
expose my deployment simply learn app as
uh yeah i'll just expose this let me see
all right i am not specifying what type
and all i don't want to get into the
complications of what are the different
types of exposing the service and all
that stuff so if i don't specify
anything uh it gives me something called
a cluster ip so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this part is up and running i'll
just try a simple curl command curl http
colon this is my cluster ip and the port
is 8080 if at all i hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me whatever
i put a simple uh cis dot out kind of a
thing where i'm just printing um the
container id of whatever pod is serving
uh being sold out of so i'm actually
hitting my container and i'm getting
this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running uh so let me just go and
clean it up i'll say equip ctl uh delete
deployment simply learn app this should
get rid of all the parts that i created
cube ctl get pod all right these parts
are intermediating things let me just
check cube ctl get services there's one
service i don't want this service let me
delete that cube ctl delete service i
want this all right that sounds good so
let me come back to my host my cop
server from where i'm running so i
managed to successfully verify this part
see if everything is up and running so
what i'll do is i'll just go ahead and
complete this uh demo by going and uh
getting rid of my cluster so corpse
delete cluster hyphen f1 yes all right
so this will ensure that it will clean
up my complete cluster that i created so
i had three or four running instances if
you see that all the three are shutting
down because you know the cop server
which had cops installed on it is now
got a mandate to go ahead and shut down
and clean up the whole instances and all
those things that are created as a part
of my deployment i'm here to walk you
through some of the aws interview
questions which we find are important
and our hope is that you would use this
material in your interview preparation
and be able to crack that cloud
interview and step into your dream cloud
job by the way i'm and cloud technical
architect trainer and an interview
panelist for cloud network and devops so
as you progress in watching you're going
to see that these questions are
practical scenario based questions that
tests the depth of the knowledge of a
person in a particular aws product or in
a particular aws architecture so why
wait let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the aws products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run any application and the compute
service helps us in managing the scaling
and deployment of an application again
lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage
talking about networks it's just not
important to answer the question with
the name of the services and the name of
the product it'll also be good if you
could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain
vpc networking can't imagine networking
without vpc in in the cloud environment
especially in aws cloud environment and
then we have route 53 for domain
resolution or
for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get our customers to
read their application with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
planning to work a network you will soon
realize the importance of choosing your
own ip address for easy remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud owned range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that get asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship right so a region is a
separate geographic area like the us2s1
i mean which represents uh north
california
or the ap south which represents mumbai
so regions are a separate geographic
area on the contrary availability zone
resides
inside the region you shouldn't stop
there you should go further and explain
about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regions
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular r now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because auto
scaling is going to handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an aws service the
ability to increase and shrink based on
the need of that art that's how powerful
is auto scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's due targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching servers global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloud front
then what do you mean by geo targeting
jio targeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the url
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
chances that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies and if you're being hired
for
a devops or you know if the interviewer
wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now everybody's moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is going to cause a downtime
right so that's you should be answering
or you shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you're going to use an ami of the old
machine well and good you don't have to
go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the ami once you've launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind
a route 53 let's say all that you could
do is go to rot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cutover is handled or if
you're using static ip you can actually
remove the static ip from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic nic card you can actually
remove the neck card from the old
machine and attach the new card to the
new machine so that way we would get
near zero downtime if you are hired for
an architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get a visibility of your aws
resources running one way is to check
the billing there is a place where you
can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used
services so looking at it you can get it
all right so i'm using a lot of storage
i'm using a lot of ec2 why is storage
high you can go and try to justify that
and you will find if you are storing
things that should be storing and then
clean it up why is compute capacity so
high why is data transfer so high so if
you start thinking in those levels
you'll be able to dig in and clean up
unnecessary and be able to save your
bill and there are cost explorer
services available which will help you
to view your usage pattern or view your
spending for the past 13 months or so
and it will also forecast for the next
three months now how much will you be
using if your pattern is like this that
will actually help and will give you a
visibility on how much you have spent
how much you will be spending if the
trend continues budgets are another
excellent a way to control cost you can
actually set up budget alright this is
how much i am willing to spend for this
application for this team or for this
month for this particular resource so
you can actually put a budget mark and
any time it exceeds any time it's
nearing you would get an alarm saying
that well we're about to reach the
allocated budget amount stuff like that
that way you can go back and know and
you know that how much the bill is going
to be for that month or you can take
steps to control bill amount for that
particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tax now cost allocation
tags are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for production services you would put as
a production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
footy you can configure puri to access
the aws resources like log into an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance like the jump box like
the proxy machine and like the gateway
machine and from there you can actually
access the rest of the resources so this
is an alternative to the console and of
course we have the aws cli in any of the
linux machines or windows machines we
can install so that's point two three
and four we can install aws cli for
linux windows also for mac so we can
install them and from there from your
local machine we can access run aws
commands and access provision monitor
the aws resources the other ones are we
can access the aws resource
programmatically using aws sdk and
eclipse so these are bunch of options we
have to use the aws resource other than
the console if you're interviewed in a
company or by a company that focuses
more on security and want to use aws
native services for their security then
you would come across this question what
services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution
the basic services we could use our
cloudwatch logs store them in s3 and
then use elasticsearch to visualize them
and use kinesis to move the data from s3
to elasticsearch right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs
instead of logging into an instance or
instead of logging into the environment
and checking the resources physically i
can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system will scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
cloud watch pushes it to s3 kinesis
pushes the data from s3 to elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one or whatever the time window
that i wanted to look at so it helps in
getting a good understanding of the
infrastructure as a whole all the logs
are getting saved in one place so all
the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts it doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor
so as you see you have cloud watch here
that actually tracks the metrics you can
also use cloud trail if you want to log
api calls as well push them in an s3
bucket so there are different types of
blog flow logs are getting captured in
an instance application logs are getting
captured from the same vpc from a
different vpc from the same account from
a different account and all of them are
analyzed using elasticsearch using the
kibana client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so resting access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloud watch to
the elasticsearch domain and then kibana
is actually the graphical tool that
helps us to visualize the logs instead
of looking at log as just statements or
in a bunch of characters a bunch of
files kibana helps us to analyze the
logs in a graphical or a chart or a bar
diagram format
again in an interview the interview is
more concerned about testing your
knowledge on aw security products
especially on the logging monitoring
even management or incident management
then you could have a question like this
what are the native aws security logging
capabilities now most of the services
have their own logging in them like have
their own logging like s3 s3 has its own
login and cloudfront has its own login
ds has its own login vpc has its own
login in additional there are account
level logins like a cloudtrail and aws
config services so there are variety of
logging options available
in the aws like cloud soil config
cloudfront redshift logging rds logging
vpc flow logs s3 object logging s3
access logging stuff like that so we're
going to look at two servers in specific
cloud trail now this cloud trail the
very first product in that picture we
just thought the cloud trail provides an
very high level history of the api calls
for all the account and with that we can
actually perform a very good security
analysis a security analysis of our
account and these logs are actually
delivered to you can configure it they
can be delivered to s3 for long time
archivals and based on a particular
event it can also send an email
notification to us saying hey just got
this error thought i'll let you know
stuff like that the other one is config
service a config service helps us to
understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aws config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if you know your role
includes taking care of cloud security
as well then the other question you
could get asked is the native services
that amazon provides or to mitigate ddos
which is denial of service now not all
companies would go with amazon native
services but there are some companies
which want to stick with amazon native
services just to save them from the
headache of managing the other softwares
or bringing in another tool a
third-party tool into managing ddos they
simply want to stick with amazon
proprietary amazon native services and a
lot of companies are using amazon
service to prevent ddos denial of
service now denial of service is if you
already know what denial of service is
well and good if you do not know then
let's know it now denial of service is a
user trying to or maliciously making
attempt to access a website or an
application the user would actually
create multiple sessions and he would
occupy all the sessions and he would not
let legitimate users access the servers
so he's in turn denying the service for
the user a quick picture review of what
denial of services now look at it these
users instead of making one connection
they are making multiple connections and
there are cheap software programs
available that would actually trigger
connections from different computers in
the internet with different mac
addresses so everything kind of looks
legitimate for the server and it would
accept those connections and it would
keep the sessions open the actual users
won't be able to use them so that's
denying the service for the actual users
denial of service all right and
distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aws now they are
the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using aws
shield or aws vaf and there are a couple
of other tools that also does when i say
that also does denial of service is not
their primary job but you could use them
for denial of service route 53's purpose
is to provide dns cloudfront is to
provide caching elastic load balancer
elbs work is to provide load balancing
vpc is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in aws
shield and aws web so aws shield and
waff are the primary ones but the rest
can also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america north virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region
now you might think well if i'm looking
for a service in asia let's say in
mumbai and if it is not available why
not simply switch to north virginia and
start using it you could but you know
that's going to add more latency to your
application so that's why we need to
check for application which is check for
region which is very near to the place
where you want to serve your customers
and find nearest region instead of
always going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again leisure place there's a
link in aws.com that you can go and look
for services available in different
region and that's exactly what you're
seeing here and if your service is not
available in a particular region switch
to the other region that provides your
service the nearest other region that
provides that service and start using
service from there
with the
coming up of cloud a lot of companies
have turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage aws
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor to
website how to set up a monitor to
monitor the website metrics in real time
in aws the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
network at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are there are more services added
there is a reduction in the number of
servers because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloudwatch any cloudwatch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action all
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you are designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and
based on what's happening it can trigger
an event in lambda and that would in
turn run a function till the environment
comes back to normal so cloudwatch
integrates well with a lot of other aw
services
all right so cloudwatch has
three statuses green when everything is
going good yellow when the service is
degraded and red when the service is not
available green is good so we don't have
to do anything about it but anytime
there is an ello the picture that we're
looking at it's actually calling an
lambda function to debug the application
and to fix it and anytime there's a red
alert it immediately notifies the
owner of the application about well the
service is down and here is the report
that i have here is the metrics that
i've collected about the service stuff
like that if the job role requires you
to manage the servers as well there are
certain job roles which are on the
system side there are certain job roles
which is development plus system side
now you're responsible for the
application and the server as well so if
that's the case you might be tested with
some basic questions like the different
types of virtualization in aws and what
are the difference between them all
right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization on hardware virtual
module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pv amis and when we talk
about pv on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host
another good question is name some of
the services that are not region
specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that vpc is both
availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpcs
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have im for every availability zone and
for every region which means you know
users will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means it's not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can you know cache
content on a continent and country basis
it's still considered a global service
right it's not bound to any region so
when you activate cloud front you're
activating it away from region or
availability zone so when you're
activating a web application firewall
because it's not a region-specific
service you're activating it away from
availability zone and regions
so a quick recap imusers groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally route 53
services are offered at edge locations
and they are global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using nat or if they are already
securing their environment using nat by
any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between an ad gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about
the availability of it
that gateway is a managed service by
amazon whereas nat instance is managed
by us now i'm talking about the third
point maintenance here nat gateway is
managed by amazon that instance is
managed by us and availability of nat
gateway is very high and availability of
that instance is
less compared to the nat gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not gateway if something
happens to that service amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
net gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and if we are launching a t2 micro it
barely gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the nat gateway is very
high but the performance of the nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the net instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
nat gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the nat gateway but billing
for that instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
security in that gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
such a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the uh that instance
changes as per our ad gateway is a fixed
product but that instance can be small
instance can be a big instance so the
size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab
and are attending the interview chances
are that you might your ways lost when
answering this question it might look
like both are the same well stopping and
terminating both are the same but there
is a difference in it so when you stop
an instance it actually performs a
normal shutdown on the instance and it
simply moves the instance to the stopped
state but when you actually terminate
the instance the instance is moved to
this stop state the ebs volumes that are
attached to it are deleted and removed
and we'll never be able to recover them
again so that's a big difference between
stopping and terminating an instance if
you're thinking of using the instance
again along with the data in it you
should only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that gets asked what are
the different types of ec2 instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them all right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on demand instances spot instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of hardwares for us but if you are
looking at cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we got to be
very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
i'll go with on-demand instance because
i pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know i can use them anytime i want
and anytime i don't want i can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so on demand is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short-term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on-demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using
on-demand for production spot instance
spot instance allows users to purchase
ec2 at a reduced price and any time we
have more instances we can always go and
sell it in spot instances i'm referring
to any time we have more reserved
instances we can always sell them in
spot instance catalog and the way we buy
spot instance is we actually put a
budget this is how much i'm willing to
pay all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price comes down and meets the cost that
we have put in will be assigned an
instance and anytime the price shoots up
the instance will be taken away from us
but in case of on-demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances it varies based on
the price if you meet the price you get
the instance if you don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and the spot
instance availability is actually based
on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time all right so
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat that you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot instance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
then how much was it how much is it this
month so how can i code or how much can
i code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company we can opt for
reserved instances for you know one year
or three years there are actually three
types of reserved instances light medium
and heavy reserved instances they are
based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
upfront or no upfront or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall if you're looking
at using an application for the next one
year and three years you should not be
going for on-demand instance you should
be going for reserved instance and
that's what gives you the cost benefit
and in an error-based interview
sometimes you might be asked you know
how you interact with the aws
environment are you using cli are you
using console and depending on your
answer whether console or a cli the
panelist put a score okay this person is
cli specific this person is console
specific or this person has used aws
environment through the sdk stuff like
that so this question tests whether you
are a cli person or an console person
and the question goes like this how do
you set up ssh agent forwarding so that
you do not have to copy the key every
time you log in if you have used puri
anytime if you want to log into an ec2
instance you will have to put the ip and
the port number along with that you will
have to map or we will have to map the
key in the puri and this has to be done
every time that's what we would have
done in our lab environments right but
in production environment using the same
key or mapping the same key again and
again every time it's actually an hassle
it's considered as a blocker so you
might want to cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your puddi session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your putty instance so we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key to the ssh and next time when we
try to log in you don't have to always
go through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solares and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solar s and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different and solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers they
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails
well we know that ec2 instances are
considered as immutable meaning
irreparable we don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once
an ec2 instance crashes like it goes on
a ospanic or there are various reasons
why it would fail so we don't have to
really worry about fixing it we can
always relaunch that instance and that
would fix it but what if it happens at
two o'clock in the night what if it
happens that during a weekend when
nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that not only
on a weekend or during midnight but it's
general practice good to automate it so
you could face this question how do you
actually automate an ec2 instance once
it fails and the answer to that question
is using cloudwatch we can recover the
instance so as you see there is an alarm
threshold a set in cloud watch and once
the threshold is met meaning if there is
an error if there is a failure if the
ec2 instance is not responding for a
certain while we can set an alarm and
once the alarm is met let's say the cpu
utilization stayed high for five minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm going
to do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of ami designs there are
a lot of ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back a mice and the other one is just
enough os ami j e os ami and the other
one is hybrid type amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's uh ready to use ami and
this is the simplest ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
ami so a lot of planning a lot of
thought process will go into it and the
ami is ready to use right you hand over
the ami to somebody and it's ready to
use or if you want to reuse the ami it's
already ready for you to use so that's
full baked ami the other one is just
enough operating system ami just like
the name says
it has i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is the hybrid
ami now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami and just
enough operating system options so these
amis have some features of the big type
and some features of the just enough os
type so as you see the security
monitoring logging
are packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed during the
time of a deployment so this is where
the strict company policies would go
into the ami company policies like you
got to lock this you got to monitor this
these are the ports that generally gets
open in all the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami format and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an ec2 instance
another very famous question you would
face in an interview is how can you
recover login to an ec2 instance to
which you lost the key well we know that
if the key is lost we can't recover it
there are some organizations that
integrate their ec2 instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the ad and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just a couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure run in that ec2
instance and then detach the root volume
for that instance of course it's going
to require a stop and start to detach
the root volume from the instance attach
the root volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then log in
to that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but abs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's going to
run stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and evs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
server it's a very external service
you'll have to go through or you'll have
to go outside of your vpc to access s3
s3 does not come under a vpc but ebs
comes under a vpc it's on the same vpc
so you would be able to use it kind of
locally compared to s3 ebs is very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is
replicated the data in s3 is replicated
across the data centers but ebs is
replicated within the data center
meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words redundancy is higher in s3 than
eps and talking about security of s3 is3
can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he is
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we would actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put attack on them put attack saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources with this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are tagged
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them and the same goes
for bucket as well or if an organization
is excessively using s3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users who are local to that region
stuff like that so when companies do
replication how do you make sure that
there is consistency in the replication
how do you make sure that the
replication is not failing and the data
gets transferred for sure and there are
logs for that replication this is
something that the companies would use
where they are excessively using s3 and
they're fully relying on the replication
in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have region two and region
one is the source bucket and region two
is the destination bucket all right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or made a copy in the region to
bucket and the problem is sometimes it
fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these services together and
create and cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watch
that make sure that the data is
moved no data is failing again there's
cloud watch on the other end make sure
that the data is moving and then we have
the logs generated through cloudtrail
and that's actually written in dynamodb
and if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a vpc is not resolving the server
through the dns you can access it
through the ip but not through the dns
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default vpc does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the dns hostname
resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns hostname resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
one simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and they have a head office in a
central place and the rest of them are
branch offices and they are connecting
to the head office for access or you
know for saving data or for accessing
certain files or certain data or storing
data all right so they would actually
mimic the hub and spoke topology where
you have the vpc which is centrally in
an accessible region a centrally
accessible region and then you would
have a local vpcs or branch offices in
different other regions and they get
connected to the vpc in the central
location
and the question is how do you actually
connect the multiple sites to a vpc and
make communication happen between them
by default it does not do that we know
that vpcs they need to be paired between
them in order to access the resources
let's look at this picture right so i
have like a customer network or branch
offices in different parts and they get
connected to a vpc that's fine so what
we have achieved is those different
offices
the remote offices they are connecting
to the vpc and they're talking but they
can't connect or they can't talk to each
other that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then
reach the other customer network which
is in los angeles or which is in new
york all right that's the requirement so
that's possible with some architecting
in the cloud so that's using vpn cloud
hub you look at this dotted lines which
actually allows customers or which
actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpc has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is neyman explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
vpc or the vpc delivers those products
to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security product in vpc
and a vpc has security groups that
protects the instances from unwanted
inbound and outbound traffic and network
access control list protects the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc except for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason so how do you monitor
your vpc how do you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc using vpc flow log that's the
basic service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which ip's
allowed which ip is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed i mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a certain
hike in the graph that the sudden hike
and something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at cloud watch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought we'll also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key to clear them is to
understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services are good enough
all right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game could be a mobile
game it's a game that you are trying to
design and you need a millisecond
latency and it has to be a database all
right so let's talk about the options
available rds rds is a database for sure
is it good for a game design we'll come
back to that neptune uh neptune is a
graph a database service in amazon so
that's kind of out of the equation and
snowball is actually a storage all right
it's it's a transport medium i would say
so that's again out of the equation so
the tie is between rds and dynamodb if
we need to talk about rds rds is an a
platform as a service it provides cost
efficient resizable capacity but it's an
sql database meaning the tables are kind
of strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with the gaming so the only option left
is dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so talks about real-time
monitoring a firewall manager what does
it provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and aws guard duty is and
thread detection service it does
monitoring it does continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that
helps to track metrics it's a service
that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
i mean we have one more option left
that's uh ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's i mean if
there is one relation between cloud
watch and guard duty that's monitoring
so easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking guard duty but
know that guard duty is only for gaining
security inside but not about gaining
aws service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a system
wide or an aws wide or an account wide
and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good insight of
how a service is performing be it cpu be
it ram b network utilization beat
connection failures cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily all right so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here uh shield aws
massey aws inspector amazon cognito so
let's try to weed out services which are
not relevant to it so what's aws shield
aws shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with
improving the security and compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud so
kind of looks like it could be because
it has to do with apps the last one
cognito now cognito is a service that
actually lets the administrator to have
control access over
web and mobile apps and it's a service
that helps us to sign up and
sign in to an mobile and web app so that
very much looks like we found the answer
so cognito is a service that helps web
app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has i mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who would be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question uh you are an ml engineer or a
machine learning engineer who is on the
lookout for a solution that will
discover sensitive information that your
enterprise stores in aws and then uses
nlp to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the above
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify uh the data
depending on severity the sensitivity
classify the data so which service is
that so firewall manager just like the
name says it's a manager and the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation then the aw is massey we
already had a quick
definition description for aws massey
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning kind of looks
like it could be it it's a security
service that uses machine learning and
it discovers and classifies the
sensitive information not only that it
does not stop there it goes beyond and
protects the sensitive data aws massey
kind of looks like but we still have one
more option to look at which is cloud
hms cloud hms is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of fifty percent of it it's
a security service it encrypts helps us
protect the data but aws maxi is right
on spot it's a machine learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for this question would be aws messy so
hope you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify the question that's being asked
read between the lines and then try to
find the service that meets your
requirement then finding the service is
by first weeding out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service and see how well that
matches with those hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with two
just to to decide from at some point and
then it becomes easy for you to decide
click on the question submit it and then
move on to the other question in your
interview all right so how about this
one you are a system administrator in a
company which is running most of its
infrastructure on aws you are required
to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to looking at the permissions
we can actually predict whether the user
or the group will have servers or not so
that helps us to get a track of who is
able to use who's not able to use
certain servers and all that stuff so it
kind of looks like but we have other
three options left let's look at aws
firewall manager just like the name says
it's actually a firewall manager it
helps us to manage multiple firewalls
simple as that and shield is a service
it's a service that's used to protect
denial of service or distributed denial
of service an api gateway is a service
that makes it easy for developers to
create publish maintain and monitor and
secure api so i mean it's completely on
the api side very less on user and how
you authenticate your user we can get
that by looking at the name itself right
if you abbreviate it or if you if you
try to find a definition for the name
api gateway you would get it it has to
do with api but if we aggregate aws iam
its identity and access management
pretty much meets the requirement for
the problem statement about its aws
identity and access management that's
the right answer all right let's look at
this one if you want to allocate various
private and public ip address in order
to make them communicate
with the internet and other instances
you will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us
to allow i mean the security in vpc the
security group the network access
control list in a vpc that routing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular ip
address or to a particular service
within the vpc or outside of the vpc so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the amazon vpc gateway api gateway
we know that it's a managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure api so that has completely do
with api not with ip cloudfront we know
about cloudfront that it's a content
delivery network and it provides global
distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily all right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpz can help us with a private ip
address vpc can be used to allow deny
connection based on the security group
access control list and routing table it
has so that's right answer is vpc all
right how about this one this platform
as a service or platform as a db service
provides us with a cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating time
consuming administrative tasks so this
question is very clear it's a db service
we got to look for and it's a service
that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be resizable at the same
time so let's talk about amazon rational
database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if
that matches the definition that
we've figured out about elastic cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an in-memory data store which
helps in achieving
high throughput and
low latency in memory data store so it's
not a full-blown database and it does
not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything like that yeah we can resize
the capacity as and when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and
amazon glacier glacier is a storage but
not a database all right so that's again
of the equation so that tie is kind of
between amazon rational database service
and amazon elastic cache because they
both aid the database service but
elastic cache is not a full-blown
database it actually helps database but
it's not a full-blown database so it's
amazon relational database so that's the
one which is a platform as a service
it's the one which can be resized it's
the one which
can be used to automate the time
consuming administrative tasks all right
let's talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or temporary
basis all right let's read the question
again which of the following is a means
for accessing human researchers or
consultant to help solve problems on a
contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides
a human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be an repetitive task one time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive task
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated task the scenario you
know it should have been there already
only then that can be executed but if
it's a new scenario and it requires uh
appropriate addressing then it requires
human task so we could hire researchers
and consultants who can help solve a
problem using amazon mechanical turk the
other two are already out of the
equation now dev pay is actually a
payment system through amazon and
multi-factor authentication as it says
it's an authentication system so the
right answer is amazon mechanical turk
all right this sounds interesting let's
look at this one this service is used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized
instances so that's again out of the
equation would light scale be a good
time for elastic container service
what's light sale now light style is a
service it's called as virtual private
server without a vpc it's called as a
virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers no servers run code select the
correct service from the below option
all right so no servers but we should be
able to run code amazon easy to order
scaling easy to auto scaling ec2 is
elastic compute cloud which is a server
and auto scaling is a service that helps
us to achieve scaling the server so
that's the definition for it could be
that's out of the equation aw is lambda
now lambda is a service it's actually an
event driven serverless computing
platform and lambda runs code in
response to the event that it receives
and it automatically manages the compute
resource that's required for that code
as long as we have uploaded a code
that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batch is
service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that and about inspector
amazon inspector it's actually a service
that helps us to increase and identify
any security issues and align our
application with compliance well that's
not the requirement of the question the
requirement and the question was run
code without provisioning a server and
without any more space for confusion aws
lambda is a service or is the service
that runs code without provisioning and
managing services right the right one
would be aws lambda i'm very excited
that you're watching this video and i'm
equally glad that we were able to
provide you a second part in aws
interview questions all right let's get
started so in an environment where
there's a lot of automation
infrastructure automation you'll be
posted with this question how can you
add an existing instance to a new auto
scaling group now this is when you are
taking an instance away from the auto
scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it has part of
it it's not a straight uh procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added i've
had worked with some clients so when
their developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like i said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the
instance under actions in specific you
know there's an option called attach to
auto skilling group right if you have
multiple auto scaling groups in your
account or in the region that you're
working in then you're going to be
posted with the different auto scaling
groups that you have in your account
let's say you have five auto scaling
groups for five different application
you know you're going to be posted with
five different auto scaling groups and
then you would select
the auto scaling the appropriate auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular auto scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you
know that's possible as well sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto skilling group there would
be requirement that you change the
instance type to a better one to a
better family to the better instance
type you could do that at that time and
after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step up process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and vm into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth
moving the instance to the cloud given
the additional bills and results
features available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and supply transparency is
this application and high demand you
know is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are a few things that
needs to be considered before we move
the application to the cloud and then if
the application does the application
needs to be provisioned immediately is
that an urge is there an urge to
provision the application immediately
that's something that needs to be
considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their softwares buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means uh you know workforce productivity
loss is it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if if your application is of that type
if there is a urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if
the
the software or if the product that
you're launching it requires hardware it
requires an updated hardware all the
time that's not going to be possible in
on premises we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in on
premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they're
constantly the cloud providers are
constantly updating their hardwares and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
tied to the revenue of the company and
you don't want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business uh agility you know
moving to
the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails amazon makes sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is rto and rpo in aws they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo in
your environment or how to define rto
how do you define rpo or some general
questions that get asked rto is recovery
time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is uh
in the future right how much time
is it going to take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's rto on
the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data laws your company is willing to
accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was
before 12 hours you have lost the in
between 12 hours of
uh data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount if the company wants
less rpo rpo is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups every one
hour if rpo is 12 hours then you should
be planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how rpo and rto you know
helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you'd
like to transfer huge amount of data
which is the best option among snowball
snowball edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that gets asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with the migrating
data into the cloud i'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now aws snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball edge adds additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball edge has a compute function
attached to it snow mobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation different from
aws elastic beanstalk you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and elastic bean stock
gives us an small contained environment
in which we can run our application and
the cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs of many different
types of application like the
enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock it's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using cloud formation to manage
their infrastructure using or if they're
using infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a code services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an aws cloud
formation template so it has a four or
five
basic
elements right and the template is in
the form of json or in yaml format all
right so it has parameters it has
outputs it has data it has resources and
then the
format or the format version or the file
format version for the cloud formation
template so parameter is nothing but
it actually lets you to specify the type
of ec2 instance
that you want the type of rds that you
want right so ec2 is an umbrella rds is
an umbrella and parameters within that
ec2 and parameters within that rds are
the specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the rds service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted
in the result section so we can simply
go and look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource rds is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and nat gateway
is a resource vpc is a resource so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0 9 0 9
2010 that's the latest version number
you'll be able to find that on the top
of the cloud formation template and that
version number defines the capabilities
of the cloud formation template so just
need to make sure that it's the latest
all the time still talking about cloud
formation this is another classic
question what happens when one of the
resource in a stack cannot be created
successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful
when the cloud formation cannot you know
go forward cloud formation cannot create
additional resources because we have
reached the elastic
ip limits elastic ip limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five ips and a cloud formation is trying
to buy three more ips you know we've hit
the soft limit till we fix that with
amazon cloudformation will not be able
to you know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 ami as
well if an ami is included in the
template and but the ami is not actually
present then cloudformation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it created
so that's what cloud formation does it
simply rolls back all the resources that
it created i mean if it sees a failure
it would simply roll back all the
resources that it created and this
feature actually simplifies the system
administration and layout solutions
built on top of aws cloud formation so
at any point we know that there are no
orphan resources in the in in our
environment you know because something
did not work or because there was an you
know cloud formation executed some there
are no orphan resources in our account
at any point we can be sure that if
cloud formation is launching a resource
and if it's going to fail and it's going
to come back and delete all the
resources it's created so there are no
orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store again if the
environment deals with a lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
backup using ebs it's actually a six
step process to automate the ec2 backups
we'll need to write a script to automate
the below steps uh using aws api and
these are the steps that should be found
in the scripts first to get the list of
instances and then and then the script
that we are writing should be able to
connect to aws using the api and list
the amazon abs volumes that are attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list the snapshots of each
volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because you have captured the latest and
10 snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot of each volume create a new
snapshot of each volume and then delete
the old snapshot anytime a new snapshot
gets created the oldest snapshot of the
list needs to go away so we need to
include options we need to include
scripts in our script lines in our
script that make sure that it's deleting
the older snapshots which are older than
the retention period that we are
mentioning another question that you
could see in the interview be it a
written interview beat online interview
or beat and telephonic or face to face
interview is what's the difference
between ebs and instant store let's talk
about ebs first ebs is kind of permanent
storage the data in it can be restored
at a later point when we save data in
ebs the data lives even after the
lifetime of the ec2 instance for example
we can stop the instance and the data is
still going to be present in ebs we can
move the ebs from one instance to
another instance and the data is simply
going to be present there so abs is kind
of permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine ebs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of the
machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with eba so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using ebs and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take efs to efs backup solution efs
does not support snapshot like ebs efs
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for efs elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one efs to another efs and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
efs and this can be automated but any
data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole ef is is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an
one-step configuration it's a cycle
there are series of steps that's
involved before we can achieve efs to
efs backup the first thing is to sign in
to the aws management console and under
efs or click on efs to efs restore
button from the services list and from
there we can use the region selector in
the console navigation bar to select the
actual region in which we want to work
on and from there i'll ensure that we
have selected the
right template now some of the templates
would be you know efs to efs backup
granular backups incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take you want to take grant
alert do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is
not always an you know click button or
an single step configuration so you
might be facing a question like how do
you auto delete old snapshots and the
procedure is like this now as best
practice we will take snapshots of ebs
volume to s3 all snapshots get stored in
s3 we know that now and we can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all snapshots the ops automator service
it allows us to create copy delete ebs
snapshots so there are cloud formation
templates available for aws ops
automator and this automator template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots it would you know copy
the snapshot from one region to another
region if you want i know if you're
setting up a dr environment and not only
that based on the retention period that
we
create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than the
retention period so life or managing
snapshot is made a lot easier because of
this ops automator cloud formation
template moving into questions and
elastic load balancer this again could
be an uh question in the interview what
are the different types of load
balancers in aws and what's their use
case what's the difference between them
and as of now as we speak there are
three types of load balancers which are
available in aws the first one being
application load balancer just like the
name says the application load balancer
works on the application layer and deals
with the http and https request and it
also supports part based routing for
example
simplylearn.com slash some webpage
simplylearn.com
another website so it's going to direct
the path based on the slash value that
you give in the urls that's path based
routing so it supports that and not only
that it can support a port based colon
8080 colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know
based on that port also it can take a
routing decision and that's what
application load balancer does on the
other hand we have network load balancer
and the network load balancer makes
routing decisions at the transport level
it's faster because it has a very less
thing to work on it works on lower osi
layer it works on a lower layer so it
has very less information to work with
than compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives the
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path-based or
port-based routing it does simple
routing and because of it it's faster
and then we have classic load balancer
which is kind of expiring as we speak
amazon is discouraging people using
classic load balancer but there are
companies which are still using classic
load balancer they are the ones who were
the first one to step in to amazon when
classic load balancer was the first load
balancer or the only load balancer
available at that point so it supports
http https tcp ssl protocol and it has a
fixed relationship between a load
balance report and the container port so
initially we only have classic load
balancer and then
at after some point amazon said instead
of having one load balancer address all
type of traffic we're going to have two
load balances called as the child from
the classic two load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balancers talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it application load balancer is
used if we need a flexible application
management and tls termination and
network load balancer if we require
extreme performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static ips for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from ec2
classic network now this is an older
version of vpc or this is what was
present before vpc was created easy to
classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of this
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we cannot
avoid discussion talking about waff web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use aws off in monitoring your
aws applications waff or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or a block
which traffic from a certain source you
know which source or which traffic from
a certain source should be allowed or
blocked your application with waff we
can also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple uh
data management data storage application
it has i mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack so based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and waff can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then a block all request and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and management
service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in aws off are the origin
ips and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
origin ip allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
a malicious sql code in a connection
that we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different aws im categories
we can control using aws iim we can do
the following one is create and manage
iem users and once the user database
gets bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in im we can
use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like mfa and you know rotating the
passwords you know resetting the
password there are a few things we could
do with iam and finally we can create
policies that actually grants access to
aw services and resources another
question you will see is what are the
policies that you can set for your users
password so some of the policies that we
can set for the user password is at the
minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters in the password so that's one
and then the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an automatic expiration of
the password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not still old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin i mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or there are a few things that
we can control and set for the users
when the users are setting or recreating
the password another question that could
be posted in an interview so to
understand your understanding of iem is
what's the difference between an im role
and an im user let's talk about iem user
let's start small and then go big or
let's start simple and then talk about
the complex one the iem user has a
permanent long-term credential and it's
used to interact directly with aws
services and on the other hand iem role
is an iem entity that defines a set of
permissions for making aws service
request so im user is an permanent
credential and role are temporary
credentials and iem user has full access
to all aws iem functionalities and with
role trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services uh assume
the role so when an im user is given an
permission you know it sticks within the
iem user but with roles we can give
permissions to applications we can give
permissions to users in the same account
in a different account corporate id we
can give permissions to ec2 s3 rds vpc
and lot more role is wide and im user is
is not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that im user let's
talk about managed policies in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and amazon managed
so manage policies are im resources that
express permissions using the iam policy
language we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the im user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so i can
have like three services four services
point to a particular policy and if i
edit that particular policy it's going
to reflect on those three or four
services so anything that i allow is
going to be allowed for those four
services anything that i denied is going
to be denied for the four services
imagine what would be without the im
managed policy will have to go and
specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like i said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policies and then the other is managed
by aws which is aws managed policy this
question can you give an example of an
iem policy and a policy summary this is
actually to test how well versed are you
with the aws console the answer to that
question is look at the following policy
this policy is used to grant access to
add update and delete objects from a
specific folder now in this case name of
the folder is
example folder and it's present in a
bucket called example bucket so this is
an iam policy on the other hand the
policy summary is a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so iam policy is all
about one particular resource and the
policy summary is all about multiple
resources with iem policy it was only
talking about s3 bucket and one
particular s3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of iam and how
does im help your business two important
or primary work of im is to help us
manage iam users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users to their appropriate aws resources
so that's one it does and the second
thing it does is manage access for
federated users federated users or non
iam users and through iam we can
actually allow and provide secured
access to resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential google credential amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party uh identity
management right so we could actually
trust them and we could give them access
to our account based on the trust
relationship that we have built with the
other identity of systems all right so
two things one is manage users and their
access
for manage iam user and their access in
our aws environment and second is
manage access for federated users who
are non-iim users and more importantly
im is a free service and with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the im username and
password that we create all right lets
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53. one classic question that
could be asked in an interview is what
is the difference between latency based
routing and
geodns or jio based dns routing now the
geo-based dns routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between
networks and
data centers now latency based routing
is used where you want to give your
customers the lowest latency as possible
so that's when we would use latency
based routing and on the other hand the
geo-based routing is when we want to
direct customers to different websites
based on the country they are browsing
from you know you could have you know
two different or three different
websites for the same url you know take
amazon the shopping website for example
when we go to
amazon.com from in the us it directs us
to the us web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and and a couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from india it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a geo
based routing another use case of jio
based routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the dns requests sorry if you should
handle all the
requests you know from a country within
the country then you would do geo-based
routing now you wouldn't direct the
customer to a server which is in another
country right you would direct the
customer to a server which is very local
to them that's another use case of jio
based routing and like i said for
latency based routing the whole goal or
aim is to achieve minimum end user
latency if you are hired for the
architect role and
if that requires working lot on the dns
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
internet right so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand hosted zone is actually
an container that holds information
about how you want to route traffic on
the internet to a specific domain for
example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted zone
whereas simplylearn.com is a domain so
in other words in hosted zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it lms is a prefix here ftp is a prefix
mail.simplylearn.com as a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question
from another classic question from route
53 would be how does amazon drop 53
provide high availability and low
latency the way amazon route 53 provides
high availability and low latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with amazon amazon is a
globally distributed dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal locations it has got a
global service or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide high availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in aws config a
classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloudtrail
aws cloudtrail actually records user api
activity on the account and you know any
http https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any api calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloud trail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your cloud environment on
the other hand config is an uh point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in aws
conflict all right so with that
information you can always answer the
question what did my aws resource look
like at a given point in time that
question gets answered when we use aws
config on the other hand with cloudtrail
you can answer the question i mean by
looking at the cloud trail or with the
help of cloudtrail you can easily answer
the question who made an apa call to
modify this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happen to be a
downtime and you want to identify who
made that change in the environment you
can simply look at cloudtrail and find
out who made the change and if you want
to look at how the environment looks
like before the change you can always
look at aws config can aws configure or
aws config aggregate
data across different aws accounts yes
it can now this question is actually to
test whether you have used aws config or
not i know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability zone specific some of them
are regional specific and some of them
are
global
services in amazon and though some of
the services are region services you
still can do some changes you know add
some configuration to it and collect
regional data
in it for example s3 is a regional
service but still you can collect logs
from all other regions into an s3 bucket
in one particular region that's possible
and cloud trail is and cloud watch is an
regional service but still you can with
some changes to it with some adding
permissions to it you can always monitor
the cloud watch that belongs to
cloudwatch logs that belongs to other
regions you know they're not global by
default but you can do some changes and
make it global similarly aws config is a
service that's a region based service
but still you can make it act globally
you can aggregate data across a
different region and different accounts
in an aws config and deliver
the updates from different accounts to
one s3 bucket and can access it from
there aws config also works or
integrates seamlessly with sns topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer wants to understand how well
you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand db instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low
per hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved incidence is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
on-demand instances are built on an
oddly early price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y the two types of
scaling as you would know now uh
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can vertically scale up the
master database with a couple of clicks
all right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on t2 micro
now we would like to run it on m3 two
times large instance previously it had
one virtual cpu one gigabit now it's
going to have eight virtual cpu and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one vm now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 vms all
right that's horizontal scaling so
database can only be scaled vertically
and there are 18 different types of
instances we can resize our rds to right
so this is true for rds mysql postgres
sql mariadb oracle microsoft sql servers
there are 18 type of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for replicas
so they are read only replicas we're not
going to touch the master
database we're not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling only with amazon aurora and i
can add additional read replicas i can
add up to 15 read replicas for amazon
aurora and up to five re-replicas for
rds mysql postgres sql and marie db rds
instances and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right a read-only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking in to increase
the storage and the processing capacity
will have to do a vertical scaling if
you are looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be
looking for horizontal scaling or we
need to be implementing horizontal
scaling in our environment still talking
about database this is another good
question you can expect in the interview
what is the maintenance window in amazon
rds will your db instance be available
during the maintenance event all right
so this is really to test how well you
have understood the s delay how well you
have understood the amazon rdas the
failover mechanism of amazon rdas stuff
like that so rds maintenance window it
lets you decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the db
instance will be available during that
event because you're gonna have primary
and secondary right so when that upgrade
happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach
consistency within a second and
sometimes when you write and when you're
you know trying to read immediately
chances that you would still be reading
the old data that's eventual consistency
on the other hand there is another
consistency model called the strong
consistency or strongly consistent read
where there is going to be a delay in
writing the data you know making sure
the data is written in all places but it
guarantees one thing that is once you
have done a write and then you're trying
to do a read it's going to make sure
that it's going to show you the updated
data not the old data and you can be
guaranteed of it that it is going to
show the updated data and not the old
data that's strongly consistent still
talking about database talking about
nosql dynamodb or nosql database which
is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of query
functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using global secondary index
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite
partition sort key in other words a
dynamodb indexes a composite partition
sort key as a partition key element and
the sort key element and by holding the
partition key you know when doing a
search or when doing a query by holding
the partition key element constant we
can search across the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and the composite partition sort
key should be a combination of user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sort key is made
of let's look at some of the multiple
choice questions you know sometimes some
companies would have an uh written test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for at the first level or
before they call you for the second
level so these are some classical
questions that companies asked or
companies ask in their multiple choice
online questions let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have aws step functions amazon
mq amazon simple queue service amazon
simple notification service let's read
the question again as a developer using
this pay-per-use service so the service
that we are looking for is a
pay-per-view service you can send store
and retrieve messages between two
software components kind of like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simply queue service is the
one that's used to decouple at the
environment it breaks the tight coupling
and then it introduces decoupling in
that environment by providing a queue or
by inserting a queue between two
software components let's look at this
other question if you would like to host
a real-time audio and video conferencing
application on aws it's an audio and
video conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use application what is this
service let's look at the options they
are amazon
chime amazon workspace amazon mq amazon
app stream but you might tend to look at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference but it's actually
for a different purpose is actually
amazon chime that lets you create chat
and create a chat board and then
collaborate with the security of the aws
services so it lets you do the audio it
lets you do the video conference all
supported by aws security features it's
actually amazon chime let's look at this
question as your company's aw solution
architect you are in charge of designing
thousands of individual jobs which are
similar which of the following service
best serves your requirement aws ec2
autoscaling aws snowball aws
fargate aws badge let's read the
question again as your company's aws
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar it looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an storage uh transport service
ec2 auto scaling is uh you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and aws far gate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are similar aws batch it's the right
answer but let's look at the other one
you are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train machine learning
models in aws which among the following
are we referring to so we have amazon
sage maker and aws deep lens amazon
comprehend aws device form let's read
the question again you are a machine
learning engineer and you're looking for
a service that helps you build and train
machine learning models in aws which
among the following are referred here
the answer is sage maker it provides
every developer and data scientist with
the ability to build train and deploy
machine learning models quickly that's
what sagemaker does now for you to be
familiar with um you know the the
products i would recommend you to you
know simply go through the
product description you know there's one
page available on amazon that explains
all the products a quick neat and simple
now that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it a db service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with great confidence so the
answer is amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build the train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
id team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it amazon vpc amazon iam amazon
inspector amazon elastic load balancing
amazon vpc is a networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the uh
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on amazon's servers so
we have amazon game lift amazon green
grass amazon lumber yard amazon sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports pc xbox playstation
ios and android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on amazon servers the answer is amazon
lumberyard this lumber yard is an free
aaa gaming engine deeply integrated with
aws and twitch with full source this
lumbar yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create and highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer we have amazon work mail
we have amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost explorer now cost
explorer is an option in the amazon
console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the aws cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect at your
company and how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency
of all scalable resources so we have a
cloud formation as a service we have aws
aurora as a solution we have aws auto
scaling and amazon api gateway let's
read the question again you're the chief
cloud architect at your company how can
you automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is
autoscaling right that's a basic service
and solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust monitor
and ensure the maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources it
does that by automatically scaling the
environment to handle the inputs let's
look at this question as a database
administrator you will use a service
that is used to set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres sql which service are we
referring to amazon aurora amazon
elastic cache aws rds aws database
migration service amazon aurora is
amazon's flavor of the rds service and
elastic cache is is the caching service
provided by amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate the database
from on premises to the cloud and from
one a database flavor to another
database flavor amazon rds is the
service is the console is the service
it's the umbrella service that helps us
to set up manage databases like mysql
money db and postgres sql it's amazon
rts let's look at this last question a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages to onto google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service so the options are aws
cloudtrail aws config amazon chime aws
simple notification service it says a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages it's dealing with
pushing messages to google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is an message pushing uh service
and sqs is pulling similarly sns is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
aws full course i hope it was
informative and interesting if you have
any questions about the topics that were
covered in this video please ask away in
the comment section below our team will
help you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
you